[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates the
most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
it is round five
the palacio de santonia it is beautiful
it's a beautiful day it's a beautiful
building
fans enter through that amazing
entrance every single day as they file
in
to the live audience hall where our
spanish broadcast is it's where dina
bell and kaya does her interviews so
much beautiful art i don't even know how
they focus on the chess looking in that
room
but i know that there are some guys here
that are focused on the chess and those
are the players and uh those are not the
players but that is where they throw
down daily
here at the 2022 feed candidates with so
much at stake we are upstairs daily and
i am joined
every day so far by elmira scripchenko
and there's there's someone else here on
mira did you see this guy sneak in yes
finally you know
there is an epic friends episode you
know where rachel's neighbor is driving
her crazy by singing morning is here so
i will be singing literally every day
like robert is here
every day robert welcome in my man we uh
we tried to spell chess without you we
did the best we could but how excited
are you be here in madrid and uh help us
take this thing home the rest of the way
i'm pumped i've been watching the shows
i've been missing out being with you two
so i'm really thrilled to be in on the
action
well we we already have uh
the chat's going nuts for you so there's
been all kinds of comments we're we're
just here for the hess i don't know if
they forgot to see but i think they're
just here for the house maybe they just
got here uh we've got hype for hess
everybody everybody's hype and believe
it or not chat hess the chess i think
the the people most excited are indeed
me and elmira not that it hasn't been
great but it's going to be even better
now that we have robert and uh
well so much to get into but where i
want what i want to start is just taking
a look back at how we've gotten here
almira
yonda pomneshi
dominant yesterday but really his
tournament so far he he seems to be on
form
well jan is leading the tournament of
course but uh what is more important is
that he he has not shown sign of
weakness and has been patient during
these four rounds what do you think
robin
yeah i know i think elmira put it well
he's patient because sometimes jan he
can be a little bit hasty he'll make
moves quickly but as we saw yesterday
when he's not sure something he sits he
thinks and he plays great chess
he ha he has been playing great chess of
course uh we know that yesterday was
maybe some of his best chefs so far and
on that note
after after that victory versus only
rest of ferruccio he caught up with our
own dean of bell and kaya and here's how
that conversation went
jan congratulations on your win today uh
what would be your thoughts about how it
all happened
well it's
actually very very nice that ie
uh
i don't know i i was really confused
with the bishop c4 move because
as far as i know like after f5a4 there
is like long forced theory but
i believe this was like uh
quite popular like 10 years ago so this
line is not the
most i don't know
i would say a little a little bit out of
fashion probably i can normally black
plays other lines but this line is quite
quite nice but after bishop c4 i was
like quite puzzled so
maybe like if the game would take place
like 10 years ago i would be more into
into this topic so i just decided to go
for some
logical moves
uh just obviously his idea was d5 takes
and put knight on d6 so i decided just
to interrupt three f6 i'm not sure if
it's objectively good but i felt like
okay i just give up giveaway opponent
put my energy free and at least i
shouldn't be worse as my like
next five moves are very natural so like
knight g3 i don't know some prophylaxis
maybe bishop h6
so i believe bishop f1 was quite
unfortunate because okay he just
develops me and gives away
an important tempo but
i believe it should be analyzed with
with the engines
in general hadn't your opponent
blundered opponent before would he be
still suffering for a long time
well i'm not sure he just plundered it
because
somehow i felt he was quite desperate
but i obviously was expecting rook e5 or
something or k5 then probably i should
go for something like d6 and then it's
like a very curious position so perhaps
d6 if he takes on d6 uh
it's like two minor pieces per rook
and the pawn and uh
i mean the question if this pawns like
and e5 if we go somewhere okay black is
okay if they don't
i'm probably in time to take away like
okay all this b4 a3 i like develop my
king so
i mean in this rookie five this was
something i was expecting
but
you know other way was maybe to play uh
d4 instead of kingly 8 and just try to
play with an extra pawn but
maybe after bishop h6 i just go for an
id3 and i just try i i'm not even going
to take the exchange i'm trying to put
some pressure onto e5 so anyway it's
like it's very complex
you know
as we see him break down the variations
there elmira
you get a feel not just how well
prepared he was but how much
the feel that he has for those types of
positions the sharp positions how deeply
he sees those lines how well do you
think that that night or suits nepo
style well he's clearly in his element
you know he loves these positions and he
excels in them and i think also in the
yesterday's game he took of well a few
very good practical decisions which
earned him the victory yeah
style being well suited he's on form at
this point is it his tournament to lose
robert are there some other guys in the
standings that you think have something
to say about that yeah it's kind of a
fair question the way he's playing and
considering he won the previous
candidates but i do think that we have a
situation where it's way too early right
levon oronian who now plays for the us
formerly from armenia he's led in
canada's past he's never won a candidate
so it's way too early to make any kind
of declarations like that well yonda
panrishi leading the standings but as
robert said
likely way too early and it's uh fair to
say that the two guys from the united
states of america nipping at his heels
uh one of them plays yonder palmer sheet
today elmira well looking at the
standings you know i wanted to say that
two americans chasing a russian this
looks like a classic scenario of an
action movie you know only we are here
in madrid
and what i wanted to say that um i
really like how fabiano quran and hikaru
nakamura uh played in this tournament so
far fabiana hasn't lost the game
uh and hikaru well he lost only against
fabiano but their games are
have very high quality the average like
the quality of the their average move is
very high so this is very important
obviously in terms of the standings
there's no argument right now that
fabi's had the better tournament than
hikaru but let me just ask you
personally looking at both of these
these two fellow americans robert who
have you been more impressed with at
this point in madrid
i've been impressed in different ways
for fabiano he's as elmira said shown
that steady hand he won his first game
it hasn't always been smooth yesterday
against ding was a little bit shaky but
he played well when he needed to and for
his car with the resilience to rebound
from an opening loss so many players and
candidates pass they lose an early round
they're never in contention so for him
to immediately score victory over
rajabov that's huge and it shows that he
has the confidence necessary to win an
event like this
was it was it a steady hand or a or a
shakier position than we thought let's
see how fabiano felt about it he caught
up with dina bell and kaya after the
game holding that draw with black
against dingley wren
finished in the draw that was uh last
game for today uh
having
had to defend for a while
did you anyhow regret having given that
basic spawn after all
well well i wasn't sure because i was
already thought my position was rather
unpleasant
um i must have misplayed it at some
point maybe bishop a6 is not the most
accurate or maybe rook a8 because
i started to dislike my position and um
i sacked the pawn because i
yeah i just wanted some activity i
didn't want him to get the c file and
and i'll have to defend passively
um
and yeah it was quite lucky of course
that this end game is holding the rook
on game it seems to be holding at least
i think the last very important move was
rook a8 instead of rook c8 because rook
c8 was a bit more natural but then after
rook a1 i went upon but um
but his past a pawn is much stronger
than my c pawn
so yeah afterwards i didn't see anything
it's very close
very often i'm defending by one tempo
but it seems to hold
so overall you're satisfied with the
result
yeah considering that i i was in quite a
dangerous situation i'm quite happy on
another note uh how did you spend your
rest day
it was it was pretty boring it was uh
there wasn't much besides a bit of
preparation and mostly resting
and trying to conserve some energy
everyone's goal here of course to become
uh the world champion to win the
candidates uh was there or when was the
point in your career then you realized
that becoming a world champion was
actually quite possible
i don't know exactly the moment um
because i i
when i was growing up i mostly took
things as they came i i wasn't
let's say the youngest grandmaster in
history or
uh you know the highest rated uh junior
or anything so
i tried to make steady progress and
that's more or less what happened
um and i guess
at some point i adjusted to the fact
that i was among the
uh the top players in the world and i
and i had my chances in the candidates
um
maybe like the first time i played the
candidates and i got very very close i
felt like
it was a realistic possibility to
someday win the candidates and uh
and if you win the candidates then then
of course you have a chance at becoming
world champion
uh so maybe that i think that was the
year of 2016 i played the first time in
the candidates
it's interesting just to hear him talk
about 2016 the first time he played the
candidates but in his mind
he took things as they came he never
considered himself breaking records or
anything but the candidates in his eyes
is when he arrived i'm interesting well
it's actually this last question
and especially fabi's reply surprised me
shows how humble he is first of all
because when you consider chess players
career you know that this is the life
which is filled with sacrifices you
sacrifice almost everything to achieve
your goal to become the world champion
and that he considers like playing the
candidates the first candidates as a
turning point you know is uh was very
important for me yeah
i think humble's a good word it kind of
surprised me too but robert your
thoughts on
uh well
both is 2016 2018 and now here and can
bobby win this thing
yeah he definitely can in his 2016 he
didn't just have a chance he was tied
for first yeah with sergey kayaking
going into that final round the rules
were different back then the
head-to-head record mattered so he
needed to win with the black pieces he
was not able to do that he did not make
his way the world championship so of
course he has a chance he's extremely
well prepared we've seen even in the
quicker time controls he's shown
incredible skill as of late so why not
fobby he's showing everything it takes
to be a challenger for the world
championship
i want to talk about that point too and
and come back to it because we have some
time here the players are filling in
welcome everybody getting set for round
five but you know
the tiebreakers were different than they
are now if there is a tie at this event
there will be a tiebreaker match and
part of it is because fans have been
screaming for that sort of thing right
in 2016 those who don't remember the
story he was tied with karjakin but then
denied right so how much do you think
that's going into the players heads is
that do they feel a little more
confident because they know if they get
there that they they have a tiebreaker
an opportunity to to win it
robert i'm sorry i don't know i know he
put in me i realized i have two i have
two people
my bad i think somebody like this player
right here nakamura he'll feel very
confident in the shortest of time
controls right because he's been a
superstar online and over the board for
so many years now but i think just
having a chance knowing that you don't
if you're playing somebody you don't
need to win to leapfrog them in the
standing you just need to be able to tie
with them that's important because it
should always be duked out over the
board yep
well i think it's uh it's also logical
for the whole cycle because they go
through so much they pass to their
qualifications it's so difficult so
just to have some logical uh
continuation to play the tiebreak is i
think it's very important for the
players
yeah it makes sense and i i don't know
if i'm personally rooting for a
tiebreaker how exciting would that be
right uh all right well we're
we're gonna get set for the exciting
matchups of today before we talk about
whether we'll have an exciting
tiebreaker i think we have to go to the
top look at nakamura versus nepal
nasheed they've each dealt two fatal
blows to the other in their careers
against each other elmira how aggressive
will nakamura be with the white pieces
today oh well he will be very aggressive
because the tournament situation is
dictating you know for him he needs to
push with white uh to show his
preparation because he's fainting
someone who is also very well prepared
and actually their score does not refle
reflect the intensity of their games
they've been very wild yeah so i'm
actually looking forward to
to this match you and all the fans for
sure
all right well
the next matchup fabiano caruana
playing richard report has a good record
against richard robert your thoughts on
on how bobby will will be with the white
pieces report needs to survive the
opening i think the onus is more on him
than he is on fabi you know we see him
here every single day he's been in
hard-fought battles but in game one
against duda he could have been lost in
10 moves yeah and against dingley wren
he's fortunate he didn't lose that game
either so fabiano we know as being one
of the best prepared players on the
planet and here in round five against
report i mean he is going to show
something report better be ready for it
especially with the white pieces i think
you're really this is why you're very
good at what you do i i think you're
everyone take note of robert has his
foreshadowing there i i'm with you that
if report is still in the game by move
it'll be not to say he's going to be
losing but i think fobby's really going
to be showing something in the opening
here
he was playing some of the very peculiar
openings against five bend especially
with black i remember he played like on
the move uh understand knight f6 finally
pushed e5 and then knight g8 so and he
won this game actually so richard is not
afraid to be worse yeah
that's he may need to he may need that
lack of fear today we'll see what kind
of prep bobby brings to the table okay
let's take a look at some of the other
matchups here of course we have ferrugia
versus duda
that might be you know the biggest story
line of all that we're not talking about
that's a donut that duda has in terms of
his record against farouz and we know
that ali reza is going to be looking to
bounce back from his loss yesterday
robert and usually when you see a score
like that you think it's the younger
player with the disadvantage you think
that they've lost all their games when
they were like 13 years old against
someone slightly older no this is for
ruja in the last couple of years just
absolutely dominating this matchup so i
mean you look at it on paper you think
about this tournament the stakes will
alerza be able to put his best chest
forward after yesterday's game
and that remains to be seen but the
score speaks for itself yeah
our last matchup of course rajab versus
dingley wren
two to one in favor of the man from
china there are seven draws though a lot
a lot of games these two have played so
we'll see how aggressive or jabba tries
to java tries to be with the white
pieces or not but uh
uh amir i'll ask you while we're getting
set here for all the players to come in
how hard is it to sleep when you're a
young player after losing a game like he
did to yonda pandashi and how how
anxious do you think ferruja is to just
play that first move this morning well
it's actually very hard and uh
the most important here is that he's all
surrounded you know that he's here with
his family so he has someone to talk to
not only to prepare for his game you
know maybe even to forget about the
tournament you know to to go out to do
something like what any youngster would
do at his age you know and to come back
stronger well there he is
hope hopefully coming back stronger uh
for all those rooting for all the rest
of perusia we'll see what he does uh he
had a very impressive performance as
white versus sakura nakamura at least in
terms of the preparation does he bring
similar heat to young christoph duda we
will find out but it's time to find out
also
uh what everyone is waiting for just
kidding is who's dating gonna pick today
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with it i'm gonna
go with the american with the white
pieces to provide absolute drama to us
in this event by taking down yonda
pamashi going to faruga i'm also going
to take
ali reza faruja to bounce back from that
loss to yon napomnishi in style
tamar rajabov i think is uh not going to
take too many risks against dingley wren
with the white pieces and this game will
ultimately or end in peace and then you
have fabian or karwan and richard
rapport i'm going to say this is going
to be an incredibly exciting battle
maybe i'm going to shock you guys
three decisive games i'm i'm i'm saying
we'll have today
so you're going for the bloodbath
maybe maybe you think i did that just
for the drama but i actually really do
think that's going to happen what do you
think is going to happen use the command
guest or just type in the url directly
go.chess.com candidates guests it's not
just for kicks and giggles it is for
cash money which is as good as cash
money these days along with premium
membership prizes of course cast your
vote daily before the games begin we're
keeping track of who's playing along and
who's winning and i can't wait to start
showing you who who might be most likely
to win those cash prizes in our
community so
all right
what what is most likely to happen in
the first stage of things here
we go
in the cameras that's just likely to
happen people walking in front of
cameras before everybody settles down uh
we we have all four games getting set to
begin i'm not sure if we've had our
special guests make the honorary first
move yet but let's let's continue to
circle up on this
elmira ali rezafaruja again you said he
needs to do things that normal 19 year
olds do to forget about what exactly do
normal 19 year olds do in madrid well
actually when i said that i was thinking
that uh i don't really have
well an experience of doing so because i
myself was preparing at that age and
quite a lot so it's like i'm living
now you know basically so maybe go out
you know have a nice dinner and well
play a game of mario kart
play game of mario kart okay robert
what what opening do you think is uh
it's gonna be the spices for us here i'm
asking you to put your prediction hat
back on hikaru nakamura and yonder
palmishi or you i guess you already
foreshadowed your thoughts on what
fabiano might be able to do yeah i see
you nodding your head over there yeah go
ahead i was gonna say i think actually
if we speak specifically about hikaru
and yandapamishi we have spoken how
their games have been quite wild but
they've tamed their repertoires a lot
like hikaru is known as this crazy
tactician but if you look at his
classical chess a lot of it has been in
quieter openings so i do think it's
going to be 5 and against report and a
lot of the onus is on the player with
the black pieces to choose where they're
going to go and who knows what report's
going to choose right
well and like you said fabiano so well
prepared we already know that the only
win he had in this event came as the
white player versus hikaru nakamura
this is a
fun moment there ali reza suggests e4
again we don't know i think it's going
to be four do you think it's going to be
d4 not e4 oh okay so you think that it's
not a troll and that is indeed ali raz's
intention remember he played d4 against
sakura nakamura went to that dim zone so
that's why i was saying okay we'll see
moment of truth what will mr perugia
play indeed it is the king pons bobby
fisher's favorite and akara nakamura
follows suit
yeah no surprise from your car no
surprise from ali raza i think uh
anything but the king's pawn would have
been quite a shock for
us and i think their opponents as well
well e4 is on the board here we're uh
we'll we'll see what the other two games
are
you and i were talking about it i'm kind
of making a joke in our prep but i
actually do think we're going to see
some sort of anti-berlin i expect yon
kyan has already played e5 and hicario
quickly plays knight f3 oh okay nope
okay you you're you're
expecting this petrov i see you nodding
over there well actually i was not
expecting this because petrov is not uh
well a very often guest in jan's games
and well i remember he beat van gaal at
the last candidates it's a very nice
style but
uh i think that's why hikaru paused a
little bit because he was more expecting
the
sicilian
okay he paused knight f3 and
he was thinking is there a chance that
he's going to play petrov again
and here it is
yeah
well for those wondering um the dgt
boards are are struggling to relay the
moves sometimes that tech can be finicky
so that's not uh not just us but an
actual physical relay air i'm being told
from the tech downstairs so i will enjoy
a lot of wide shots of our players and
continue to talk about what we're seeing
without without getting too deep so so
that people don't feel lost but we see a
main line petrov ensues after knight
takes e4 jakarta responds d4 uh robert
your thoughts on on the line we have
ahead for us honestly my thoughts are
why are these chairs so tall
i mean
i'm sure you've discussed it on air
before but these are freakishly tall
chairs
um as it you know pertains to the actual
chess board uh so far nothing too
abnormal uh we'll see how the game
continues because uh there's already
some pressure in the center of the board
here right you can see that knight for
black hopped right in there and white
just put the bishop on d3 yeah now
there's various ways for white to
continue at this point including the
castle but where that knight on b1 goes
is the important question right well
young plays the knight to c6 line as you
can see we we're still in opening theory
very very popular opening theory a lot a
lot of different options a lot of
different results too but
hikaru
so
what are the sharpest lines you said
that the night the night's choice of
development is one of the key features
often white castles and goes for c4 in
some of these positions as well right
trying to undermine protection of the
pony here
yeah that's definitely a viable option
and knight to c3 at some moment can
actually be way spicier than it would
initially appears like well knight c3
just you know offers to trade up pieces
if you take on c3 you get these double
pawns but look at that bishop on d3 once
that knight clears out it's staring over
where the black king is likely to castle
to so it gives white the ability to
maybe launch an attack so you're saying
that despite the symmetrical structure
it doesn't mean we may not have
fireworks elmira in these positions well
first of all i agree with robert i like
this variation with knight c3
one key element to to understand this
position is this knight on e4 sometimes
the whole battle the whole strategical
battle goes around this night because c
even if you play c4 then black will play
bishop f5 and take with the
queen on d5 and try to maintain this
beautiful and strong piece on the e4
and knight c3
first of all gets rid of this knight and
there are some lines where you can even
sacrifice your bishop like if you play
an early bishop g4 then you have to
watch out
for this move bishop h7
yeah in some variations so i
hacaro is the first one to kind of pause
and perhaps
considering
the critical decision that you're both
alluding to of course both c4 and knight
to c3
have been played in this position many
many times as well as the move rook to
e1 and even the move you initially kind
of foreshadowed which is knight bd2 is
also a variation that has been played
hundreds of times so
okay
let's uh we'll come back to this one and
ultimately see whether it's prep or
whether uh hikaru was surprised by
yanupong machine is just kind of taking
a tamer line in the meantime we look at
that all four games are underway thanks
for being with us and making chess a
part of your day
i want to head over to uh
okay what's funny is
the the farouza duda game actually same
opening so i think that's the natural
call to action is to go see what's going
on with ali reza and his battle versus
the number one player from poland
because we have the same opening and
before we talk about any moves it is
deeply uncomfortable to have the same
opening as somebody else a few boards
away there's a famous example at the uh
grant switzerland island man where the
two boards next to each other had the
same exact game so they had to take two
of the players on one board and move
them to the other room because all four
players involved were like this just
feels weird i have an example of this as
well where i was playing game the u.s
championship and somebody a few boards
away was playing the same opening and
it's super uncomfortable because you
don't want to like be copying somebody
else but it may objectively be the best
choice so that you just like deviate to
something random just to avoid the
awkwardness is there a psychological
trap in that that you might be afraid to
play your preparation because you almost
don't want to reveal it to another game
that has nothing to do with your game
elmira well and you well you almost
you're almost tempted to not to make
your move until the move is done on
another board but where they're going to
put those players hopefully we are
having another variation on the board
but if that would be the case what's
what would be the decision of the
arbiter well quickly to show where the
deviation was just so even though it is
uncomfortable as both robert and elmira
shared
they already are at least in a little
different territory after bishop d3
young christophe chose to play the move
bishop f5 of course if you're just
tuning in yonder pandashi played the
move knight to c6 so at the very least
we do have a slightly different version
of whatever this mainline patch off is
going to be but the themes you both
highlighted right what's going to happen
with this knight on e4 how are we going
to try to undermine it are we offering a
trade with knight d2 or knight c3 or are
we building up the pressure first these
are the big decisions of how white can
approach these these positions this
already is a little bit of a
a more defensive line i guess in terms
of the pressure white could get on the
king side by young kristoff here with
this bishop f5 move and there's already
one huge difference in the move c4 which
we did see yon tsumi hikaru play against
yon then now black can take it so that's
another option
in black's arsenal because the 94 is
already defended so if you are going to
play c4 you very likely will turn rook
e1 first just to bring another attacker
against that knight on e4 but these
little differences actually
are very important at this level no it
makes a ton of sense that the
overprotection of the knight gives you
more flexibility but does that does that
backfire as white is forced to bring
more pressure here
okay it'll be fun to bring up these two
games and really compare the type of
position they get but before we go any
further let's talk about the other two
games as well we want to make sure we
touch on all of them so that the stage
is set and we know in the back of our
minds what type of game we might get
fabiano caruana playing the white pieces
versus richard report
we have a sicilian over there
now okay we're going to head to that
game the last time i got super excited
about fabiano playing the white side of
a sicilian his opponent young christoph
duda came super well prepared in that
game
fabi's on the clock what do you expect
reports preparation to be in the taimana
that's a really difficult question to
answer as good as young christophs in
the night or
i think that yanchez has proven that he
can come to the board exceptionally well
prepared report i think just doesn't
like opening theory that much he's the
type player he wants to play 960 fischer
random chess where the pieces are
scrambled to start with i mean they're
mirror images of each other but still
like he wants randomness chaos he
thrives in the chaos well elmira you
said you looked into their games and
obviously the record favors faviano but
that in recent times report has actually
done well here with fabiano thinking
what do you what do you think he's uh
considering to play well i wanted to say
that uh the taiman of is maybe a more
flexible opening than tonight or first
of all they're like the lines are not
so concrete
and that shoots uh richard very well on
the other hand uh i've looked through
well i went through their games and five
is recently started more with d4 or c4
and
here he is clearly surprised i think
maybe by the opening choice
because he well he has a few options
here so he can take on c6 he can play
bishop b3 so
i thought he's trying i think that he's
trying to guess also what would be
richard plan i love that point because
okay you know i want to see bishop e3 uh
i'm an english attack player and as i
said following fabio caruana's games
when you're someone who plays the white
side of the sicilian just becomes a
necessary part when you back when i was
playing real chess right i'm expecting
him to play bishop three but i think the
point mirror made robert i want to
elaborate on that because she and i were
talking about something a couple days
ago about half your preparation and
maybe your critical thinking in moments
like this
is is also the games you not not what
you not what games they played but
you're trying to guess what game have i
played that he's maybe thinking about
what game did i play that maybe he's
going to improve upon you think that's
why fabi has paused here before moving
forward so quickly absolutely the great
example this was just yesterday between
yonder pond machine and already is a
furuga right fuji plays as a rare bishop
c4 move or rare at the modern times so
what young apology thought well what is
he expecting from me and maybe i should
choose a different line where he knew
that he's no worse and has a good
initiative and that's exactly what jan
said so i think at this point it's not
like fabiano's unfamiliar with this
position five moves in but he's thinking
am i gonna play these bishop e3 lines
you can push your pawn to f4 in many
different variations do you want to push
that pawn to f4 sometimes you leave it a
little bit more flexible with the pawn
on f3 so it's not about the here and now
it's about trying to figure out what
path this game should go down that
favors his style more so than reports as
elmira said everyone of course knight
takes c6 also an option bishop b2 also
an option here even g3 is is not there
are so many different ways that white
can play on the white side of this timon
i'm still guessing fabi's going to go
for his famed and well-known english
attack not just because i'm biased and
hopeful to see it uh but okay time will
tell that favi really is taking his time
here on move seven you see he's seven
and a half minutes in so we'll back up
and take a look at the last game we
haven't checked on while while mr
carwana lets us know where that game is
going to go
rajabov has the white pieces versus
dingley wren a completely different type
of game than what we're seeing all three
other games have e4 on the board
almera we've got a
a d4 sort of double fee and kettle
catalan hybrid system here
yeah well it's a very solid opening for
white and well french you know do you
know how french would call the players
which are
uh at the bottom of the stainix they
would call them red lanterns okay that's
well actually coming from some ancient
times and
it's what does it mean to be a red
lantern it means that you're at the
bottom of the standings coming also
it's used in uh tour de france standings
and being last actually gives you well
brings you some honors so well it's not
the case in the chat
okay they are in last place but as we've
said we're only four rounds really in
here's round five robert your thoughts
on the chances that that either player
is is aggressive here they need a win to
get back in the standings i'm sorry it's
my first day here just seeing the
difference in their chairs
like that's huge where jumbo has this
monstrous chair and dingle ring has like
this really tiny chair that i would
definitely prefer to be in the chair
that he's in me too
we made the comment that he actually has
a better view to
to maybe the other boards um
yeah and well speaking of his board in
particular because i know that's the
question you asked me is i think
everything he's doing is sensible these
positions can be a bit frustrating on
this h1a8 diagonal we see that both
players have a bishop on the long
diagonal and there's already tension
from the c4 to d5 squares so right now
a common motif from white's perspective
is to move this knight away from f3
maybe to e5 think if you were going to
take me on e5 with your knight my pawn
gets to replace it start attacking some
of your pieces and putting pressure on
black center so i think that dingle ren
has no issues at the moment and for
rijaba here is a critical time to figure
out do i want to play this knight jump
which can give some trades or am i just
going to continue maneuvering optimizing
the placement of my pieces the other
thing i find sort of awkward about the
position over to you elmira is the
bishop on b4 that's exactly the point
that i wanted to bring i even wanted to
ask robert you know because normally or
traditionally in these lines white is
trying to ask like a question you know
what to do with this bishop on before
and play an early a3 so aft well the
last move uh queen is seven
maybe prevents white from doing so but
on the other hand i was looking at the
variation you can still play a3 you can
sacrifice play rookie one and row case
seven doesn't it make sense i was going
to show this too because i think that
it's one way the the other awkward thing
that can happen in this position i don't
know that it works is a move like
c5 in some positions has to be
considered right because
okay in this particular moment it
doesn't work and that's why the e-bell
bar likes black everybody because black
can take here and then have one a pawn
but there are all kinds of tricks in
these positions where if you weren't
able to take and white was able to take
on a3 with c5 that that bishop is
forever in a really awkward spot and as
you can see this was the idea i was
trying to illustrate and the computer
likes it so
again we all kind of took notice of that
bishop because normally you see it
pinning a knight on c3 or or already
back on e7 right so it's really curious
to see what java cooks up against that
that awkward piece i think it just gives
ding a little bit more breathing room
right because with the bishop on e7 it's
hard to connect those rooks except for
black playing this move c7 to c5 now
that's a move that you don't play
lightly in this kind of dynamic because
you're opening up the position in its
entirety the bishop on b2 is waiting for
that pawn d4 to go out of the way you
can be left with what's called a hanging
pawn structure where black is c5 and d5
pawns and white is just aiming all the
pieces around at them so um without
having to play c5 here black is a little
bit more flexible now the a3 question is
an important one it forces off some
trades and i think ding is perfectly
okay with that in this particular
position because it's a forcing sequence
like there's not much to think about
after a3 black has to keep taking white
will bring the rook actively up to a7 to
regain the pawn yep when all is said and
done black can defend that bishop on b7
and while white has control of the only
open file and that's important the
position remains closed so it feels like
black should be in an acceptable
situation there yeah all right well
despite the awkward start maybe maybe
black is uh is going to be just fine
with that visual before but let's back
up because we've now checked in on all
four games
take a deep breath everybody we have
action here
in round five
and
i know where your eyes are about to hit
yeah a lot shots i'm looking at
nakamura's position with napalm to she
but if you have something else we want
to go to oh fat
g4 oh my gosh okay so
let's let's quickly look at hicaro's
game because it's where we started and
he's about to move but everyone if you
look at that upper left corner card
juana's choice of g4 and then a quick
response of 97. are we even more
impressed by that from richard report we
might be getting the uh the spicy
english attack i was hoping we were
getting the last time fabiano was white
so okay hicario's position versus yonder
palmishi
we see this move knight to b4
chase the bishop on d3 back to e2 which
means hicary chose the c4 line if you
remember our our question was whether it
would be c4 knight c3 or rookie one we
got our answer and now after castles
we're still we're still in theory hikaru
checking up to the sky
trying to see where he put his post-its
when he came in late last night hid them
all around
the historic palacio just antonio i'm
kidding obviously
i think he actually did not expect this
the way he's using his clock right now
yeah is not somebody who's just
verifying their lines making sure that
they're not going to make a mistake i
really don't believe he had this mapped
out for today's game of course he's
looked at it before yeah but just the
sense i'm getting it carl actually moves
quickly in the opening when he's feeling
really good about it and for yon i mean
he clearly expected this he's blitzing
out his moves i think it's a good sign
for the tournament leader yeah
well knight c3 quickly met by bishop of
five again a very similar position
albeit without the c4 structure going
down between all the rest of peru and
young christophe duda for those just
tuning in that'll be an interesting
storyline for us today maybe not even
just for this game elmira maybe for
future games in the candidates and
that's one of the fun things that i
think fans can forget early is that
these openings they're playing is their
best prep because the most possible high
prize in chess is at stake right so what
ends up happening as the event goes on
as we continue to refer more and more to
what they played we see more things
revealed talk to talk to me a little bit
about what it means that they both
prepared petrov's meeting young
christoph duda and yonder palmishi to
play the candidates well first of all in
the modern
era like you cannot keep your opening
preparation for for a long time because
before all these ideas could be it could
be used like in many tournaments now as
you can see it could be used in one game
and then well
well you cannot use it like against a
next opponent because so it's very
important to um well to target your
opponent's preparation and to to be
precise and not surprise value is also
very important when you prepare so you
you have to weigh all of these open
options and to see like if this is the
day for example if i'm going to use it
or should i save it for the last round
for example so
but both of these players prepared the
petrov uh
i think it's um
it's a very interesting psychological
choice because for example
from jan's perspective he knows that
hikaru will push he wants to win you
know so
even if he doesn't play it's very this
opening very often it's uh probably a
very wise choice
young sister is well the picture is a
little bit different but he uh has
expressed that he's given an interview
and he said that the most important is
not to lose once again
so he's probably very happy with the
draw in this game so
so it's very different but what you're
explaining says why the petrov isn't a
good choice perhaps for both but uh
speaking of choices hikaru nakamura
seems to have made up his mind robert in
his head not just because of the move he
played a3 but he then
rattled off very quickly
capturing back and then quickly rookie
one for the first time really today
yonder palmishi is on the clock yeah and
i feel like i'm watching a krumnik onan
battle or something you know
they put so many games in this petrov
and what's the good news for white is
you have more pawns towards the center
these double sea pawns we typically
don't like the thought of double pawns
but here there's already a trade on the
table uh if white ever wants it and the
semi-open b-file can come in handy for
white but there's a bishop on f5 that's
really annoying
hikaru to this point because you can't
play rook b1 you'd just be dropping
material so that's one of those key
dynamics here white with the better pawn
structure despite the currently double
pawns and black with some activity you
see that all three of black's minor
pieces the knight and the two bishops
are developed but the pawn structure
favoring white the development favoring
black so white i would say is to be
slightly preferred but there's nothing
major happening yet in terms of somebody
who could potentially fall apart it
seems like it's a very stable position
for both good to highlight again as
robert said the double pawns are
currently an issue but a capture on d5
in some
cases followed immediately by an advance
on c4 so what kind of move do we think
so let's say yawn
is ready for that maybe moves the bishop
some something in the position to try to
continue to coordinate his pieces is
this immediately an idea for white to
take here and play c4 or do you have to
worry about the d-pawn being weak
yeah it's always an idea but here
specifically
black just teams up on it too easily but
yeah it's something you need to keep an
eye out for every single turn okay maybe
he should take on c4 sometimes you can
play knight e5
but what i wanted to show that uh very
often you should keep an eye on those
two pieces knight a5 and bishop f5
because rookie five you know is well
coming in some variations so with a
double attack and in fact we can easily
shut knight a5 bishop f1 and if you make
a careless move like h6 or you know well
c6 protects the knight so that's awesome
okay so
it's a good move something careless and
suddenly we see rook to e5 that's an
interesting way for the eval bar to
shoot up it doesn't look very obvious
but rookie five is a fork of the two
minor pieces in the middle of the board
a common tactic in these pet troughs the
reason i played c6 and i i was trying to
make a random move but it actually is a
good move because it defends the knight
and in some cases even prepares ideas
were one of the whole purposes of knight
a5 is to eventually maybe get a grip on
these light squares uh an opportunity
for the pieces to relocate so maybe you
can play c5 even in that position and
start attacking the center immediately
something like what c5 or c5 yeah
even even bishop d6 is common in some of
these positions just to kind of continue
to improve and it would stop rook e5 so
yeah black has a sort of
flexibility in choosing where that
bishop on e7 goes to d6 or f6 of course
after you've exchanged pont on c4 so the
position is still rich there's so much
life in a situation like this and yan
he's doing the right thing he's sitting
he's recalling preparation he's also
trying to make sure that you know when
he goes forward he's choosing the right
plan and that's the key at this high
level this elite level it's almost never
about this one move because if you made
them play bullet they would
pull just with one minute for the whole
game they probably make this move
instantly right but what they're making
sure is that six moves down the line
they're not getting in a passive
position where they feel like they have
no counter chances so that's what jan is
doing right now is ensuring that he is
able to get a position a few moves down
the road that he feels comfortable with
half of it being comfy too is is
even if objectively many positions are
possible they're almost close to the
same evaluation but you want to have one
that you feel good about playing on that
day right having a having a plan is
sometimes even more important than
whether you're a little bit worse in
some cases right elmira well i think
it's also very important it's a very
important factor to consider when you
prepare because
sometimes computer might as well give
like
a very nice evaluation but you don't
have the feel for the position and i
think that well i personally would
reject it right yeah no and of course we
know that fabi talked to us about that
in in uh at the world championship
coverage we talked about a few days
earlier that having a feel having a plan
even if you're a little worse is a place
where you can catch someone right where
they maybe thought the advantage was
bigger than it actually is so okay yawn
is thinking we're gonna back up and uh
take a look at all the games in progress
from my perspective
there is one game that i would like to
get back to it doesn't doesn't look like
more than two or three moves have been
played since we left it but i think we
have to set the tone for how sharp that
carwana versus report game is going to
be
fabiano chose to play that move g4 you
see that pawn is extended up the board
on the king side but i'm even more
impressed as we dive into this game here
with how quickly report responded so
this position
was on the board this is defined as a
time monoph
there's many options bishop e3 and f3 as
we were saying are things that fabian
has played and often those are moves you
play before you play the move he chose
with g4 robert but he is all in in the
most aggressive of attacks
knight ge7 bishop e3 and b5 is where we
stand
i'm surprised how much time bobby's
taking here though
yeah and
he is a player who plays especially
quickly when he's in his preparation so
it's clear that you know he was not
anticipating report to play this way now
the move that report responded to g4
with knight g to e7 just to point out
that the knight often wants to go to f6
here it's not a good idea because then
the pawn goes to g5 and just kicks it
away you spin another turn so the knight
e7 can replace the knight on c6 once
black captures in the center that's
another idea and whenever you pawns two
squares away like this e4 and g4 just
look at that square in between you can't
control it with a pawn so that knight at
some point can come over to g6 aiming
for f4 or h4 that seems a bit far down
the line but there is a possibility of
white's not looking out for the squares
whenever you push pawns you leave some
behind i like the point you made too
about the timeout of development is a
little different than other sicilians
one of the specific things is that like
in a night or for example this knight is
taking a completely different route into
the into the queen side the knight
replacing the other knight on c6 is a
very common thing in the timeline often
so
report perhaps has direct variations
like that in store
again i guess
i guess
if we go back to young kristoff due to
playing black and then i don't think
it's fabiano i was all excited young
chris stuff neutralized him here fabi's
taking a lot of time and fails to get
yet another advantage i don't know
that's going to happen but if he fails
to be happy with his prep on the white
side of a sicilian elmira what kind of
impact do you think that makes to uh
what him and his coach chuchulov are
cooking up back at the hotel
oh
actually i was thinking about the
position because uh the more fabiana
thinks the more it indicates that uh
first of all how important is to choose
here the right plan
i've played some of those positions with
black i know um well how difficult
because this is sort of you adapt with
black
first when fabiano played g4 because i
wanted actually to ask you a question
because
it could be a transposition could play
bishop b3 knight g7
g4 that's actually what he was thinking
about now so i think that he's uh trying
to well to
to find a way to
play out the nuances of this position
can he start with the h4 here so
um
i actually like white's position yeah
it's very unusual one of the main lines
we should show if you did choose g for
uh sorry bishop e3 instead of g4 is in
that move order often black's most
popular response is queen to c7 right
and so it's a really good point you're
making elmira that because of the g4 or
move order being met with a different
move now that you're transposing into
the standard development and again to
remind everybody this is you know a very
natural thing to do you want to get the
queen out get castled long at some point
obviously the bishop supports the center
we are getting a unique move order i
guess right so perhaps i should be
changing the way i'm reading favi taking
his time he really wants to make sure he
doesn't miss his chance to pounce on a
potentially incorrect move order from
report i would say that's a hundred
percent what's happening right now okay
because in the game against duda it was
it more concrete where he allowed a dude
to simplify to trade off the queens and
all these pieces and then you have too
much left to work with here we've talked
about that knight on e7 knight on c6
dynamic these superfluous knights
they're kind of doing a similar role the
97 what's its future maybe to replace
the knight c6 so one key idea for
fabiano in addition to h4 which elmira
mentioned can be played right now
perfectly good move is moving the knight
away from d4 yeah to to b3 first because
that eliminates the possibility for
report to free that 97 and the reason
that 97 doesn't want to be there is that
bishop on f8 is sitting home doing
nothing so
knight b3 is a standard type of move but
whether it's necessary is what fabio is
calculating he might just go forward
with h4 sending the pawns down the
king's side that's a really important
point because if the knights continue to
step on each other's toes like you said
it's not just it's not just a thing that
optically looks awkward right you say
that night it's like the old lady who
swallowed the fly the knight blocks the
bishop the bishop prevents you from
castling which means the rook isn't in
the game and it's a chain reaction of
problems for black so
i i mean the more you talk about that i
actually really like this idea of knight
to b3 which would be a unique that would
be a specific response to expose the
move order that he's seen h4 is saying
you know what maybe i could have done
something but i'm just going to go all
in but knight b3 would really be
challenging report's choice here elmira
well i agree with this i was also
looking at some ideas of how to develop
white species sometimes you put your
queen on e2 you cast long with the idea
of playing knight g5 when the knight
moves for example from a seven it's it's
a very important idea in this opening so
maybe he's trying to make everything
work at the same time so hopefully if
you're a fobby fan he doesn't take too
much time trying to be perfect here and
then he doesn't have enough time left
later on in the game but okay bobby's a
big boy he knows how to manage his clock
so we'll let him continue to think and
ultimately i feel like we painted a good
picture here of
what what maybe could happen so we'll
see what lines he chooses um can i just
say one quick thing about this yeah
let's do it before we go back black
would like to play the move d7 to d5 and
strike in the center but because
considering how underdeveloped report is
here you have to
be very careful because as soon as that
position opens black's situation might
just completely collapse so d5 is an
idea but don't be rushing this move b5
to b4 just to play d5 right that may be
too soon for your own good
maybe maybe losers alright we'll come
back and see which of these ideas
ultimately became the storyline of the
game
we look at all four games in progress
interesting rook a2 move over there from
hikaru nakamura on your lower right
not too much action
in the rajava of dingley brand game
since we left it
e3 was chosen instead of a3
i guess for ruja duda maybe deserves a
little bit of a call we can certainly
compare some contrasting differences
it's funny how they both came from
almost could have been the same game
they're not going to have the problem
that we described right they're not
going to have the problem of oh this is
too similar to another game look at
dude's clock
that's the biggest thing of the round
right now yeah his duda is just blitzing
out his moves and frozen now has spent
about half an hour and the position at
least to our eyes in the bottom left
should be completely playable for black
agreed town population us oh man first
time i've used that awkward joke
i'm just happy to be here he was happy
to be here welcome everybody to round
five of the 2022 feed a candidate's
tournament
and uh
but here we see a completely different
structure you know
when you play with whites
you always feel you have a slight
advantage
but black already exchanged the light
square bishop which is one very
important well strategic idea in this
opening
but somehow you have this
differences because white is in the
position of the e5 square whether black
cannot put a piece on on the e4 so
that's probably one of the well key
elements which gives white like a small
advantage a long-term advantage yep
it's interesting because i think robert
pointed out the biggest
the biggest thing that stands out is
definitely on the clock although
you wonder what ali reza's you know
mapping out in his head because the
position is objectively still pretty
good for him right there's a lot of
options here so it's not like he has
anything to be worried about but not his
style ali raza he's an electric player
yeah he doesn't want to grind somebody
down from a symmetrical pawn structure
where he has control of the only open
file for the time being like there's a
lot of life in this position and if you
told me that report was playing this i'd
say no he'd probably be pretty happy
here right but frugal doesn't want this
he didn't want to see a petrov that just
is you know seen just one pawn and one
minor piece traded and now they're
fighting for control for you know these
squares you know kramnik somebody like
that go ahead throw them into this game
and i'm saying they're happy but for
ruja he just has a more dynamic style
and i feel like he's just not getting
the positions that he really wants well
the question is is that part of the plan
we know that he didn't play a lot in
2022 we know the style we've seen from
ferruccia that got him here right but
obviously he's been working on something
over that time right so my question is
is this going to continue to be
something that we see in the candidates
and trying some new openings new
positions elmira and maybe was that part
of the plan
well this
this is certainly part of the plan
because what i think that
uh on
this high level on the elite level you
have to
work on your universal style so you can
play any types of the position so maybe
what he was doing is like just for
example taking this uh position and
playing it against a very strong
opponent in a training session like
until he like he feels like every
possible nuance
so maybe just like you should work on
your own weaknesses that's what i do
and i of course agree with them that's
100 what the players do but look at the
clock consumption duda is just right at
home he's like okay i'm going to be
slightly worse out of a petrov that's
normal to me it just feels like he's
playing into duda's hands more so than
his own just based on kind of all
elements the tournament the position and
the clock usage i just
you know of course he's a great player
he's been working hard and he may in
fact win this game
but i just i don't know something is off
for me about the openings he's getting
i don't disagree and the only question
is whether it's too early for us to make
a judgment on that and it was a plan or
whether it's just a couple of games
right coincidence because i want to
point out a stat before we get to a fun
thing here part of it might be that he
wasn't expecting dude to play e5 dude
has only played e5 about 25
of the times against he faces e4 so
maybe ferruja came to the board prepared
for something different maybe a sicilian
like like dude who played against
caruana so maybe that's one of the
reasons ollie rose is uncomfortable but
while we watch and wait we're going to
listen in to something nepo had to say
about ali reza when dina caught up with
him yesterday following the match with
the teenage sensation
many people were putting high
expectations on anireza how would you
rate his performance so far yet only for
rounds but still
i believe he had like three games with
black out of four so it's that's never
easy
and uh
i mean there are lots of examples when
you start like poorly but then okay you
find your your player you find i mean
the wind blows uh
to your sales and you you start scoring
a lot so i guess it's like it's too
early to to judge
it's interesting right too early to
judge and that's kind of what i was
saying about the opening soon maybe
maybe he's prepared some different type
of positions and he's trying to continue
to grow and reinvent himself as a player
maybe maybe this slow start has to do
with that or maybe it's all just
coincidence at this point too early to
judge what do you think robert
of course i
listen to what a player like yonder
palms has to say and i take that very
seriously and it's a fair point it's an
argument to be made i just you know i
can't get over what we're seeing here
where he's down 30 minutes on the clock
it doesn't feel at home and part of that
could just be because he lost the game
yesterday we were talking earlier about
can you sleep after a tough loss like
that and for duda he understands how
important is to not lose which is
probably why he chose the petrol
symmetrical line against uh farouja
whereas he didn't choose against karwana
because karwana likes bullying people
from positions where he's you know
slightly better and he's gonna increase
his advantage incrementally so i think
that duda is doing a great job of
picking his openings thus far and i
think that you know he may have have
caught already off guard you use the
stats right 25 percent of the time he's
playing e5 he has played the pestroff
before for sure you know this particular
landing against carlson yeah
so you know that frozen looked at it but
maybe for this particular game he was
hoping for a bit more of a fight with
sicilian okay
bishop d2 has been played
from ali raza after a bit of a think
yeah well because usually you would put
your bishop on f4 in this line yes so uh
we should understand what are the
differences
do you want to look at the bishop before
yes just one second yeah yeah okay so
bishop d2 here chosen from ali reza
bishop before
the uh
most
i mean optically it looks like the more
natural square for the bishop
so ah now i understand if black would
wants to play knight c7 in 96 then he
probably uh
felt that
you know the bishop would be soon under
attack so maybe this is the difference
yeah and those those subtleties they do
make all the difference at this level
we're putting your bishop on maybe a
less active square but one where black's
plan doesn't include attacking that
bishop could be a tempo that is
necessary to leave white with the edge
so i think bishop v2
completely reasonable takes away the b4
square which i think is what a lot of
people were probably initially thinking
when they saw the game bishop d2 uh oh
night before that looked annoying let's
deal with it but no as elmira said it's
actually deeper than that the knight
doesn't want to go to b4 because once it
goes to b4 the queen moves and then you
just kick the knight away on the next
turn so i think one move threats are
tempting but that's not what duda is
looking for at this point in the game
so very uh like
thematical um
strategical idea in this opening after
playing bishop d2 is to double your
rooks on the e-file
uh
i'm pretty sure that elias zaffiroza
knows everything here
so he's trying to
find
a more precise move forwarder
chat paying attention and doing their
homework as well we love that when we
have an active chat pointing out the
amount of time student has played this
line as black maybe only plays e5 25 of
the time but he's already played this
line he threw a game against carlson
he's also won
uh games in this line as black so
i i agree with what you said young
christoph has
has been on point with his choices from
a practical perspective and remember he
was also on point as white almost won
game one against richard reports so we
haven't talked too much i guess or added
too much hype about the fact that maybe
he's someone whose score could be
different at this point played very well
so far yeah no he's been steady very
steady throughout sure there have been
some big adventures that he let slip and
you know sometimes you get an
uncomfortable position you have to
defend accurately but dude has been
playing well in this game i really like
what he's done but he does need to be
accurate right now because another idea
that white has we keep talking about how
the position is symmetrical let's not
count out the idea for white of playing
pawn to b3 and then pawn to c4 we saw
hikara play c4 and then white gets to
strike at the center so the side that
controls the pawn brakes is off on the
side with the advantage and here b3 to
c4 is a pawn break available to white
black doesn't have a similar pawn break
so he instead retreats his knight to c7
he'll later play rook to e8 get ready to
swap brooks down the only open file and
he's hoping that there's just not enough
firepower remaining after these trades
for white to
attack anything yep
well he plays knight c7 as we said he's
been
on point with the openings he's chosen
to play and that's one of the reasons
he's right in the middle of the thick of
things as we see there we talked about
hikaru nakamura being in third behind
faba carolina really he was tied with
players like young christophe duda
and richard rapport so
so jkd
and all these players are just to win
away from legion
yes every single one of these players is
a win away from the leader uh of course
what will the leader do in his game uh
versus hikaru nakamura remains to be
seen but
for rujak what other plans are available
here so b3 c4 seems like the most
natural strategic plan putting the
knight immediately on e5 has to also be
considered the moment you put the piece
there
black already has to start asking
questions how long can i put up with
that pesky pony but if f6 is played you
retreat the night happily and maybe you
poke some new weaknesses open so
farouza again he's taking his time
perhaps that
goes to the practical wit of young
christophe duda surprised him in the
opening but still this position plenty
of life for for rouge to try to get an
edge well he can play rookie 2 once
again and rook ae1
to take over the control
to take the control over the e file but
then
knight d6 and knight c7 they protect the
eight square like very well so you can
trade rooks
play bishop f6 and rookie eight
robert i want to go back to something
you were saying about farouz's uh
i guess his style his choice if we're
saying this is not the position that he
feels super comfortable with and then
we're going to look look ahead real
quick about his matchups coming up
is it something that he should be
worried about and thinking about he has
white here he's going to get white
against corona next but let's say he
does fail to get an edge in this game
maybe quickly and and gets nothing more
than a draw are you looking to go back
to some more aggressive openings
immediately in your next round well as
we look at the pairings here i mean
that's a nightmare stretch for alares in
particular black against dingley wren
you want to face someone who's got a boa
constrictor style who's going to say
you're not getting any tactics against
me and then of course in round six he
gets the white piece against fabiano
who's notoriously a very difficult
opponent for him and we see the record
there 500 has beaten him twice never
lost and father always shows a high
level of preparation and just has a
consistency to him that he's not
particularly blunder prone so
i think that elrisa has been circling
this game especially after yesterday's
loss looking for some way to play for an
engine if you want one way there is this
move h4
and i know a lot of people say what are
you doing your king's over there how are
you throwing this part you're losing a
pawn directly but h4 is actually a
common idea where if you can distract
black's pieces even at the cost of a
pawn it could be worth it to get white's
initiative rolling i think it's an idea
we're going to have to look at what
we're analyzing next but i want to
highlight you pointed out fabiano's good
record against caruana of course many
fans will remember farouza's only loss
in the tournament that got him to the
candidates at the grand swiss was a loss
to fabiano caruana who actually got
second in that event which also
qualified fabi for the event we now have
so yeah definitely some story line there
we're going to be talking a lot about
tomorrow when ali reza froza plays
fabiano caroline that'll be the first
time they've met actually since
the grand swiss no they played one time
in um the grand chess tour event uh it's
rapid though no it was classical in uh
the superb term in romania oh okay okay
yeah and they drew but five nights at
the white pieces again in that game five
minute was a bit better okay okay but
now at least alareza gets the white
pieces you know he keeps getting the the
second move against fabiano now he gets
white so that's a huge difference of
course okay
well a lot of storyline ahead on that
but let's let's talk a little bit about
this h4 move robert just said because if
ferugia indeed does feel the pressure to
get the win
like robert foreshadowed maybe he finds
h4 and this is okay first thing you got
to prove to me is why can't black just
take it
right so that's that's something that
i'm thinking about as well you take on
h4 you have to you gave away the pawn
you lose the bishop for it and it's like
bishop b4 so all of a sudden the natural
way defend rook to d8 loses material
because i take your knight on d6 and
fork you on f5 so that's very clearly
good for white that would be a big
mistake so that means that after bishop
b4 you need to put your knight on an
awkward square the c7 knight and e8's
the only available square because if you
go forward you get kicked out
and then you lose a piece and that means
bringing the queen back and so all of a
sudden white you know seizing the
initiative here getting the pieces
active and this is something that maybe
i can get behind perhaps there's a queen
f6 might be more accurate than queen of
d8 just to keep the f5 square under
black's control but it's starting just
to look i don't know it's the fact that
knight h5 is a very short right away
well
even if you playing queen eight gosh
do you see that tactic by the way
knight takes g7 it's enough it's got to
be queen g3 oh knight
queen first there's knight five so you
take yeah just take on g7 queen g3 no
matter where the black queen went and
you lose the knight on d6 back and
that's game over but even if black sees
queen d8 elmira one of the funny what
does it say about a position where
you're down a pawn
but the computer
likes you right so talk a little bit
about the big picture macro features of
the physician as to why the computer
even would say that white is better at a
pond sac like this well first of all
the interview which was given by hikaru
comes to my mind where he explained us
that recently the
computers have changed
our
way of seeing those positions especially
by proposing the move h4 in every
possible way you know so here is the
perfect illustration of this thought and
it's very important to understand that
players are looking now for a long-term
initiative than like a small advantage
and they're
specifically looking for those positions
while they're analyzing you know
the openings and while preparing against
also a specific opponent but
here i really love this idea
i like it too and i love what you're
saying about it's changing the way
they're preparing long-term initiatives
things like pressure on the dark squares
outside ideas of tactics that could
occur against the king opportunities
really for your opponent to go wrong
that's what they want especially because
so many people are so well prepared they
all have the same tools so you really
are just trying to create chances where
your opponent might misstep but okay now
that we've said all of that
and especially how the players were
preparing before you know they were
stopping their preparation like at the
moment where like the computer would or
they would feel that there is like plus
sequel you know slight advantage and
they were fine with it right
well now they're going for very
complicated positions and they're very
happy with those
no i like it although i was going to say
that
despite all of our hopes about seeing
something like that unfair i see robert
smiley because we're like oh darn he
went for he played v3 already it's
completely sensible i think that we need
to point out that after the h4 okay
black was not obligated to take that
okay that's fair i was i guess it was my
fault that we got into that bad position
no i mean that's the question that needs
to be asked can i play h4 the answer is
clearly yes it says that white remains
uh with a slight pull so we like that
but yeah black should not take is the
verdict on that one instead otherwise it
went for uh plan a b3 and rookie eight
and now he can continue with pawn to c4
start gaining some space and creating
tension in the middle of the board all
right
well looks like we'll have a bit of
positional tension but let's watch out
for this h4 idea because even though it
wasn't played when robert first
suggested i have a feeling we might be
seeing that that theme at some point in
this game but that's also very
thematical and a battery of years
because when the bishop retreats to f8
very often your only plan in this
position is to play h4 h5 h6 and to
create some weaknesses
so i'm pretty sure that uh he's going to
use it later in the game
no and i agree on here it's a thematic
idea it's an alpha zero idea we keep
calling it that right it's because even
if the pawn isn't taken h5 h6
maybe in that particular case you use
the g5 square depending on how black is
dealing with it so
all right ali reza is thinking about it
let's back up and check in where all
four other games are
because uh
because we have liftoff here in round
five we're to have a lot of interesting
chess oh my gosh that car won a report
game it's going to give me everything
that i desire well okay the yonder
palmer game is what i was waiting for
but uh it doesn't have everything the
body needs but it has a lot right there
and that car wonderful 4k um
okay the uh hikaru nakamura battle with
yondapan rishi looks like it's slowing
down a little bit
um with with yon having taken a deep
think so that's interesting
and uh job often dingley wren following
robert's plan of playing c5 as black
gonna be an interesting battle of the
fiance bishop so all right i think the
table is now set out we've got our
silverware in order you know how you do
that thing with the silverware like
smaller to bigger or whatever because
you start with appetizers salad and so
we're getting closer to the main course
here but before we dive in to all that
these games are going to give us in
round five we're going to take our very
very first break
but before we do i want to remind you
that friday we have an amazing
doubleheader first it's the women's
speeches championship it continues the
2021 quarterfinalist
katarina lagno takes on the qualifier
vantika agrawal this is this has been
something we talked about yesterday i'm
really excited for this clash tune in on
friday at 5 am pacific time for that one
but as we said it's a double header
after that we have the next
semi-final
one of the commentators in this room
already lost the other semi-final
shmarnit eric rosen anyway but the
second semi-final for our i'm not a gm
championship goes down with canty taking
on lawrence trent again the winner will
take on eric rosen in the title match
make sure to tune in on friday june 24th
at 9 00 a.m right after the wscc match
we just previewed so
okay
so much ahead all the games are in
progress hikaru nakamura is trying not
to fall asleep we hope he doesn't fall
asleep while we're at the break but
don't go in here because the round five
of the 2022 feed a candidate continues
in just a moment
this kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
i was told by the locals of a chess
school and there's people out there we
should go we should go while they're
opening the door for us let's go let's
go school of chess don't cost nothing
judging traffic
a game as old as chess itself
and half as dangerous
this is the most dangerous part of our
career
game on gotta give the people what they
want
game one keep going don't stop
so we tell them that chess education
gives you better life decisions as we
get hit by a car crossing the road in a
non-crosswalk
at 5 20.
520 what's home we got
of all the places we could film in spain
the fact there's going to be a class and
we're here
we can film other stuff but we got to
stay for that yeah i agree people say
crashing weddings is fun we're crushing
a school
if the chest is not taking place
check it out flamenco dancing huh you
think of what i'm thinking you want to
be my partner
are there partners in flamenco we're not
even graffitiing a building we're like
trying to help local kids and yet
somehow i see this going poorly
this this would be like you know
being at the public courts and like
federer comes
but we are walking quickly i heard the
word sigiridad and i was like no
security god might leave me not
yeah but we gotta go you know they
obviously kind of knew that we were
you know we kind of knew we were a big
deal they opened up their arms and so
this is why when we were kids our dad
told us to say open sesame yeah which
gets you into the building but if you
say open ahadres you do not get it you
don't get into the village no no it's
open sesame you got to remember that dad
was right i play a lot of it yes i love
it you could have gotten us into the
building you play on chess.com yes of
course do you know who that
you don't is to no you just need to use
the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a
peccatina there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain
say i met danny and danny said he would
i could get a diamond membership okay
all right i love your work i love your
work thank you bye-bye so it's funny
danny we were sold a bill of goods they
flew us here to do real work yeah and i
realized our entire job is just to go
around getting out of the stickers
honestly let's oh well there you go um i
can't even do that well
[Music]
do
welcome back chess super chess in madrid
this is giant chess i could throw down
some bullet on that giant chessboard
there is big chess in el bertiro park
we've shown many different angles of
that beautiful
location now we see the beautiful
location the playing hall
in palacio de antonio
a lot of beautiful games in progress a
lot of beautiful faces
a lot of beautiful people
here in the studio
my my lovely co-host
um we should offer him like you know a
dictionary of synonyms yes yeah
i ran out of words besides beautiful
don't judge me
we're just gonna go no i'm kidding
that was intentional
but seriously no we we the the three of
us
uh checked on a lot of stats at the
break some interesting knowledge we have
about nakamura's game he has had this
position successfully so earlier in his
career
we're going to talk about that a little
bit
father carwana's game he did choose the
knight to be three line so trying to
expose the specific move order by
richard report and now let's report
who's finally on the clock really for
the first time
lots of interesting chess ahead
i think uh
oh i'll let one of you choose where you
want to go where do you want to start
mirror the choice is yours oh the truth
is mine thank you then i wanted to have
a quick look at caruana report okay uh
this is such an unusual position that's
why like i feel that i'm still a chess
player you know
so i want to understand
all the ideas in this position uh
fabiano just played queen d2 yep and
went for a quick walk so uh how much
time did he spend on this move like
especially on this sequence
spent five minutes on queen d2 we see
that report is
just about 12 minutes in before choosing
his ninth okay and knight b3 then
because there's a sequence of move
knight b3 and queens
yeah bobby took 17 minutes before
playing knight to b3 so that's
interesting but if you're just tuning in
uh robert kind of called that that might
be what probably was thing i was getting
a little bit you know i'll be honest i
was getting a little nervous
i wasn't sure what bobby was thinking
about robert calmed me down knowing that
his good friend was actually just trying
to be precise so we're gonna we're gonna
analyze exactly what he was trying to be
precise about because now that it's on
the board it's even more instructive the
move order that was played here
was specifically designed to expose the
knights on c6 and e7 so if we back up
everyone right here
instead of the traditional move order
bishop e3
favi chose g4 first one of the key
things about g4 to summarize robert's
point is this aggressive move order
makes it a little more scary to play
knight f6 whereas in the main lines for
example if white plays bishop e3 you
often see queen to c7 and eventually
knight f6 so just this subtle change by
favi with g4
now makes reports
think twice instead of putting the
knight on f6 goes to e7 but when the
knights are standing next to each other
they're sort of stepping on each other's
toes right like like a couple of
brothers wrestling for a pair of socks i
don't know why i made that analogy but
they're like hey it's mine no it's mine
i want the square give it to me because
of that bobby actually had the
opportunity to take away the option to
trade the night where report was going
to back up the c6 square on the next
move with knight to b3 and then as soon
as you suggested that move robert i
really liked it and we see how desperate
report is to get rid of that knight he
now brings it to a5 and queen to d2 on
the board this is where we stand
i uh
i guess report is not sure how to
continue here you definitely don't
really want to take on b3 and allow
white to take with the 8 pawn that's a
bad idea really bad idea
it's playable but it clearly gives white
the upper hand in that position because
the viking is not castled so the rook on
a1 stares at this pawn on a6 and threw
that pawn to the rook on eight there
will be tactics available if black's not
looking out for them and so in this
position we have the eval bar on screen
i don't really think it matters because
the position is so unclear yeah there's
uh so many different possibilities at
this point and
right now for black do you play bishop
to b7 you start in that direction or do
you start on the other side of the board
with knight to g6 to free up the dark
square bishop not an easy question to
answer and right now report is spending
time wisely because they're completely
different plans and white is ready to
castle queenside use that semi-open
d-file maybe barrel down it and cause
black some serious problems and i guess
the big question is where's black's king
going in this game yeah elmira you the
answer to that well i really like
robert's explanation especially that i'm
looking at this position from the taiman
of players perspective
uh i was looking at knight g6 but
in i wanted to um to take control of the
dark squares you know but then i was
really concerned with move four
which is very concrete once again and i
wanted to know what would be a black
response to that
so knight g6 and simply f4
queen h4 bishop f2 and queen g4 can i
take those pawns let's analyze it okay
so knight to g6
f4 right away or castle's loan first no
i wanted to try a four right away just
okay just uh and the question is the
knight a5 is loose so bishop f2 uh just
pair the thread and you take g4 have fun
with that yeah you just come back yeah
and even if you take on b3 which is
actually possible here because the
queen's under attack you take on g4 but
that rook on a being loose is a huge
problem knight takes b5 have fun with my
king side pawns black is woefully
underdeveloped as you're pointing out
there's a huge threat on c7 this is
miserable for black okay
that's why i wanted to delay castle a
little bit and to see if there's way to
exploit this move immediately so
no it seems
again i think robert you did a uh did a
service to the chat so they don't stress
too much about this email bar this is
the email bar in the middle because the
computer has no belief in idea what's
going on right it's just as lost as the
rest of us and it's one of those
positions where you know oftentimes you
give the players just the eval that's a
huge hint you tell the players oh it's
zeros they're like uh why what do you
know what do i do here so you know there
are moments in a game where even if a a
player just got that one time hint it's
this is the evaluation that changes the
entire game here you give them that hint
of zeros or plus point three or whatever
it is just so there's no clarity
whatsoever like is white gonna play
amir's f4 which i really like is white
gonna play for h4 which you talked about
earlier and it looks like
wow report takes on b3 you see the eval
bar sliding up and the reason why after
a takes b3 back i'm pretty sure five is
gonna capture that way uh the b5 pawn is
threatened so bishop b7 is kind of a
forced move which is a useful move
regardless and then white can continue
with bishop to g2
and i mean look at the position d5 is
firmly under white's control if you ever
make that move you'll be left with an
isolated pawn that's a problem and as i
mentioned a long time ago b4 is kind of
a cure for that but then that b4 pawn's
at target and the knight just walks into
those weak dark squares and yeah that's
another issue that black has to contend
with
how surprised are you to see nate takes
v3 on me right i feel like we were just
talking about how that's exactly the
move that black isn't going to play well
but this
explains why even computer hesitates
because
should you stick with the d5 plan then
play bishop b7 and do something about it
or choose the knight g6 plan or choose
something else you cannot play d6 here
anymore because the spawn is going to be
weak forever
you can actually still get in
the vote chess prizes before richard
report moves remember move 10 is the
benchmark so that was moved in so this
was a purposeful thing uh a good
reminder to everyone that if you're not
playing
along with us you should be before every
game you can vote on the results of the
game for a chance to win cash prizes and
that was your last chance to do so which
is very rare robert that there's so much
maybe revealed by move 10 that players
can actually vote with some sorry
members can actually vote with some
informational advantages yeah no this
this is a ton of information unlike the
symmetrical petrol we're seeing in the
ferruja duda game here like the contours
are laid out and as we look at this
position another big moment for fabiano
and we keep saying that but it's not
just because we like hyping up a moment
i especially don't like doing that you
know if it's not true guilty of that i
do
but right now there is a big question
for fabiano is do i play bishop to g2
which looks like a pretty natural square
and the reason why i'm i'm saying do i
make that move am i actually afraid of
d5 i mentioned that earlier like d5 is a
pawn break that black
would like in theory but in practice it
may be too soon because look at black's
development the bishop on that fate
stuck behind the knight the rook on h8
rook and eight black is not with
harmonious pieces the way that whites
are set white's pawns perhaps a bit
overextended as the game continues but
for now they're taking control of vital
squares and i really like the look of
this from fabiano's perspective
the question is is there anything really
better than bishop g2 i mean
like would you castle long still even
though your rook has been opened and and
just continue with the straight up
traditional english attack we know i
would but that you know it's a
rhetorical question for me but still a
good idea absolutely it looks like a
very natural way to continue
well but why i like bishop g2 more than
maybe f3 i i don't know yet like what to
do here i thought he's played it he
played history
bishop i was so sorry i was afraid that
i was going to make a point and he is
going to prove me wrong is that what
robert said that it controls the d d5
square once again so you cannot make
this breakthrough in the center just
push easily
well and i would argue too that if you
are going to go for the f4 plane that
you like you've saved a tempo right so i
i'm with you that multiple reasons i
like bishop g2 better increases the
pressure on blacks break and if we're
all in
on the pawn storm
at this point why waste f3 right in the
english attack you play f3 to reinforce
and often support g4 why because there's
a knight on f6 so without f3 sometimes
you can't play g4 it gets taken but in
this particular position i think it
makes a ton of sense to leave the f pawn
take advantage of the rule that pollens
move twice
and then uh see where the attack builds
too so i would say the one hesitation i
had was knight g6 was a plan we were
looking at from black's perspective now
knight g6 aiming for h4 there is a
target but
it's just too many moves with the same
pieces in fact just if we go like two
moves down like knight g6 yeah white
castle's queen side yeah you play knight
h4 you are attacking my bishop that
isn't particularly friendly but as you
were showing bishop g5 and once black
plays bishop e7 i can take that knight
on h4 like
yes you have this bishop pair but what
white has is a monstrous control of the
board the d file is whites so if you
castle you may already lose a pawn
directly on d7 if you
want to play d5 well
your wants are never going to be
actualized because what all of white's
pieces are staring at that square and
what's your dark square bishop doing the
answer is not particularly much for the
time being so i really feel like fabiano
has firm control and report now the
burden of this game is on his shoulders
squarely because it's not even easy to
figure out the next three moves
okay i like it maybe that's why report
is leaning in here he agrees with you
rob he's like i hear you robert now i'm
gonna work hard and try to figure this
one out all right we're working hard
we hope you're hardly working chat as
we're making through making our way
through all four games in round five
let's back up and take a look at where
the other positions stand uh at this
current juncture i think we need to head
over to nakamura and napomnishi to talk
a little bit
about uh the research we uncovered at
the break
because while we were
we were we were kind of thinking that
hey carl's time management the way he
was looking at it that this you know was
a position that was uncomfortable for
him maybe you were both half right and
half wrong robert maybe he was surprised
by napoleon's approach but as we learned
this move rook a2 is actually not a very
popular move but we know it's prep
because he carl used this move at the
2016 u.s championship to beat baruch
unicobian as white so he has played this
position before successfully so your
thoughts on that updated information
it's good from the point of view that he
has experience it's bad because that
means that yon could expect exactly this
yeah so right now the players they're
about even the clock i'm not too worried
about them from a time management
perspective but the eval bar hovering at
zeroes yonder palms she undoubtedly has
researched that exact game yeah and now
that he's here and that rook's an a2 you
have to wonder where is the coordination
from white's pieces coming from because
rook a2 to me indicates that that rook
probably would like to go to e2 at some
point and control the open file that
takes a lot of time going to the b file
it's a one move threat we were talking
about the semi-open file is good for a
rook but that pawn on b7 is easily
defended so i think
right now hikar is like where am i gonna
get an edge from i'm i'm okay with my
position
but
i'm not loving it
i'm here again oh we're about to see a
move but we've talked before about how
the preparation is both to expose your
opponent's weaknesses but also try to
anticipate
your own weaknesses and how they might
try to expose it
what what chances you give that yawn
really knew that hikaru would go back
for this old position
uh not only he knew but i think that uh
his seconds felt that
hikaru
repeats the positions
which he feels well and especially if
the well if you've won this game you
know he's feeling rather confident
so they're probably targeting they were
targeting this line
um
okay the position is equal but i i think
that it's still full of
play and it's
it remains complex because of the very
strange pawn structure
maybe you can also because
in these positions you want to bring
your rook to the b file so maybe if
rk2 is looking very awkward so maybe you
can play with b2 because uh in many
variations which are
uh we analyzed in petrol if you play
rook b1 rook b5 at some point you know
so maybe this is also possible by
playing rook b2 rook b5 so let's say you
take on d5
looks very strange but queen d5 and
rogue b2
you're coming to b5 yes i like that idea
yeah and black plays b6 you're also
attacking the pawn down the line and
after rook b5 i guess the black queen
can just slide right back to d7 and keep
everything defended and i'm worried
about the long-term prospects of this
position from white's perspective
early in the game when you have an extra
pawn in the center that's a really good
thing but white has an isolated pawn on
a3 and i can envision a near future
where pieces start getting traded off
and then if the rooks come off the
e-file yeah and many of these pieces are
gone then white is saddled with an
isolated palm we talk about pawn islands
white has three pawn islands c to d file
and then the king side and then that
lonely isolated a pawn black has two
pawn islands which means that's harder
to actually get at black's pawns so i
actually do believe in the long-term
possibilities of a position like this
for napalm machine even though the
evaluation is it's fine for white i'm
not too stressed about hikaru's position
it's one of those situations where you
kind of start feeling the
trajectory shift a little bit from an
opening advantage for white to wait a
second i need to make sure i'm not going
to be worse at some point in this game
and i love how you said it's the
long-term prospects right because the
immediate prospects again there's
activity for hikaru he's he's he's going
for the uh maybe this idea of rook b2
rook b5
but always keeping your eye on the
forest through the trees the big picture
here especially because it's not just
that that pawn is weak there's already a
natural predator right for that plug
that the natural predator is just
sitting over there on the long diagonal
and uh
and okay we'll we'll see what he calls
ideas are and we'll get you updated on
exactly when this game
is uh deviating from hikaru's victory
over and ocobian from the 2016 u.s
championship so
okay queen d5 already responded and
neither player at the board as almira
and i said the most exciting event in
sports
neither player at the chessboard besides
sudden death dodgeball
okay
well uh
here we go all four not many people at
the boards right now by the way yeah
they're taking their
mid-game
respite they're just trying to walk
around enjoy maybe a snack
in the top right well hold on we've got
hikaru
he did come back to the board and real
real quick before we uh
before we go check on the game that i
know robert wants to we're going to
watch and see
what what hikaru comes up with in his
next turn and we know that takara caught
up with dina yesterday they talked about
a lot of things
uh we want to we want to check back in
and see one of the opinions hikara gave
on a new place like madrid for a huge
event such as the candidates
i mean i
think it's quite important especially if
you're coming from another continent i
think i i suspect fabiano had been in
europe for for a while but at least for
me coming from the us where there's a
six-hour time difference certainly makes
a difference but even beyond that i
remember when i played in 2016 i think i
got to moscow maybe three days before
the event started and i never really got
on track sleep schedule or anything i
never had a good routine so
yeah i think it's important to come
maybe a week week and a half early i
mean i know in the old days people would
come like a month early you know the
times of alaska and those guys but um i
think a week's enough but it's it's
important to be on the time zone and
feel like you're you're ready to play
you have some great memories connected
with spain you won your first elite
tournament uh actually in spain is there
some kind of aura or some extra power
that you feel here
um i don't know i mean san sebastian was
so so many years ago now i mean it was
what 2009 i think it was so
um you know i feel like i've actually
probably had my best results in spain
and france in particular those two
countries so i don't there's anything
special but i feel like i play well um
in these places so that's what it is
perhaps my final question for today uh
how has your audience been reacting so
far to your six
hours long games than they usually are
used to see you playing three minutes
well i mean i think uh as long as you're
competitive it's always going to be hype
i think
there's a certain
uh view that the the streamers when they
play tournaments aren't going to do very
well or people want to see that see the
sort of the the car crash or the train
wreck but i think as long as you're
playing reasonably well and then good
things happen that being said i mean
every game like i said i've found a way
to make sure it goes longer than it
should i mean today luckily it didn't
didn't cost me where the game went six
hours but um i mean there's there's
suspense and i think people always watch
that
there definitely is suspense and people
do want to watch ikaro it seems no
matter what type of chess he's playing
and here we see him in round five he
will get white again
against sting lee wren in the next round
and uh
when you look at
two of three of his next few games what
stands out to you robert
well i think what stands out to me if we
just look at seven in totality those are
four blacks three whites yeah so he's
not in a position where he needs to
force the issue yes he has white today
he gets white in the next game as well
against dingley wren but he doesn't need
to force things and so that's he's in a
pretty decent spot yeah um i i think
that today may not be going the way he
drew it up at home that i don't really
believe that he's thrilled about he's
listening you're the hickar face reader
we see that you know kind of
glanced there he doesn't look very happy
right yeah that's that's that's a rare
one you see there kind of the tuck in
for what eyebrows like he he's
maybe maybe agreeing with you robert
that he doesn't know exactly a clear
path for white to get advantage but
almira
apology tell me um
you said that hikaru though does
maybe better than anybody in the world
besides magnus carlsen at pivoting given
the opportunity right he maybe comes in
with an idea for a win but okay if he's
surprised he knows the draw is okay
right similarly if he comes in with a
draw mindset and gets a winning chance
he'll take it your thoughts on whether
he'll be calm here and just not not try
to go too crazy with white
well i have a feeling that uh
hikaru has changed over the last years
and
he came to this tournament um
like if i might say like spiritually
completely different you know he feels
the support of his community he is well
prepared
uh he's confident because
his last results also has shown that he
is playing great chess
so he
is wise you know this wisdom
coming up
of hicarus
from hikaru's interviews so i like it
very much and so i agree with robert he
well if he feels the necessity to push
he will do so
if a draw if he needs to make a draw he
feels that
the advantage is slipping away from him
he will shift gears
and well he has another white tomorrow
so um
takes a quick look over there he's uh
he's okay
that was almost a car nakamura number 11
which is sort of rare rare all right i i
think this comes down to what you asked
me at the top of the show yeah like
we're four rounds in and coming into
today yana palmish is the lead
is this his tournament the answer is
it's a wide open race so hikaru is
playing the tournament leader but he
doesn't have to be the person that
brings yondu palmishi down there are
seven other players in this field that
in any single game could beat young
apomashi and they can all beat each
other so i don't think that there's this
tremendous pressure on hikaru to win
this game right now
he doesn't need to feel that he's
playing a good tournament he lost game
one he rebounded in style in game two
and just a pressure filled game where he
just never let jabba off the hook so
why should he feel in this moment on day
five that it's the end of the tournament
no
right in the thick of things
and we'll see we'll see what movie comes
up with here but more than likely the
rook b2 move as predicted will be on the
board
here we get a look at report who uh
looks like he's
he played knight g6 but then got an
immediate response from fabi that was
highly interesting this move rook f1
let's head over there
and uh and see what's going on i know i
know last time we were in our bird's eye
view we mentioned the game in the upper
right we will we will get to her job off
daily run but i i i gotta say that rook
f1
if we were looking at this game in real
time none of us would have predicted
this move no but i like it a lot okay
tell me why i need to learn i think
fabiano's been playing with the theme in
mind and it's when you have more space
you want more pieces on the board black
does not have the control that white has
we saw this earlier when he brought his
knight back to b3 when the knights were
staring each other and now he's saying
that in this current position if you
play knight h4 my bishop goes to h1 but
the good thing about a bishop it's a
long range piece it's doing the same
thing that it was doing on g2 it's just
tucked all the way in the corner so
knight h4 is a bad move it's you know
just playing for one move threat but the
point is that
what is black going to do white is going
to play f4 going to castle queenside all
this kind of stuff
and black is lacks
space so i really really like this move
rook f1 because i don't think that
there's any clarity of let's say play
bishop b4 because i'm talking about how
black would maybe want to trade pieces
that's not the piece you want to trade
you don't want to give your dark square
bishop up for this night and if you guys
you're going through this whether you
have to take with the queen of the pawn
doesn't really matter black has this
dark square dominance actually white has
the darkest diamonds and it looks really
bad for i think every move in this game
i'm gonna find it difficult to find what
richard should do and also what i think
is that fabi has this
gift of playing the moves that your
opponent well his opponents are least
expecting from him the surprise value of
of the move rook f1 is is enormous
no it's it's super interesting although
it like like robert said as soon as we
see it on the board it makes a lot of
sense because the bishop on g2
controls the same squares from h1 right
and we were we were initially
anticipating that we would deal with the
threat of knight h4 with that line you
gave robert castles long and bishop g5
which was also pretty good right but as
you said when you have more space why
trade any pieces and space in chess
everyone is defined as the squares you
control behind your furthest advanced
pawns white has more space in a
structure like this so i want to keep
all the pieces on the board that i can
so that my pieces can use those squares
and that's why he's avoiding the trade
not with this bishop g5 trade but with
bishop h1 and every move for for black
like if you make the wrong one there
could be a huge drawback for white you
have like five different pretty good
looking moves whereas we've been talking
to f4 for white at any moment after f4
black can play this queen h4 check to
win the g4 pawn but white has such a
lead in terms of space and development
that even if you end up winning that
pawn on g4
that may actually walk into white's
hands because your queen is offside now
you don't have as much defense in the
d-file and it just feels like black's
position could collapse at any moment
and look at the
the faces of the players right now
fabiano's leaned in he's
taking the position and reports there i
mean that looks like a person who's
struggling yeah vintage fobby right
there that's like bobby has a little bit
of a
pounce
exactly when he's uh when he when he's
sitting straight up with that posture
usually feeling pretty confident you
mentioned queen h4 it makes me wonder
the only other potential thing to
highlight about rook f1 is the h-pawn is
loose but i guess queen h4 would just be
suicide to try to go after the h2 pawn
uh
oh you castled on first of all you
starting in mate and one
that's true that's probably the easiest
thing is to just castle long threaten
maiden one and the queen tucks
tucks uh the tail back and just runs and
runs back to date okay so wow this is uh
this could be the white side of the open
sicilian i was maybe thinking we would
get with john christophe duda but here
fabiano back with a potential very
dangerous attack against richard reports
so all right we'll keep our eye on it
let's let's back up there's a couple
other games going that we really haven't
checked in on in quite a while and i
think we need to go
to that upper right corner with tame
over java versus dingley wren
uh
we got some info on that game which was
which was interesting um
between these guys we let's see our own
peter doggers crushing it here said
they're they're still uh
they were in in
traditional territory with queen e7 but
11c5
was a novelty from black so even though
it was what you were suggesting
obviously it seems very principled to
push the pawn up and take on the
challenge
of the center maybe a hanging pawn
structure but apparently that move had
never been played before robert and
there's a reason why because c5 allows
them of a3 because the queen and bishop
are no longer teaming up on that square
the pawn c5 is in the way and then now
black is left with
not a particularly easy choice do i take
on d2 handing white the pair of bishops
in a position that isn't open yet but
will open up shortly or instead of
taking on d2 should black back up to a5
which is just kind of awkward in general
not the end of the world but it that's a
weirdly placed piece because after c
takes d5 um now you have this problem
where knight c4 is coming and the bishop
on a5 is stux you probably take with the
pawn on d5 but as we see in the game
that's not what ding wanted to go for so
a3 was probably a useful inclusion i'm
sure ding's preparation kept on going
but that's just one of the biggest
differences that you know a3 could have
been tossed in there and then it would
have been a completely different dynamic
it's interesting that he didn't go for
a3 where java took on d5 right away
that allowed a piece to recapture
because you're not worried about the
piece coming to c4
a lot of simplification happening here
elmira your thoughts on how happy ding
might be feeling right now it feels like
a position where black has gotten a
comfortable comfortable position to play
here well first of all i was thinking
that it might as well be a bluff on
ding's behalf but the very well
calculated love because timur could have
played a3 before so
this is also a parameter that you have
to integrate while you are thinking
about your plans and strategies so he
didn't play it before so he doesn't want
to go for those types of positions so i
might as well play c5 because you need
those moves to define the center or to
provoke stomach exchanges so he said
okay c5 here it comes and now i think
that his position is rather comfortable
but on the other hand it's also
well
quite easy to play for white yeah
it's easy to play pieces are already
being traded i mean
i i like your point about it being a
bluff though on c5 because perhaps a3
should have been played but if you
didn't play the move before maybe you're
less likely to play it the second time
around so okay
and there's this notion of dingley wren
is the number two rated player on the
planet if he's allowing a3 he's doing it
for a reason and maybe he's worked this
out where it's not a problem do you
think that the players at this level
think like that though even i mean even
for a guy like rojava to be
psychologically
i think we can actually get concrete
about it like if we just go to that
position not go deep down the line but
show maybe why he refrained from playing
a3 okay um
so a3 okay bishop takes d2 i think that
looks just way better than putting the
bishop on a5 and let's say knight takes
d2
after pawn takes d4 now your bishop if
it takes on d4 maybe you have to worry
about the a3 at some point not not
necessarily now but you have to worry
about it at some point and white
actually black holes play e5 and expand
the center after bishop takes i have to
take with the pawn on d4 now how
impressive is that bishop on b2 dancer
is not very it's staring into you know
bad bishops defend good pawns but maybe
he just didn't want the long-term
prospects of we talk about hanging pawns
maybe white gets the hanging pawns and
it's not super comfortable so i think
this is the type of position that java
wasn't positive about and so if he's not
sure about he's like let me just get a
symmetrical structure where i'm not
going to be in danger of being worse
makes a lot of sense and i think
interesting when a concrete line is
planning to part ways with the bishop
pair you would only you don't normally
think about that right like this would
be good for white but in this particular
case because the pawn is going to be
permanently blocking the bishop a3 is a
target black would be
black would be more than just fine so
okay
the concrete answers are what we now
have as to why
rajav didn't go for a3 but now he's on
the clock seven minutes behind dingley
wren
and uh
i think well i think we'll back up and
check back in with the ali reza ferrugia
versus young christoph due to battle so
all four games still going here in round
five wow i'm glad i said that particular
game i intuitively i was just thinking
that we haven't looked at in a while but
a lot has changed wow in that ferugia
versus due to battle but immediately
before we even jump in i observe the
clock
big edge for duda yeah he's retained the
lead on the clock but the position is
just
it doesn't even look recognizable
yeah this is uh
very different than what we left at
first observing the live position we
have a past pond for white and a two on
one advantage for black so as far as at
least taking a symmetrical structure to
something dynamic right you were saying
ferugia wants those types of positions
at least now we have we have some
imbalances on the board elmira
well i wanted to underline that b5 is a
very thematical idea so you want to uh
have the d5 square for yourself it's
important yes after
white has played b3 and c4 then you take
on c4 and you play b5 yeah
to ensure this very nice outpost for the
knight on the other hand it creates a
lot of weaknesses c5 square you know you
cannot you can no longer play b6 so
in the long term you could play knight
t4 knight c5
right and maybe there's this bishop b4
idea that we talked about before and
bishop a5 as well so first move i was
looking at was bishop a5
uh and i was trying to make it work here
so
let's uh let's take a look it's probably
what ferrous is thinking about right now
bishop a5 we should also observe a pair
of brooks has been traded too well we'll
back up and actually go through all the
lines of how we got here everyone but i
just wanted to dive into the position at
hand because it seems like it's already
way more spicy than where we left it
what does black have against bishop a5 i
actually really like that move here yeah
that's a nuisance i mean
the p you can play knight c4 it's a
force white to part with that bishop on
a5 but that also is playing into white's
hands bishop takes knight you know
you're okay doing that putting your
knight in e4 elmira mentioned the c5
square not just the c5 square g5 square
watch out for a sudden attack because
you don't have too many pieces defending
there on the uh king side and there's
also knight c3 to put pressure on b5 and
go to the d5 square like all sorts of
weird night maneuvers that are going to
cause black some issues and then there's
this d-pawn it is not an isolated yes it
is but it's a pass pawn sometimes this
can backfire when you think oh my pawn
full steam ahead let me go get a queen
and then your opponent block hates it
and starts uh piling up pressure on it a
best block canning piece is a knight
white has two of them black only has one
to be very difficult to blockade that
pawn successfully and score one for
elmira
because ali reza perugia agrees plays
bishop a5 looks at his opponent before
takes he
step up gonna go take a little little
walk stretch those young legs right um
[Music]
yeah this is
i mean it's funny because the e-bell bar
not giving a ton to white but from a
practical perspective i really
prefer white's chances although
due to played these positions as we
noted
before
likely not too stressed
let's back up and real quick while he
while he settles in for i think i just
want to see how we got here because we
left the position
on b3
black played rookie eight
ferrugia played c4 of course that's the
natural follow-up to b3
and that's when the simplification
begins because it's interesting that
robert you're i see you want to jump
here because
due to force duda is the one who forced
the type of position we're getting so if
we'd like for russia it's interesting
because he's the one who sent us down
this forcing sequence yeah and taking on
c4 like that wasn't necessary yeah but i
guess due to like the dynamic chances he
was about to obtain but if we pause here
c takes d5 is definitely not a threat
because my knight can take and now
you're saddled with this isolated pawn
now that's an isolated pawn yeah and
it's not a good one cabo blanco would be
yeah
roll over is great he'd be salivating at
the prospects of that position so uh
black probably could have played a
different move dude had choices here um
a common movement plays g6
you know even moving his knights you
know maneuvering those around but i
understand he probably didn't want to
sit in this position forever white has a
few plans to get active potentially a
knight coming to e5 that bishop on d2
going over to a5 like elmira just
suggesting the game or to f4 you have
these options for white and then when
you start feeling like their tentacles
just like coming at you you think let me
trade some stuff off simplify but i do
believe the simplification is very nice
for ferrous in this game that's funny
because he like you said he uh he forced
the issue went for this
and is now facing
the prospect of bishop a5 staring down
the barrel of the diagonal gun here and
uh we're gonna see with see what he
comes up with but while we watch duda
let's take a closer look at the player
from poland who finds himself right in
the middle of this tournament with four
straight draws
although saddled with the lowest rating
in the field janukshistop duda has been
playing well heading into the candidates
the 24 year old from poland also brings
a solid record against magnus carlson
should duda manage to win it all here in
madrid and challenge for the world title
the second youngest player in the field
duda defeated carlson at the fite world
cup to secure his bid here at the
candidates
i think he must have resigned yep
it's over yahn kissed up duda beats
magnus with black in the tiebreaker what
a performance
duda enters the candidates with some
steam recently taking both the oslo
esports cup and the grand chess tour in
poland
his success against carlson makes duda a
pretty interesting story to watch
especially should he get through madrid
amongst his triumphs duda stopped
carlson's
125 game undefeated streak two years ago
in norway
he also beat carlson in his world cup
victory that punched his ticket to spain
with some momentum and big match
experience duda is looking to become the
first player from poland to challenge
for the world chess championship
time will tell if he can pull it off
[Music]
you know it's interesting that
we're obviously focused on whether dude
can get through the candidates and i do
want to get your thoughts on his next
few rounds robert but
i don't even know that i've given enough
credit to the storyline of just how well
duda has done against magnus carlsen and
this early career young career he has i
mean what are your thoughts on what a
challenger he would be
well he beat magnus famously to stop uh
max's 125 game unbeaten streak that was
great he beat him in the world cup i'll
be he they drew their classical games
and then it was decided in quicker tie
patrols but yeah he's a worthy contender
i think magnus would be the heavy
favorite against pretty much anybody
but i think the duda has proven his
medal although not necessarily over the
course of a full tournament and i think
that was one of the main criticisms
in terms of his winning chances coming
in the candidates right is the type of
performance rating you need to have to
win the candidates is like 28.70 over
the whole length of the event and i'm
not sure dude has ever done that in
classical chess that's not to take
anything away from his successes it just
shows that this is next level stuff
speaking of performance and the
performance rating needed almira what
kind of performance will he need in the
last two games that's a pretty tough
lineup given how napaneshi and nakamura
have been playing
well he will be having
blacks to well
for two games in a row i think that he
needs to
maintain his stability that's why those
tournaments are played uh
well in a double round roman format so
uh
if you have a feeling that
young sister is waiting for his moment
you know so it's like to counter-attack
so he's patiently waiting for
his opponents to take some risks
okay that's interesting well we'll see
if he
gets some risk from the panda she
because he'll get black uh the next day
but right now
right now he has his work cut out for
him of course against all the reservoirs
we did see
two moves played at the break
knight c4 from duda and then the trade
on c7 so the the position that you both
predicted will we see 94 is the question
or does alireza have something else in
mind but
there's something that i wanted to say
about this position even though you know
this move knight e4 seems very strong
what strikes me is that
every move
young sister dude he will be facing a
very difficult decision so while white
can do whatever he likes you can play
knight e4 g3 h4 king g2 maybe e4 a4 like
to swap on b5 to create another weakness
so
all these moves seem very natural to me
whether uh it will be very tough for
black i think it's a great point even in
the current position i mean we
highlighted 94 because we were quickly
trying to build on the point of the c5
square that was made by elmira but
really i mean queen e4 is a move here by
the way you know how much i love
background checkmates don't
don't say what you're about to say about
factoring checkmates i i know knight h5
also a move knight f5 okay you can say
it how many times did i miss a
background check made in my match i
wasn't going to say that
i support you okay whatever you texted
me afterwards and you were like hey man
all the back ring checkmates
anyway
you have these insights in chess.com and
if you go through your insights i think
one thing that you can find for those
who don't speak background check made
very good like me i'll just show it for
you right there that is uh okay jokes
aside it's obviously not something that
young christoph duda will fall for
but it is a thematic uh
tactic here that makes me think about
not just queen e4 but sometimes the
power of the deep on the power of
pressure when you have a looming
weakness like this makes the opportunity
for things to go wrong yeah because
queen e4 forces the move if you want to
make a normal reaction like rook f8
right and that's not exactly a
comfortable move it works on open files
not staring into their own pawns like
that so 24 is reasonable knight h5 as
you were pointing out like going the
other direction just aiming towards the
black king it's not like there are many
defenders over there helping the black
king out so knight h5 could just be
a bit of a pester some move that duda
will have to sit and think and react to
because knight h5 queen f5 hitting that
b5 pawn hitting the bishop in f6 it
seems like as amir was saying
there are attacks coming from all
directions and white has like six
different moves that all look good and
black will need to respond and kind of
parry off all the threats that the moves
are creating
yeah much easier position for white to
play and i feel like the longer we let
if we were sitting on this one and
letting the eval go up i feel like
i feel like white's advantage is going
to start to increase a little bit in
this game now i finally understood you
know because i was thinking that the
whole time you were calling it the evil
bar well it is also
it is evil it's an evil evil bar
don't get it off it will give you heart
attacks
but uh now and now i get it so dr eval
i like that um
all right who does number two work for
sorry who does number two
austin powers that is not a movie that
aged well i will tell you that okay it's
time to not talk about most of the humor
in that movie and talk about what's
going on in the other the other three
games uh
c4
from hikara nakamura rather than rook to
b2 was responded to with queen e4 and
and jan is yona's waltzing around again
just the guy who's already leading the
tournament
feeling comfy feeling confident yawn
just continuing to
to show that he's he's happy with his
chess his queen's about to go on a bit
of a journey there yeah that queen's
going to get attacked so we'll uh
reminds me like the game chrome nick
between announce
and at the end i think a non-lost piece
somehow but
uh yeah
let's let's take a look at that so
we left the position
with rook to b2
or thinking this was an idea we were
highlighting with b5 but hikaru plays
with a more aggressive c4 and yon
very quickly by the way just looking at
the time stamps 43 seconds only to play
queen e4 so
is jan is yelling still deep in his prep
here i'm not so sure because first of
all look at how the eva bar reacted it's
starting to say that white's advantage
is increasing and i think the first
thought that the three of us had is
bishop f won anybody there's a queen on
the e file rooks usually win stare downs
with queens
queens being more valuable piece and is
that queen really going into b1 just
hiding
behind enemy lines there
it's annoying for white to deal with but
perhaps if he car digs deep right now
and he's already spent nearly 15 minutes
on this move he's trying to work through
like is that queen getting into b1 and
if it does get there is that actually
going to be a nuisance or can i use that
queen attack it and then maybe go for
black's weaknesses what is queen b1
force let's say bishop f1
bishop
queen g4
because
i i guess you just let me kick your
queen around for uh so h3 and you you
would say that i don't have
a very comfortable square yeah that
doesn't look
so pleasant to my eyes and i mean queen
bee won at least it looks fun so right
how often do you get to play with that
movie it was a fun move right queen to
be one would be fun
and it rhymes
i have some traumatic experiences of
losing my queen in the scandinavian you
know like you you make too many queen
moves and then it's finally lost i don't
want to talk about the experiences i've
had with the queen because
most of them are painful but all right
while we wait for hikaru to uh
we're going to see what happens here we
have we have the coach of america's team
in the room emily i don't know if you
knew that the coach for the upcoming
chess olympian is with us that of course
is robert hess yesterday dina asked fabi
or if you knew this robert about a
notable name not on the team for this
year's usa roster and uh let's let's see
what uh favi had to say
just one
more question um would you have
preferred to have hikaru in the olympic
team for us
well in general i'd like to have the
strongest team for the united states and
uh
um yeah hikaru
is one of the best players in the world
so it would be good to have him on but i
i kind of understand that he doesn't
want to
play the reserve board it's uh
you know let's say he he probably
considers himself of a higher stature
than to to not play all the games
in the olympiad um if i was in his
position i would still probably play the
olympiad but i
um i understand also why he doesn't
robert you're
you're the coach
right you're fabi's coach finally does
that feel good
he's coach you're gonna be the coach of
the us men's olympic team again uh
that's big news if you didn't know it
and we're excited for robert but what
are your thoughts on bobby's comments
and also not having hikaru on the team
well i have to say that the team was
selected before i was they vote on their
coach so i have no say in any of that
stuff i mean every one would want a car
on their team he's an amazing chess
player he brings you know this dynamic
energy over the chessboard and that's
always something you want you throw him
in the lineup and you feel confident
that he'll do well uh his reasons i
don't know them you know in full so i
can't speculate i'm sure his streaming
career and there are many reasons uh why
he would sit it out and it's a long
tournament
and youtube and all that stuff you know
creating content and
earning the big bucks so from fabiano's
perspective i think he said it well like
maybe uh hicara would want to be a
position where played every single game
and on the us team which i feel
incredibly privileged to be the coach of
like
it's hard to know who to play whenever
because everyone's so strong and you
know hikara's not planks instep sam
shanklin that's somebody who's 27 20
plus who's won the u.s championship
ahead of fabiano caruana wesley so has
played really well in olympia's past so
when you're kind of spoiled for choice
yes you would like a car on your team
but you're also saying they're like yeah
next option
not so bad
elvira bobby said that if he was in
hikaru shoes he still would have played
right you think that's maybe a different
mentality they have we i mean robert
just talked a lot about him streaming
but why do you think bobby said that
even if he was in his shoes he still
would have played you think favi just
feels very patriotic in that sense
well
we're all very different so i think i've
declined
this election even for this year's
olympiad a few times because uh well for
different reasons family you know
training so i can understand that it's
not easy to combine everything like what
is going on in hikaru's life right now
and i wanted to say that they also won
the gold olympics already once not like
the
and even this team like even the same
they are fighting for gold medals this
time
uh what i wanted to underline is that in
france it's a completely different story
because i was surprised that uh it's the
coach who selects the players you know
right in france yes so it's i find that
this danny would have been playing if i
got this
and then would have one goal
[Laughter]
and i find this way of like well of
doing things uh more fair so uh it's
very important so you don't have any
conflicts between the coach and the
players yeah also so it's uh
i'm looking forward you know
that's a good question for chad is who
robert would have picked on his team we
know he would have taken me
yeah i would have chosen you just like a
bench you ever said
but i actually want to say something
quickly about what fabiano said he's not
in hicarah's shoes and he knows that
yeah if i loves playing chess right the
guy always wants to play i mean that's
his career right now hikar is a chess
player but he's also
by quantity of time predominantly a
chess streamer or a streamer who focuses
on chess most the time so it's
impossible to put yourself in a car's
shoes because there's literally nobody
else on the planet who can put those
pineapple shoes on and entertain the
masses like him right that's right well
anyway interesting topic and of course
we are super excited and and uh wishing
wishing team team usa and robert has the
coach the best he made a mistake what
can i say
they made a mistake what can i say
he's about to move the car is about to
move so i was wondering if we would
catch that on camera we'll see i think
he was grabbing the rook
grabbing the rook and i think he was
about to play brook b2
the bishop
bishop of one it looks like
okay
yeah yes okay
okay bishop f1 attacks the queen
and uh like you said a rook normally
wins the staring contest right that you
ever do the blinking contest let's do it
right now don't blink
i'm gonna turn my head to focus i'm
pretty good oh he's really good all
right never mind we're not gonna do that
we're gonna we're gonna go to the
analysis board trying to get you to lose
the steering contest but the reason
everyone is that the queen is worth more
so she has to find safety it is not an
equal trade
probably we're going to see queen g4 but
just h3 i mean that queen is really
being kicked around yeah queen g4
h3 she has to run again but then d5 i
mean i can just start pushing all my
things forward here and this yeah this
looks really good for white i think the
queen's going to be one
you think she's going to be i think that
queen is going to be one
well wouldn't that be fun
you already got that right
wow i mean honestly though how often do
you see a queen all the way in the enemy
last rank that didn't involve a
promotion so then elmira what's the
response here rookie choose the
immediate response but perhaps you need
to take care of this trade first what do
you what do you think on the line we
might see
rugby too and rookie of course are the
moves that i've been looking at
first of all you need to understand the
difference
why do you need to play rookie one
advocate first okay oh wait he slid to
g4 by the way young does have the best
facial expressions i agree with you i
think hikaru has the most variety but
john's facial expressions are what was
that username
i i didn't want to read the use some of
the usernames i don't read by design but
jerem morrow is one i'll read nepo's
reaction
low a great profile pick there for
jerome maybe you simply lose a pawn
after rookie a trochet rock b2 and rook
b7 ah okay so elmira's pointing out
maybe why
yon didn't go for this because it would
have been
takes e8 takes rook b2 queen a1 and then
rook b7
and perhaps jan just uh
he didn't like this position yes there's
bishop xa3
yes there are a lot of fans hanging
there as well so
and there's like queen a4 ideas this is
really cool this is super wild but the
fact that dylan is still playing so
quickly is just shocking to me our our
analysis doesn't like queen g4 meaning
the eval bar
i
that was the first
question that i asked robert what if
queen g4 is no no it looks like a
mistake right i mean queen g4 h3
but i think speaking of mistakes one
mistake that all of us might find
ourselves making is looking at the
reacting to the evil every term because
there may only be one
pinpoint precise path that leads it
towards a plus one and a half over here
and most other moves might just still be
like point six which is right six tenths
of a pound betters are still an
advantage for white but not anything to
write home about but what i don't like
from y'all's perspective is white's
moves h3 is like the most obvious move
ever bishop
looks like he's already about to play it
by the way he's gonna play h3 and then
where's this queen going
like you're just kicking this queen
around getting free
tempe as white and yan is perhaps
suggesting that his underlying structure
everything that's going on here that
he'll still be okay yup i just don't
like how this game is going it feels
like it's playing into carter's hands
without any counter punches maybe he was
looking for some tactical ideas while
the queen is still on g4 i can play
rookie one
so he cannot take with the knight then
queen e1 and maybe queen e4 back to
exchange quiz but then rook comes to e2
yeah p2
now who controls that open file clearly
white
you move the queen to b1
d5
where's your knight going can't go to a5
a5 you lose the knight although the
bishop on c1 is hanging but yes
also knight d4 is coming soon
i mean the longer the computer thinks
the more it seems to like white i mean
wow all right well
whether don is the best facial
expressions or not chat i'm not sure
you're going to see the happiest of
facial expressions here if hikaru
somehow finds the forcing line that
proves the engine right we don't
necessarily know what it is but it
definitely feels very scary just from a
practical perspective we don't have a
safe
route for the queen and by the way the
more we look at now that i understand
that d5 is coming robert just having
found it in that line i feel like that's
a key point this is a really hard
position for black can we briefly just
go back before queen e4 was played just
two moves ago yeah
so queen e4 yeah after c4
black can go queen d7 and i don't think
you have too many issues at the moment
like it's just a game right yeah but
putting your queen on e4 like
voluntarily placing it
in the path of the rook
then immediately going over to g4 where
it gets hit by this pawn
i mean this just feels wrong like
ignoring the eval bar we have that
showing showing us that yes in fact is
incorrect but i'm sure hikaru was
sitting at the board like what is yan
doing and they have tremendous respect
for each other they're elite players and
have been for a long time
but sometimes people just make weird
moves
and they are in fact bad yeah and jan is
making some bad choices right now yeah
well
i just told before the show started that
how patient jan was and i like i feel
that he's completely untilt right now
all these moves you know kenneth work
with g4
um
what can we expect here queen g6
i i guess i think your idea of brook
takes e1 was probably what he had in
store but the more we looked at that
because if you just move the queen
you know to g6 i think the d5 idea is
still coming i i what's funny is okay
again it's hard we're we're doing
commentary of course we have the e-belt
bar guiding us but once we started
analyzing that concrete idea of d5 now
that i see that in every line i look at
i really like white right the more i
look at the position and see the d5 is
coming i think that's one of the key
points
that not only is the queen running out
of squares but this knight is going to
be kicked from the central defense of
both e5 and d4
and the white counterpart is ready to uh
to take that job and we've been
complimenting yon for not beating
himself right he's played pretty well
thus far he's gonna win with black then
he won yesterday's game after being a
bit surprised but i mean the last few
moves are it's a different player this
is not yon napomshi four games past that
we've seen this is like a completely
different player and in karu he's making
the right responses
but he's also like being fed them it's
like you put your queen on e4
i simply move my bishop you put your
queen on g4 i pushed upon create love
for my king attack your queen your
queen's going all over the place then
i'll play d5 to attack your knight gain
space i mean it just
it just does not feel like the yawn upon
machine that we have seen to this point
in the tournament and we were talking
about the opening choices so this
opening doesn't suit him that well
finally he's not a player who is seeking
uh well to equalize
well it's funny because we were talking
earlier as maybe a good opening choice
against hikaru who wanted to win he was
the tournament leader but i think what
you're saying about the style of his
chess maybe is more important than
whether it was the right tournament
choice because of the standings and that
might be that might be proving true
because we've been sitting here thinking
we're like okay
yawn's playing fast now we know that
there's a game hit carl played he
probably knew it he obviously must have
a plan
but then he doesn't seem to play i don't
know what's going on queen e4 is a move
that if you make me go through the
players in this tournament five minute
carolina would never play that move
dingly wren would never play the move so
you got to give yon credit for
creativity because he does think outside
the box
amongst the best in the world at it
right like he's able to find winning
chances and positions that mostly like
yeah there's nothing here but he also
just found himself some really good
losing chances by bringing his queen e4
he could have just slid the queen back
to d7 just played calmly instead he's
going look at his face he is dejected
right now yeah he's like what was i
thinking so it's funny though let's
unpack like how
it gets here because i think obviously
from our chair like we now see complete
information we have so many advantages
the players don't and and clearly we're
not wrong right obviously john has
messed up and now maybe for the first
time he's realizing he messed up but
but often what happens in these lines
elmira and robert is he saw something
that we don't know right he saw
something he thought there was a clear
line right so elmira i mean i saw you
nodding your head just now you you uh
what do you think if we had to guess
what was it because often these guys
don't just make blunders chat they they
had some idea maybe it was the queen b1
idea maybe maybe that was what he
underestimated what do you think it was
well first of all uh
what i wanted to say is that while he
was preparing for his game he was forced
to um
well to look at many lines in the pet
roof so
this is one of the ideas to play queen
e4 but i think this is
might be a simple mix-up you've seen so
many positions that you know that you
have to play queen f4 at some point or
queen the six like depends on the line
and i have a feeling this is what
happened yeah so just thought he thought
he was pulling from memory but exactly
he thought that we've seen it by the way
the uh the pacing fabian he stopped and
stared a few times how much how much do
you think bobby's rooting for his fellow
american in this game robert i mean
obviously
bobby only trails yawn in the tournament
right i think he i think he'd like to
see nakamura shake up the standings here
although at the same time that adds
another person towards the top yeah and
maybe a shrieking nakamura is not what
you want to see
thank you
okay that slipped out the wrong way but
okay maybe a hot
streaking
okay nakamura on a roll is maybe more
dangerous than yon tofavi fair point
he's done the worst thing so
i found the right way to get out of that
and also we think directly head to head
that fobby had black against yon in the
first half and he already beat hikart
with the white pieces so then second
time around bobby will have to play a
car with the black ops yes
white exactly so that's a part of it and
i think amir makes a very fair point
contextualizing it that queen e4 is an
idea in many positions
but that's why you have time and look at
how much time john has remaining yeah he
should have spent that time after c4 to
verify that he's just not walking into a
fire pit and so he plays this and it
feels like his old bad habit took over
took over right it's like you know this
gargoyle that's turned to stone and then
finally it's let out and you're like
well i don't know what to do with that
thing and maybe you should go back into
being a stone and so
he just
played too quickly here and now he's
like what did i do why did i put my
queen there i could have just got queen
d7 and wouldn't have these issues so i
feel like look at favi over here like um
yeah what's your queen doing over there
on g4 buddy the queen could have just
safely went home to d7 so i think that
it's a situation where he just needs to
use his clock in that critical moment
and maybe he didn't realize just how
critical it was but now he is and now
unfortunately for him it's a two moves
too late
oh man well fobby pacing makes me want
to
back out a little bit and at least at
least at least get a view from the top
of what's happening in all four games
even if we don't immediately dive into
fabi because a pacing fabiano probably
not something that richard report is
happy about
it might mean a very confident fabiano
we see the pawn has advanced the g5
report is on the clock
and what what is ahead in that
very very ominous looking kingside
attack coming to virgin report but all
right before we dive in we are going to
take a quick break and on that note
before we do i want to remind everybody
that the 44th chess olympiad is coming
to chennai india
this is the biggest team event in chess
with more than 100 countries competing
for gold
coverage begins every day at 2 30 a.m
robert i know you will be wide awake
when we're back in the states at 2 30
a.m uh pacific time between july 28th
and august 9th
right here on chess.com happy one week
i've been in in india man you're gonna
be in india oh you're busy
all right we're gonna take a break
everyone don't go anywhere round five of
the 2022 feed eight candidates will
continue from madrid in just a few
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is a
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah
we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
uh our man on the inside danny wrench
who's been with the players a lot going
to the players meetings and he's here to
tell us about some special requests that
a few of the players made danny what
have they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can defeat a okay but the
first one was
uh a lot of bonus requests if you play
and win with the spanish on either side
makes sense right that makes sense um
there was a uh
a suggestion you know that anytime you
move the queen you you drop a dab for
queen isabella yeah yeah she's the one
that made the queen power makes sense
okay um but then the players were
unanimous on one in particular which was
that every two hours into every round
they'll have a nasty well we'll see if
any of these rules are implemented for
the tournament uh especially if somebody
plays the spanish they've got some money
coming their way doesn't seem likely but
uh i don't even want to know which
players made these requests but i've got
a couple ideas in my mind yeah well you
know and uh if and anything that gets
the players to play something more than
the berlin right the most exciting draw
in the world now that we have some money
on the line perhaps we see some exciting
some exciting spanish games so i'm i'm
actually excited about that one there
you go you need some alex honold on us
yes
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera
can you tell he's a dad of a teenager
[Music]
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go ahead a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah
okay i'll see you guys in a couple hours
yeah
it's been a long day dan you deserve it
buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy yeah
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of san steaks are high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos
we are back here
miss amigos we are here i'm here with my
friends
we're all gonna have a great time when
we're hanging out with our amigos and
you know the players are being treated
like superstars as they come to the
building every day fans begging for
autographs
robert anyone anyone ask you for your
autograph on your way in
i don't think anybody knows i'm here
because my first day so i just you know
happily came early nobody saw me but
maybe in the future somebody will
what about you any any fans stop you on
the way in well i'm coming here like way
too early
two hours before and i actually love
like uh robert's coming he's coming here
com completely incognito you know so
completely incognito and we are here we
are here early just so everyone knows
but
uh we are also going to be here every
day we've got international master
almiroschenko
master robert hess in studio for the
first time we're super happy to have him
here with us in madrid
and uh
i i think there's a game that maybe
we already knew was going to be a
marquee game coming in but we might need
to get right back to it because uh we
left it knowing that something had gone
wrong for nippo and all we're getting is
confirmation of that fact with every
move that's played robert look at him
and you know they're
only a couple moves by him and by a
carbon plate and he looks distraught
he's looking at his position hoping to
find something to save him and if we
look back at the canvas the previous one
he was
in first place he loses to maxine
vashila grav
and then the tournament stops yes so we
know that young can be a player who has
hot and cold streaks right
people have talked about his endurance
can he play a full 14 rounds in a row
and
he hasn't lost the game yet he still has
plenty of chances to hold but the way
this game is going it's already it makes
you wonder like
can this collapse his tournament even
though he'd still be in fine position in
the standings i love elmer's opinion on
that because it was just you and i doing
commentary for that candidates that came
to a stop obviously because of covet
seems like life times ago for all of us
in 2020 that tournament didn't resume
for an entire year but
robert and i said on mirror that
probably the biggest beneficiary of the
halftime break that
ultimately gave them a year was yonda
pomnishi because he tends to be a
streaky player right really thriving
when things are going well the only loss
he had in the tournament ended up being
the final game before they took a year
break do you believe that that that
break was critical to him not going on
tilt and how do you think he will deal
with a loss should it happen here with
nakamura well i agree with you
especially
well this break came after loss and we
talked about the importance of how uh
how sovices players so how switch your
school up recognizes of making a draw
just you know to calm yourself down but
here you have to continue and yesterday
you said of is how well all of us are
creatures of habits you know
and i feel like
jan's mind is playing some games with
him because it's like stop smoking yes
you know
and you're looking at this and it's like
okay just one you know he he was very
calm and patient during those four games
and here is something went terribly
wrong you know it's like
you know we have our own proper
mechanisms so this one kicked in in this
game
yeah
well okay if if indeed this proves to be
a loss and again as you said still
plenty of life left
for him to try to hold this but that may
be a story line that we're looking back
on in several rounds if it ultimately is
the last time we're looking at the
tournament leading yonder ponbashi here
on cam it might be because of whatever
whatever the bad sides of his habits
that got a hold of him it was it's
unrecognizable decision making in terms
of this event yeah but it is something
that has plagued him in the past we can
name so many examples of it and for
young his blessing is his curse right
he's very quick he not just you know in
terms of playing blitz chess or anything
he just sees sharp variations he sees
through them very quickly and there's a
reason he was up an hour against
alleriza farouzi yesterday beating him
on the clock the board and just in every
which way so uh for yon i mean queen e4
in this game the the first time not the
why it's here now and that's just a move
that if you gave him
another chance just say jan you're going
to sit for three minutes and then you're
going to make your move he's not playing
queen e4 right it is just
and that's why i feel bad because it
feels like we're harping on a guy who's
already you know down i mean just look
at him right he's
very unhappy he's actually red in the
face
but
it's just so beneath his level and these
players far stronger
than i am it's not you know trying to
say that and i think that's the reason
why i get worked up about it because he
has so much time and if he just sat
there for even a couple minutes he would
not have played queen before and robert
again is referring to queenie for the
first time which was in this position
both queen d6 27 we're better for black
queen e4
just
in hindsight clearly a mistake the
computer immediately says wait a second
to use the don it goes whoop right
and then it only keeps whooping from
here on out as with every move
black is getting in more trouble now
what's he going to do with that queen on
e4 given that d5 is coming it's the big
question that we have ahead let's let's
look at a line so probably queen bee one
is
is it the only i mean
what what else can you play here besides
queen b1 i mean this move i assumed
there was some sort of discovered
three
uh and and no other squares are safe for
the queen i think this is the only move
on the board a queen couldn't be one
very directly white plays d5 yep
and where's your night going and
immediately
it's it's funny how
all it takes is one move on the board
for the computer to say yeah this is a
real problem and by the way you were
right about queen takes a five i'm just
realizing because after takes you just
take c7 every the whole house is falling
and there's two past pawns here
this i mean look at yon's reaction right
now this is a
this is the opposite of the yawn we saw
yesterday that yawn we were applauding
the confident yawn as you said
deliberate in his intention right he
managed his time yesterday which means
he played fast but when the critical
moments were there how many times did we
see him
take a sip of tea right you and i were
joking there was an hour on the clock
with ollie rosa had a minute right but
he was still patient
but today playing too fast he may not be
able to take that time back but you know
what i was saying before in french they
have this saying like uh proverb like
well you fight against yourself you're
being patient confident exactly what i
wanted to say but
then it comes back even stronger
and that's what we see today you know
he's been impatient robert said so many
times that he had to take some time to
think you know to reveal re-evaluate the
position and uh
to change his plan
robert you were you were raising your
future were you going to suggest there
was a different move i think
maybe queen e3 is better than i first
thought because there isn't a great
discovery yeah queen d3 i mean you're
just it's this is calculating by
process of elimination right queenie one
looks really bad queen d3 doesn't look
great it's the only other move that
doesn't lose your queen though so
can i still just play defense you can
play d5 but after d5 so there's no
knight a5 we we should point that out
because the queen covers that square
just losing the piece but you have
knight d4 ah that's the difference the
queen on d3 allows knight d4 whereas the
queen on b1 does not okay i can see and
the computer immediately says that's why
so so okay that that's gotta be why
queen d3
is the best move is not because of d5
back to the discovery drawing board
actually
surprisingly difficult to punish right
you would think that any rook move
should be really good but rook e8
black can just take that rule yep
because you'll take my queen but i'll
take yours and we're just trading
everything off and you see black's even
better there so rookie doesn't work
after queen d3 what about rook e7 right
they're trying to win the c7 pawn
now this queen goes to b1 and
importantly there are no rook b2
uh things like that that go after the
queen and the b7 pawn so rook takes c7
you think yes let me just grab your pawn
bishop d6 traps your rook
your greedy rook is the queen
the queen with full board defense of the
b7 pawn that's not something you see
every day
okay wow so queen d3 all right so if
john finds queen d3
it's going to take an accurate move from
hikaru to keep the edge we haven't
spotted it yet is it okay we were
looking i think at the e file for
discoveries that was sort of our
original obsession but what about just
going to b2 right away same idea i'll go
back to e4
i'm going to keep obviously this very
important point that rook takes b7
you know at some point looks like you're
gonna win a pawn but the d4 pawn will
fall in in any which way right there's
like the rook on b7 is loose in many
positions as well so
um wow i mean queen d3
shockingly is a move that keeps black in
the game and the way that jan is
spending his time here i think it's
ultimately the move that he's going to
choose can we try rookie 3 here because
i still want to play d5 and that's the
only option uh queen b1 uh c to do this
and d5 here
right so i'll play i can play knight e7
so the normally you just take twice on
e7 right because two minor pieces are
better than rook but as you're
highlighting that bishop on c1 is just
too loose to make this
but i still like elmira's idea because
if we establish what was the reason
queen d3 is best likely because you can
meet d5 with knight d4 so it would stand
to reason that rook e3 seems like a good
response because if the queen is chased
and we're back to d5 black no longer has
knight d4 so if it goes to 97 maybe we
can go back to knight d4 robert and
forget about it so amir i think you're
on to something this might be
best response but by the way look at
that yawn a little bit of a smile there
almost he he knows it's not over yet he
does find the best move and and we still
have a game oh and here's you know
hikaru is
was he gonna adjust the piece or was he
about to move no he was about to move i
think and he was about to play rook b2 i
think which would be a beginning
it doesn't mean he's offering repetition
but
one thing that this move is doing
everyone is saying if you go back to e4
my my best move might just be rook right
back to e2 which is you know as elmira
and i said the the original way to offer
a draw to repeat moves but i think what
car is doing is that you know
traditional school of chess
you're the one down in time you have the
better position let's get closer to the
next time control yeah that way you know
when it comes down to it i don't have to
be quite as worried because i've thrown
in a repetition so i think a car
probably will play rookie two back
because if you don't play rookie two
we're gonna see the evaluation start
dipping and then black's gonna be okay
like let's say you move your queen to c3
now black stabilizes with b6 and no
longer you're threatening to win pawns
and the position looks more and more
reasonable amir what do you think is it
just the
the uh
every silvia chess kid knows you always
repeat is that what's going on here well
especially with this time control and i
think a few players including hikaru
have expressed their concerns
about this time control or maybe about
different time controls being used in
different tournaments so you don't have
time to adjust
so what do you think robert i think
you're 100 right in fact we're seeing it
on the board and i definitely don't
think we'll see a draw though if it
happens i will be i will be very
disappointed hikaru takes a moment now
to say i've gained a move
like you said on mirror now on move 22
so 18 moves remain
for us to ultimately make time control
and
some may see this oh look it's 41 plus
minutes i mean that's all the time in
the world but in order to keep your
advantage union starts burning clock to
make sure that you don't make one
careless move and all of a sudden the
position is equal we're just showing uh
some variations where you make the move
rookie seven thinking you're just gonna
win the c pawn and in fact after queen
b1 you take that pawn your work gets
trapped and there goes your advantage so
hikaru he needs to show accuracy right
now yan he wasn't doing himself any
favors earlier now he sat he thought he
found this queen d3 move very
instructive and hikaru you can see he
he's searching the position and the
previously like distraught yan who maybe
thought he was just gonna lose the game
and he really looks red in the face now
he's looking at this with a new lease on
life you're gonna see the way he's
walking around now hits hikaru the
burdens on him and actually
the exact path forward not that easy
okay
yeah well
higaro does have 40 minutes to find his
next move will he find elmira's rookie
three i think you're right i'm here i
think that's the best idea rookie three
followed by d5 but
in the meantime
we're gonna we're gonna back up and
remind everybody that all four games are
still in progress here in round five
where have you been we've got almost
thirty thousand of you with us actually
we do have more than thirty thousand of
you with us just on twitch alone thanks
for making us part of your day i think
we know where we want to go because i uh
i mean i'm biased for the position of
the board producers reading my mind here
i think we should head over and see
exactly what it is that uh
carwana and report are up to because
they've made a few moves in this and
this now looking very very look at that
bobby completely denying castles with
rook d1 yeah but
i mean rapport
quickly brings apon forward getting some
counter play for himself uh
i can see the evaluation and i'm
actually trying to ignore it because i'm
just thinking what would i be thinking
if i were in this game where
black isn't close to castling but white
legally cannot castle you move both your
brooks
so
it just feels like a fight
elmira you said that rapport doesn't
mind playing we know he loves chaos he's
a creative player
right uh hairstyle reflects his chest
playing on the board just like kind of a
wild rock star of a chess player
he also said he doesn't like he doesn't
mind playing bad positions so how do you
think he feels in this facing fabiano's
pawn storm well
i think that that's exactly what he
wanted to get today
it's a fight a very unbalanced position
once again and like and i have a quote
from you know game of thrones you know
nothing
you know nothing
you know so but what do you so what do
you think he's uh he's thinking about
now that fabi is also
showing he's up for the fight because
you don't have to play rook d1 just like
you don't have to play rook f1 but fabi
is fully committed
to bringing the heat as fast as possible
at the neglect of his own king you think
that a little bit of taste of reports on
medicine almira
well first of all i like bishop c6 move
you know it was a very nice prophylactic
move now from uh there are two points i
protect the d7 pawn and i protect the b5
phone for starting you know preparing
the advance
it's it's a very nice move so um
i understand fabi's hesitation in this
position because he uh
maybe initially wanted to castle long so
he had to switch his plans as well and
thinking that
the king is maybe safe in the center you
know what do you think maybe he should
have castled one i mean this might have
been the safer option but an a5 a4
same exact plan just with your king now
in potential danger it's funny just how
much better i feel in this line just as
someone who's played positions like this
too like i i mean maybe not f maybe not
f5 but
maybe you can take first because uh
can you
but i don't even know that i'm worried
about this because i just want to i want
to do this and i want to do it before
you get your king out of the center
no i meant like after f5 you played f5
maybe we had a possibility to take as
well on
b3
in a4 after e5 yes yeah saying maybe
black can take on b3 i i don't think f5
is good though probably because of i'd
rather i'd rather actually play this
move in hindsight and then play f5 to
stop knight e5
yeah it's a really rich position i had
to say bishop c6 was a marvelous move by
a report yeah because we were talking
about every which way it seemed like uh
fabi would have a clear plan and then
reports said well why don't i just make
take away the pressure on d7 before you
even get there so preemptive move and
playing a5 a4 creates him play for
himself and he realizes that his king in
the center can't easily be attacked yeah
f4 f5 does look scary but it's not quite
quick enough to force
the black king to flee so bishop c6
i mean that is a great move and yeah if
rapport can even get the upper hand and
maybe play for a win here we might be
talking about that move as kind of like
one of the moves determining this quiet
move you're not seeing a sacrifice but
really an excellent choice in a position
that was looking very worrisome but are
we looking at a game where neither of
the sides will castle you know it's like
you know
it cannot find a way for black to castle
so it's a there was a proposal you know
to play a chess game without castling i
think from vladimir kramnik you know so
here's a perfect example
of how dangerous it might get for those
who don't know the uh the direct uh
reference elmira is making the alpha
zero papers vladimir the chess expert
sort of uh brought on to google's team
uh at deepmind as they did the alpha
zero neural net machine learning project
which was a fascinating project and one
of the variants was that the proposal
that you would play normal chess but
you're just not allowed to castle like
it's not even a move anymore and
it was i think one of the more
interesting variants to consider right
because it's it's it allows a lot of
things that we know to be prevalent but
king safety becomes a real issue in a
lot of games which is a lot of fun so
all right fabi didn't go for
what we were saying maybe with castles
and f4 he played g5
in the game i just had one question if
you can quickly get back to this
variation because i assume that it was
made but
no with castling just to understand
these ideas because i wanted to take on
b3 i thought that was made but we still
had you know just f5 you played i think
i don't want to play at five no
oh okay but the f5 i was thinking just
uh
to play take
i think f5 is is just bad because of
knight five no no but what if you take
on g6 i still can't figure it out
because i wanted to play rookie one
okay one check
why can't you take the piece yes that's
it
takes b3 if you just take the knight
because you know it's no checkmate it
looks very dangerous one knight b1 and
suddenly it's like wait a second is that
worth the piece and the engine the cold
hearted engine cold blooded this is h6
g6 and black's better this is what i
don't understand because
what i thought is like rookie one is
made of course i miss nightmare because
i just disagree fundamentally
religiously with where this position is
going but apparently the computer says
no black is better you know what
computer
i don't want anything doesn't it seem
completely insane this isn't safe yeah
this is so this position is better for
black who's down a piece for
just two pawns right now and doesn't
seem like a checkmate is coming there's
a threat of taking h2
there's i mean natural move threats i
guess just to bring pieces out maybe
this bishop gets involved at some point
it's obviously a mess because i think we
could say the computers is better but
also it's pretty it's close enough to
say this is one of those what do we say
they say in the books when they don't
know the answer unclear yeah this is
unclear and
now you have this queen i ate ideas with
rook now that i started
like digging deeper queen eight would i
give rugby one queen i took a one minute
that's another mate yeah yeah okay well
all right
we'll see where this goes because i want
to kind of just catch us back up to the
live position because there's some other
crazy stuff going on
apparently the perugia due to game might
be about to peter out so i want to head
over there uh as you can see everybody
he only has 16 i mean since last game
against yon where he took a ton of time
right now this game
history repeating here
i
and and and not getting anything i'm
going to go back to a story that i said
i didn't double down on it early on
because you know there's no reason to
but almira i said that
the other dr the so the pro of the
storyline of you didn't play this year
right you're keeping some things secret
you're reinventing yourself maybe you'll
show some new openings we've seen a
little bit of that the con is the direct
reference to talbot vinnick right and
the self you know autobiography about
the match and again like it
it's still a game and when you have to
manage your time make critical decisions
right under pressure calculate your
weight through variations you can't
replicate that unless you're playing
against the best chess players in the
world the only event he played was in
bucharest it did not go well right and
we see some i don't want to call it
clock miss management because what else
was he going to do yesterday besides
think he was losing but here he's been
better and still like just an hour down
on the clock doesn't seem to have
settled in in these games here but i
mean what do you think that that's my
practical argument is that he's his time
management is showing well he does feel
a bit rusty like someone say he's rusty
so does ding you know he ha he haven't
played that many tournaments
so um rugby won
maybe amazing secrets by the way queen
takes princesses
this is like beautiful stuff yeah a lot
of fun the geometry that saves this game
is actually just gorgeous queen of one
well yeah and just look at this move the
only move there was queen takes d4
because if you traded rooks first
thinking you're winning the night back
you get background checkmate so the
mutual background checkmate what's funny
is white complete brook takes a1 here
and queen of f1
yes exactly oh no my queen anyway all
right so i know i went on a long tangent
there because i think it's something
i've been curious about because ali raza
farusha disappeared and a lot of fans
were missing him right and he wasn't
playing online chess either it wasn't
just that he wasn't playing over the
board he wasn't playing anything and i
wonder if if that's something that you
know he needs to shake off the rust as
fast as possible here in madrid but if
you think of the flip side of rust his
experience and no matter how much he was
playing he just doesn't have the
experience that others do and he had a
fantastic a meteoric rise
i mean to get to 2800
his age hadn't been done before so
nobody is dismissing the potential
and i wouldn't go and dismiss the
current
for when you say potential it often
means that they're not there yet no no
he's there he's a star
but this tournament is just one that he
hasn't played before fact he's never
played the candidates and the canons are
so special because you're playing 14
games in a row
against players that are
incredibly difficult to defeat and if
you make a mistake they will beat you
whereas on his rise he did beat some of
the players and we see the result in the
books the draw is agreed to there are no
pieces remaining um this is fair but he
beat duda four times he's shown that he
can beat some of these players
but he hasn't done it round after round
after round around the way that fabiano
caruana has just it's just a fact so
farouza still has his chances in this
event i'm not counting him out and if
you do then that's on you and this is
wrong
but i think that you know he's a
youngster and he is just getting his
feet beneath him
i just had a small observation that's
the first time that i've seen uh lyriza
not smiling after finishing the game
because even after his loss you know
yesterday
you still had a smile and wanted to
analyze because that was a
very intense battle right but
here like he left the board he never
smiled he left the board immediately you
know he he didn't analyze his opponent
he was clearly disappointed
speaking of his opponents we're
analyzing his next two opponents with
that game in the books he gets white
again so that's a pro against bobby or
caruana but not someone who he's played
well against
right we see two losses there and then
ends with ding so robert you said it
this is
this is the first half of an event of
this event that is really going to
challenge the young ferugia nobody has
ever won the candidates their first time
in the tournament right and for him to
turn things around does it have to start
with game six and seven actually i think
kind of a start today not that he's out
of it but when you look at these
pairings he does have four
black pieces in the first seven rounds
which in the back half he gets the first
move advantage for the games but duda
was the player that you pencil in on
your uh you know your list of opponents
you're like that's the guy that i
usually beat yeah and i'm four wins no
losses against him and everybody else
are kind of like no i can beat them but
you're not like looking at that game the
other games like this is one that i need
to win because when you white against
fabiano it doesn't matter what color you
have against him he could beat you if
you make one inaccuracy and duda of
course can punish otherwise he just
hasn't done that in his career thus far
so i think that ali reza i mean today
was a
a big missed chance because
it's just about the result right often
as chess players it's about how you put
pressure on your opponent where you'll
feel okay with a draw as long as you
were able to make that sustained
pressure you knew you were better and
you made them suffer for a while if they
played like hikaru nakamura did and
survived that suffering just credits the
opponent but when you liquidate and
seemingly in like 15 minutes and then
the game just draw you're kind of like
i'm not on my a-game
yeah
well i think you painted it well right
it's not just that it was a draw it was
the lack of fire but we are not lacking
fire in the game between nakamura and
upon rishi elmira
icaru found your move
rookie 3 as the best response to queen
to d3
and after queen to b1 and d5
we see 97 and we see the advantage for
white remaining i think that nakamura
will not will not make this mistake of
taking e7 given that c1 is hanging i'm
guessing knight d4 is is the main option
maybe there's other options here on
mirror
well we
like d4 seems
uh very strong to me
because you know i cannot see how black
can coordinate his pieces you know
that's probably the biggest trouble
meaning you don't see how black and
white yeah i don't understand the thing
i just spotted about knight d4 now that
it's on the board is it also guards b3
so i'm immediately considering whether i
can respond here note that this is a
different position than we had before
because if you go for this line i can
take this pawn now maybe i can't because
i'm mouse slipping but you get it uh the
so knight g4 is a double attack of not
just the bishop but also the b3 square
although when the queen slides over to
a1 like we've seen in many positions it
also attacks the knight that's on d4 so
okay that's fair it may give a key move
black the necessary time to attack the
knight and then try to defend b7 we can
see it's good for white but
i mean in this moment in knight d4 the
bishop i guess doesn't necessarily have
to move from f5 which is because the 97
defends it so
the move queen b6 like just retreating
throwing our pieces backwards that's
another option that is in fact possible
here i guess
it's a very clever way queen b6 you know
to um
to keep the balance because i still
cannot take on e7 because you attack my
knight on d4
so
yeah because by the way everyone the mo
the moment white can taking two pieces
from the rook would be an easy decision
for hikaru and probably an easily
winning end game so if this queen is not
spying a piece look for hikar to go for
that looks like he was just about to go
for the night he was reaching
another idea that but why can't i
like queen b6
rook is seven ah you play queen d4
immediately okay that's a very important
uh okay your idea was obviously it takes
you take a five okay but then i wanted
to play rook c7 that's why i dismissed
it uh
this is probably possible but it may not
be as much of an edge as you want the
work gets trapped oh again
the rook is always running out of
spirits yeah
okay okay
all right well hey karu
is he gonna find knight d4 is there
another move here
i i was thinking that you know again
moving the queen to a square because the
other thing i've been spying is just
finishing development coordinating my
pieces and it's
not just because you know you know what
i'm thinking about always you know a
little checkmate over here but not
really a thing in this position
but hikar i mean he's hesitating right
now and if we look at the clock 27
minutes and we're on move it's about to
be wise 25th move and we're just talking
about the before you need to be precise
if he makes one inaccurate move that
evaluation goes from plus one and a half
to we've seen many different ones go to
plus only point five or even completely
level so jan
he's the good thing about his bad
position
is that there are going to be a few only
moves where like you see that your
queen's under attack and you move your
queen away or now the threat is rook
takes knight on e7 and gain two pieces
so you have to deal with that so
the position the foundation of it and it
looks like knight d4
knight d2
okay
interesting
i wasn't expecting that one
well because taking a different approach
to coordinating you cannot play queen b6
here so you're
you have two options queen a1 and queen
c2
right you need to keep in touch with
that bishop on c1
yeah if you move the queen to anywhere
that doesn't attack c1 rook takes e7
will be played
but but a passive move right maybe
hikaru has different plans for the
knight than d4 is it doing something
over here
maybe queen a1 is met by knight b3 and
then if you go queen b one knight
well
what do we obtain this like then we just
transpose
also the queen can go back to f6 like
that queen can just sprint back over
there and while black is all tied up and
passive there are no like weaknesses in
the position right we have six pawns for
black it's not even easy to start
targeting anything so that's the good
thing for yana and he's kind of forced
to make certain moves and after that
it's not like there's a night outpost
there's no pawn that hickor just gang up
on so i really believe that when yon
paused and played queen d3
he felt a renewed sense of belief in
himself in his position and we can see
him working hard his head's not in his
hands he's like you know what this game
is not over i i did something that i
can't even possibly comprehend but now
that we're here
let's keep digging yeah
well that's good maybe it took a couple
of mistakes for yon to kind of find
himself but if he is indeed feeling
confident again after queen of d3 then
we might be seeing the uh the nepo that
we know who
qualified his way into the world
championship let's take stock again of
what the expectations were on nepo and
the great player that he was in our
nextjust.com it is excuse me in our next
chest.com player profile
the defending champion jan napomnishi is
back at the candidates affecting his
second straight bid to challenge for the
world chess championship
one of the more experienced players nepo
brings to madrid an aggressive style
that is both challenging to face and
entertaining to watch
two years ago nepo made the most of his
debut in the candidates with a round to
spare he won the event in convincing
fashion
that's all he needed yon napon mushi is
the 2021 world chess championship
challenger
that victory led nepo to a world
championship match with carlson and also
secured his return to the candidates in
madrid this year
despite being one of only two players in
the field to have won the candidates the
expectations for nepo are not
particularly high this time around
however his confidence from having won
here before in addition to his years of
competitive experience may offer him a
shot to turn some heads
if nepo should pull a major upset and
face magnus carlsen again the two know
each other well
nepo has competed against carlson for
decades ever since the two prodigies
were 12 years old
maybe maybe riding the ship here against
ikaro nakamura
expectations again on yon do you agree
with sort of the summary that that uh
john you had just that maybe the world's
expectations weren't that high for
napalm rashid but he certainly doesn't
feel that way based on how he's playing
robert yeah i think i mean
i wasn't gambling on this event but i
saw the odds makers and he was all the
way towards the bottom i think that
people thought that maybe he was a
one-hit wonder that you know he didn't
win anything before the candidates he
hasn't really won anything after he lost
very badly to magnus carlsen in their
match although it was really tight for
the first
five and you know three-fourths games or
even towards the stretch of game six so
i think that people just somehow
think of yon is like ah you know he
can't do it again but of course he can
and as we have his results thus far he
gets white against dude tomorrow he's
already at three points and if he can
hold this game i think in some ways
holding a game where you've made a
mistake is the best confidence builder
because not just when people are
misplaying things against you or playing
an opening they don't know and of course
he had to work for those victories
against dingley wren and other reasons
for ruja but when you have to just give
it your all because you're the one who
did something wrong and you're still
able to survive that game i think that
can give you all the confidence in the
world we feel like well i am handing
chances to my opponents and they still
didn't beat me that must make you feel
really really good
well mary henkaro kind of backed up that
storyline robert just said in the last
interview i had with him before the
candidates he won another event on
chess.com go figure but he said that
often you feel
one of the biggest indicators that
you're on form is is not how you win but
actually how well you can hold bad
positions so your thoughts just more on
on that that storyline
well i agree with it of course and
well once again the computers have
showed us that chess has um
so many defensive resources that we
previously
ignored and now we're well that we are
aware and as you have said that before
we might have resigned in certain
positions but well now you continue to
play on and you find uh
very difficult moves
so uh
well hikari is in great form in this
tournament i somehow i am
worried a bit that
he is feeling a lot of pressure in this
game because he knows that he has to
deliver here because he has an advantage
and he's getting very low on time i mean
for the classical time control he has
like 15 more moves to make 15 more moves
to make and like
20 a little bit more than 20 minutes so
he knows that he needs to be precise and
i'm afraid he's going to get into a
very difficult time scramble yeah i
think he feels it's slipping yeah i
agree and i think i think the time
pressure thing is even even more of a
talking point because if knight d2
wasn't as accurate as knight d4 the
advantage has already come down a little
bit less an unclear position without a
lot of time on the clock versus
nepambashi is um usually not a recipe
for success so even if you are hikaru
nakamura queen a1 i mean look at this
position if you showed this to the
players in zurich 1953
they'd be like what game are you playing
i mean there's a question yes all right
there's a queen on a1 and um that queen
is darting right back to f6 and as soon
as that happens then you start looking
at the like wait is black even
worse anymore we see the evaluation bar
black is in fact with a disadvantage but
i mean i think from the perspective of a
player when you're sitting there like
this is not as good as it once was and
instead of thinking it still is better
even if it's not as big of an advantage
as i had some of you just let it all
slip you're like nope this is fine for
black i don't i don't see any way to
get the knockout knight b3
that was kind of what we were predicting
but you made the point that the queen
doesn't have to go back to b1
you can go to f6 i love
because i was thinking for example if uh
well hikaru would be
mcenroe you know
and he would stand up at the times like
would go to the arbiter he doesn't
respect me
please
exactly was uh
well chess has changed and different
times
i like the plan though from hikaro i
mean we see it now sewing you know
clearly he had something in mind when he
goes knight d2 knight b3 a player of
icarus level blood and this move bishop
d2 was by the way he gave it a little
bit of a gary kasparov shake when he put
it like not quite the twist but it was
like a
two right and he like puts it on d2 it
actually has a bright future
maybe on c3 maybe even on b4
right
go ahead you just miss a great pop
culture oh i was going to say he gets to
wear shades
you could have said shake and not stir
shake it
he prefers his bishop shake and not stir
but all right
let's back up and make sure we take a
peek at the other games because this
this one could suck us in big time but
omgs are snaps the car honor report game
it just is getting more and more wild we
might even be in the end looking back at
a positional masterpiece by one of the
players in rajab dingley wren but hey
we're a sucker for tactics and we're
going to go right back to caruana report
uh sorry everybody um
how did the queen get on g7 let us go to
there we're going to back up and find
out rook d1 was met by bishop b4
which invites queen d4
a double attack of the bishop and pawn
and report
plays queen a5 and just says i don't
care honeybadger takes what he wants you
take that pawn but i've got pressure
over here
and then
what
oh my goodness
man what a game here and my first
thought was if i play rook a1 can you
actually take on b2 or what's happening
i think you can let's show it rookie one
you take b2 because that takes you get a
queen with check but then your queen's
hanging out and the knight is pinned oh
my god
you protect the knight and the queen is
hanging
and the rook is hanging and then you
play f5 at the end you remove the knight
from protecting the rook on h8 like i
think that the position is collapses for
black so you allow black to get
sacrifice the queen gets a new queen
with check and then immediately loses
the game that's that's fun
it's fun for you i mean
i am a nervous nelly over here and i
don't even know why it's not my game um
a3 what are the other options rookie one
looks fascinating
the other option is to find a way to
unpin the knight so that the knight
could hop in can you play something like
kinky two
no
e2 you said e2 yes okay king f2 maybe
well it
could be maybe king of two was better i
don't know why
why is like
the computer doesn't like there's some
bishop f8 and like b4 and then the king
being on the light squares may be
misplaced in some of these okay so same
right idea from elmira maybe but let's
put the king on a safer square on f2
wrong square yes okay so i understand
what if like just takes you
let's just let's not even pretend like
we need to figure this out so they got
to do the work we can just analyze you
you need to move the knights 92. i want
to go here man what i don't want to move
the night i just want to go all in but
take i don't know just come on and
can you play bishop c3
you probably can play bishop c3 as well
i was just going to move my bishop to
the bbc
i want f5 and just everything okay fine
you want it all and you want it now i
want it all and i want it now thank you
veruca
what in the world is happening in this
position it says zeros and it's like
either player more likely black could
just be lost in like three moves but
it's one of the most fascinating things
of 2800 level chess is that every move
has an opportunity to be a blunder yet
they're maintaining the balance so well
and i see why e5
traps the black queen the white queen
excuse me so you you're gonna like
bishop f8 and the queen goes to f6 and
you play bishop e7 and then this is the
line
the computer says that this is just
going to end in a fancy draw it's
incredible
wow
and i'm almost one like sacrifice the
white queen somehow and
wow what a ridiculous position we have
here
but what i think what was really
important about what you're pointing out
robert is that
if the players don't see that line then
this position is not zeros elmira right
i mean that's the point there's one line
that's zeros and if that line doesn't
happen we're going to have a train wreck
here well it's like like having a
universe mysteries being unveiled in
front of us right that's like that's a
total chaos but yet everything is in
perfect order
the taoism of chess it's richard reports
style but fabi i mean look at him right
we have my camera here he looks like
he's just calculating and this is the
type of position that he does tend to
thrive in so something that other
players do is they make speculative
decisions whereas fabi you know maybe it
prevents him from winning certain games
because he's not taking the risk think
about how report got here he won that
final game in the second uh grand prix
leg where he took a risk and he was he
reaped the rewards of that risk i mean
against uh
and that's on draken exactly in the
final and that was brilliant but imagine
he lost that game he wouldn't be here
and nobody would be calling that
decision brilliant and because it was
risky so fabiano is not really the type
of player who just like throws pieces at
his opponent and says hopefully this
works out he's going to sit here he has
40 minutes on the clock it's still
plenty of moves until time control but
he's going to evaluate
am i going to move my king and is f2
really better than e2 or can i put my
cumulus diagonal and perhaps that's okay
can i make this rook a1 move which is as
spicy as it gets because black can
can take on b2 giving up a queen to get
a new one and then we found out that's
not good for black so it just kind of
says no you think about it your turn to
figure out if this is going to be okay
it's really
an immensely difficult position to
calculate
elmira i want to go back to the point
robert made about whether bobby likes
speculative decisions because i actually
did a video series with him about his
world championship match with magnus and
he talked about that game eight which
maybe in hindsight was really the best
chance he would have had to win the
world championship he chose this move h3
instead of queen h5 for those who know
the game and favi okay now he does play
the very accurate technical move bobby
was critical of himself in saying
sometimes his strength is his weakness
that because he doesn't make speculative
decisions
the time where he really needed to that
wasn't his instinct right so
what what would you say about that well
i would not feel that this is definitely
true now because i've seen so many games
where he was going for the long term
initiative especially for example if you
remember a game against dink in the last
candidates which he lost but he
sacrificed two pounds in a very
speculative ways so you know i think
that he's made some adjustments
and maybe he's trying to be um
more precise about it you know it's
sometimes you're taking a very
calculated risk by the way they're good
wow they're going through this line this
is insane this is going to be the draw
bishop f8 bishop seven queen f6 queen
this is
this one this is welcome to 2800 level
chess ladies and gentlemen
i mean seriously this is fascinating and
brilliant but if this is a draw this
might be one of the most exciting draws
we're going to get in the entire event
it also might only be like 24 moves and
people like they only drew 24 moves
they're not trying do you understand how
rich this game was there's a black pawn
on b2
neither side is castled
i mean
e5 is just a great move by reporting
perhaps even a cold shower for fabiano
who was maybe liking his chances playing
for initiative but there is no way
possible to stop bishop f8 bishop b7 now
the queen can slide via f6 to f5 so
maybe there is a way that fabi can play
on but he might also switch on if you
play a five which is the best move right
you play f5 but what if you should take
on e5 for example yeah okay i have an
idea queen of six what if i play key one
right castling by hand and opening the f
file then i can do your idea okay and
queen effect and now i i now i have
threats of taking e5 oh computer says
yeah danny good call yeah but okay look
black's best move i just saw was castle
okay okay
okay let's i would love for this game to
continue because as you said this has
been a rich game this has been a
spectacular performance from both
players of of accuracy and frankly guts
like you said on mira like these
rapport loves chaos he thrives in this
stuff but fabi's not shying away from
the battle so
let them play on come on chat let's send
them the positive vibes right what what
fabiano might do though is if he thinks
he has this draw in his pocket he might
go watch the yanapomshi games against a
car nakamura
because the last thing he would want is
yan to win and then he draws and then
now it's a full point it's a full point
distance so it's too early to really
consider what your adversaries are doing
but i do think that fabiano if he plays
queen f6 queen g7 he can say you know
what this is not the moment where i need
to take an unnecessary risk because
i mean there's a pawn on b2 that pawn is
one square away from queening and so
black could easily win this game if
white just says i'm gonna move my king
and try to avoid the draw so um elmira
robert is excited about the point well
and what i wanted to say is it it's all
started with bishop c6 a very quiet move
remember six it all started there yeah
it all starts starting there c6 was
brilliant from report i mean
i wondered i wonder how much of it was
just at the board or coming in and
playing a interesting line in the timon
of like this
how much rapport was prepared for this
type of fight so
i i think this is report doing what he
does best showcasing his brilliance and
i mean wow what a game we have in store
and what a game it's already been and if
i take on e5 are you castling still like
bishop of faith bishop f e7 a queen f5
your castle probably yeah and i can
castle queen signs on position i mean
the white king is no safer and well this
in this game the kings are
chat we see you screaming for hikaru
we've got the game board back up we're
uh in fact we may not even wait for
bobby to make his move but that
another move by hikaru already played
knight a5
the big the big thing i think that uh
you know chat is getting excited about
slash nervous about because we know
there are so many fans is he is he's 12
moves to make
in only 13 minutes
and his evaluation or his edge that's
slipping a little bit
knight a5
i mean okay forget about what the
computer says
i see the idea he's attacking the pawn
and if b6 is played the knight's coming
to c6 that looks like a very strong
square
yeah
so
i kind of like the idea of 985 maybe
there was something better but at least
he has a clear plan he wants this he
wants the knight on c6 to put the bishop
on c3 and just sort of strangle black a
little bit because the queen and the
knight they're running out of squares so
but i feel like b6 is a move you kind of
have to play at some point
and then after knight c6 you think where
the knight looks good in on c6 and
probably will go there um but can i not
bring my bishop back to d7 and just
flush that knight out of c6 right
this was kind of my thought about the
goal but you're right maybe the queen
just moves somewhere
here
how is white crashing through right and
if you don't crash through and you get
black couple turns we talked about the
pawn structure that a3 pawn still loose
over there the bishop can park on c5 in
some positions and if that bishop gets a
c5 it could be the white king that's
suddenly in some danger over here
wow okay
uh
robert's long-term foreshadowing
of white's potential problems in this
structure could be coming back to haunt
nakamura if he doesn't find the most
accurate moves elmira is there maybe he
can play bishop c3 first though before
knight to c6
what are your thoughts on where this
game is headed
well it's a very unexpected turn of
events
i think from chess point of view
psychologically as we were trying to
predict it but then i think i think that
now he has to find a way to exchange the
bailout so maybe to play bishop c3
knight e5 to exchange the
the last pair of knights and
um
when you'll said bishop c3 do you think
the car was already trying to bail out i
think he needs to do so okay well that
would be
a huge turn of events but given the time
pressure situation i'm not sure i can
really disagree with you i mean the more
we look at the fact that the edge has
slipped if you if you make this too
spicy and black gets bishop c5 and queen
g5
and knight f4 or knight h4
and it's what i was trying to highlight
earlier we said plus two there was some
sequence that you know with
absolute precision you maintain this
advantage but the foundation and jan
plays bishop should be some c this is
what i mean if he plays instantly yeah
he's capable of finding the best moves
but earlier that queenie for me was just
bad but what he's doing now is he's
saying
the worst is behind me my piece is now
on good squares none of my pawns can be
attacked and so that plus two from
earlier it wasn't two extra pawns that's
what it means in computer speak right
you're two pawns better but it wasn't
being up two pawns in a rook end game it
was still really complicated that car
couldn't find the right path forward
he's now playing bishop c3 i do think we
will see
this queen just hop on over to g5 from
yon and if that rook leaves e3
then black can try to take over the e
file at any moment black can consider
playing bishop take c6 uh the a3 pawn is
loose that knight on g6 could hop into
the game of course white is hanging in
there white's fighting but talmur's
point i think even if you don't
ultimately bail out you need to have
that in your back pocket you need to
make sure that at every sequence
that there could be a series of trades
that mean that you're not going to get
in trouble because this is the exact
type of game where someone with a huge
advantage at some point they're feeling
it they're like i gotta win because i
was better and they don't recalibrate
and say
am i still better right now they think
sometimes that psychological trick like
i was better so i am better but right
now we can see the evaluation bar
we also see that we're about to have a
handshake uh in the game between
fabiano and report unfortunately he did
not hear our call that we wanted this
game to continue
so uh
we we see that f5 was indeed played
bishop e7 and bishop f8
the only real option for black and to
remind you everybody it is the only
option because if you move the knight
you lose the rook
so
that's it report is brilliant and
fabiano is a very stable player yeah
like he was not going to take the risk
there bobby didn't go for the spicy and
probably objectively worse rook a1 moves
or or what i was hoping for this king
chi one keep the queens on the board but
um
our second sort of short game in this
round we've already seen a draw between
all the resurrection and jan christophe
dude if you're just tuning in
but this this was the opposite of that
if you were here you heard robin's
comments on
kind of the fact that it never froze was
never able to get anything this could
have gone wrong for either player so
they get credit for bringing the fight
and being accurate to the draw i think
favian was upset because he had the
white pieces and he couldn't make the
most of it couldn't capitalize and get a
victory but also the type of game that
gets stuck in your head forever and
you're just like can we talk about this
position for the next three hours oh
wait we gotta go prepare so yeah good to
play you richard those who are good
friends um but it was a fun battle but
unfortunately for fabiano not a good
result because he had the white pieces
you need to
strike with white generally speaking for
report a great result and he's shown his
own resilience in this event two games
to black before this he was in huge
trouble now with the black pieces i mean
he gave fondby everything that he could
handle because if bobby played on it
would have been lost himself getting in
trouble well
amir this game might see a similar fate
we already see
a repetition here what are the chances
you think we see uh bishop back to c3
and not some other move from hikaru i
think it would be a very good practical
decision here yes given his clock yes of
course it's um
or he can repeat get
closer to the time control but i think
it would be
safer to take a draw here especially
robert explained very well like that
once again your mind is playing these
tricks on you so you were better and
this is haunting you yeah well you said
hikaru made comments about the time
control right we know that he's been
doing amazing post game analysis videos
for his youtube community he's also
often been joining his own channel if
you didn't know that
talk a little bit more about why this is
so dangerous right nine moves with 11
minutes and the increment time control
we saw for 20 years is very different
than no no increment and hikaru's
criticism elmira was that it seems to be
changing a lot right like it's like that
he wants feed a to decide on the right
time control for top level chess right
well and i agree with this although i
told you before that i find this time
control rather logical you know so you
would add this extra 30 seconds only
at the last stage of the game where you
would need it to convert an advantage
not to lose with an extra queen but
playing with different time controls
it's very difficult for professional
chess players because they have to
handle
team competitions individual
competitions with the time control where
you have to adjust yourself all the time
so
i really find that he has a very um well
it's a good point so yeah it's it's
funny because i think i agree with you
too i think it's a good point from
hikaru but i also kind of like this time
control if they can stick to it
i think takaru
uh probably doesn't like his position
enough we see that head shake there
doesn't like his position enough to
continue
kind of knows that he let he let an
advantage slip he may not know exactly
where yet in his head or maybe he does
knowing hikaru um
but i think that's a that's a look that
says
yeah that's a resignation to the draw
rez he's resigned to the draw
shaking his head perhaps it was then the
moment of knight d2 instead of knight d4
who knows uh what what he'll feel in
hindsight he could have done to keep an
edge
yeah it's it's a position where he he
like
clearly wants to play on like he wants
the hunger inside of him that
chess player who wants to strive for
victory he's like maybe i should do this
but look where his eyes are concentrated
all on the queen side over here so he's
looking at bishop b4 he's also looking
if black were to take this knight on c6
that's you know an imposing piece can i
get away with that like
i got some bad pawns there's a bishop
against night scenario will that be
acceptable and he doesn't really have
the time to calculate it because it's
not just about
seeing the position in your mind's eye
it's about assessing it correctly both
players can see bishop takes e6 pawn
takes you sick and stop there and be
like oh it's a bishop for a knight bad
pawn structure for white but now you
have a light square bishop that if you
could bring that bishop into the game
then that's great but you need to assess
it properly and he just has nine minutes
just about to say you're talking a lot
about the disparity or the difference of
opinion maybe about which move to play
here but i think the disparity on the
clock
is ultimately what's going to be
influencing his decision right 40
minutes
of an advantage young young maybe got
away with one we were talking oh yeah it
was it was playing too fast it was not
the type of habits jan has built elmira
that got him into the world championship
match
but he caught himself just in time found
this queen d3 move and then has been
very probably played the best move on
the board every move ever since
yes i agree with this but
robert also said that they were
they were the only moves yeah so he had
to find those of course there were
difficult ones but
uh now he coordinated his pieces
and
it's funny we can see yon standing
behind us here
we see we see hikaru there we can see
yon standing over hikaru right here for
the record the computer says white
should play g3 here i just looked at it
and it says that uh on to robert's point
white may still have an edge even if
black takes on c6 but like you said it's
the imbalance of that position combined
with the imbalance we have on the clock
that is likely going to influence icaru
to accept the draw and not keep the
fight on it's a move you play when you
have ample time to calculate but you
then play and you're like am i really
going to win this game or am i risking
the lose because it's a big decision to
play g3 the point is you protect
in air quotes then knight or the pawn on
c6 because at the end with the pawn on
g3 right the bishop gets the g2 so
um white defends that pawn tactically
speaking so that's you know where it
makes sense but i mean you're looking at
the clock icar keeps thinking the more
clock he burns the less time he has for
the remaining moves and it's not like
the game just ends with g3 and all is
said and done like there's a lot of life
left in that position but he's thinking
about it
we see i saw a couple of comments in
chat wondering about the ding name we
see that he's got an advantage there is
black don't worry we'll probably have
plenty of time to get there because i
have a feeling that the number one
player from china might have his first
real chance to win at the candidates
even with the black pieces in today's
game but okay we'll get to that in a
little bit
don't you stress we don't want to miss
we don't want to miss what could be the
final moments of nakamura's round five
there's very bad news for the field if
they might run out if dingley wins the
black pieces don't worry you hold your
rope we are going to dive into that
wins with the black pieces oh boy you
better uh you better change whatever
plans you had to not be watching our
coverage every day in madrid because we
might have another dog entering the
fight in a real way um
well i think we know it he's now four
and a half minutes in and i think elmira
with here he goes with every second that
went by the result was even more certain
that he would not choose to play a
fighting move that move offers a draw to
yonda pomnishi
um
when when jan comes back i believe he
can actually call the arbor if he wants
before playing queen f6 um remember how
the rule works before the position is on
the board
you're supposed to
you're supposed to make the claim
so um you have to write the move down
stop the clock and make the claim yeah
you have to write the move down stop the
clock and make the question you have to
write the move down on the scoresheet to
prove to the arbiter
tell them that's the move you intend to
play
hey carlo he's put on his coat sorry i
got distracted which means the car was
just waiting for yon to come back we're
not we're not going to go anywhere until
this game ends in a draw it's going to
happen the moment young comes back to
the board in fact here it is great
advice for you know the uh average
player but super gm they don't wait for
the arbor they make the move they look
at each other they play a little eye
dodging right and then we've we've had
it happen here though i don't know if
you saw them where they're around we had
someone do it the old-fashioned way yeah
the arbiter wow because you're right
most of the time that's not what happens
say carl puts on it yeah look both sides
they have too much pride to do it
neither one of them is gonna do it but
now yawn is taking a peek
is this like an unspoken thing it's like
me and my wife neither one of us wants
to say we're sorry
it's like how long are we just gonna
stare at each other here
okay finally
yeah they both know right there
i wish i could hear what they were
saying
yeah no we have commentary provided by
danny every day
of those moments yes
okay i think he's he's probably
describing what went wrong for him in
the line
kind of saying what he forgot
oh yeah he said cd5 25
that's what he was describing
yeah
and that's such an important safe uh for
young yeah very important
it may we talked about how a loss could
put him on till guys
if he goes on to win this we might be
talking about this game as one of the
early games that that really uh
influenced his 2022 candidates victory
so
uh
they're they're still analyzing here
the arbiter by the way shout out to the
arbiter being very conscious about the
cameras oh i thought the arbiter was
giving his advice in the position
[Laughter]
like a car did you miss 194 buddy
because
yeah but you can just look at the
player's faces and what's happening here
hikaru is like super upset with how that
game went john's like sweet i drew it
yeah i just drew a game i should have
drawn and speaking of hikaru
uh whether he's upset or not we know
that he bounces back well even if things
don't go his way but
tomorrow he'll need to do it against the
highest rated player in the field coming
in and someone who might be getting his
first victory against dingley wren so
that should be a very interesting game
uh tomorrow getting his second first
move in a row half the feel gets the
same color two games in a row it's
really interesting right it's it's one
of the ways they even it out i think
based in the end but um anyway
white against ding and then black
against dude is what faces hikaru in the
first half of the candidates here
huh we still have one game going here in
round five at the candidates in madrid
and all eyes will be on that man right
there
from china can dingly wren find the mojo
can he find the mojo can stella get her
groove back in a position with an
advantage
versus
tame over java but okay
before we head to the break one real
quick reminder to our community that if
you want to share your thoughts then
then get involved
join our discord community we have this
we have a discussion room set up every
single round uh it's there for you use
the command discord in chat to join the
conversation exchange ideas observations
all the things that you see talk about
what robin and i are wearing that day or
the different songs elmira is singing
over there and
get involved let us know how much you're
enjoying the show we're going to take a
very quick break when we come back we
have one game to focus on one man who's
gonna try to see if he can right his
ship we'll be back from madrid in just a
few moments don't go anywhere
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
the feed day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed a
chess.com grand swiss ali reza farouza
won the grand swiss turned the heads of
everyone in doing so and has become the
youngest player in history to cross the
2800 evo rating barrier he would become
the youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the us
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikara nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in
madrid fide awarded one of the eight
spots to the wild card invite grand
master tamor rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
punched his ticket by ousting none other
than world champion magnus carlson in
the semi-finals of that event judo would
ultimately defeat karyakin in the final
to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent dingley ren takes the spot due to
being the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
[Music]
and we are back here by the way the
candidates is going but the chess kids
have their own candidates going how
awesome would it be to play on the same
boards of your chess heroes i never had
that chance
that would be amazing shout out to all
the kids in this event
super fun to see this happening
i mean
i i literally think this is like one of
the coolest things we've ever done to be
honest
having these kids come here and playing
the candidates and i say we shout out to
the chess kid team it was their
brilliant idea
and uh it's been awesome and exciting to
see more content for you if you're
looking for more content
in between these amazing matches here by
the best players in the world check out
chess kid tv
all
right speaking of chess kid tv
uh
one of the winners of that event may
actually end up being interviewed by us
so we'll see we'll come back around and
confirm on that
well when i was a kid
dingley wren was would have been one of
the players would have been one of you
winning that event yeah and uh dingley
wren is the only game still going here
inside the playing hall
uh will he
will he get the w with the black pieces
against tamworth over java what is what
a story that would end up being for
today but back here in the studio
upstairs we have elmira kripchenko
robert hess
danny wrench we're having a great time
we hope you are too
uh the game that just threw us into a
bit of a tizzy right before the break
was the draw between nakamura and
napomnishi we talked a little bit about
what's facing hikaru in the next two
rounds let's remind everybody of what's
facing nepo in the next two rounds
before all eyes focus on the battle
between rajab and dingley ren
white against duda
i mean i'm just looking at yon and just
super impressed right now he just held
that draw now he gets white right back
at it this guy uh in his next two rounds
robert still still the man to beat yeah
if you count he was out four
black pieces in the first seven rounds
during the back half he gets the first
move advantage for the seven games so
he's in great shape he's leading the
tournament right now and he just showed
resilience for the first time like he
against fabiano or undetermined he
didn't have the best position but it
never got to the point where it looked
out of control this game was spiraling
and jan upon she showed that he could
dig his heels in say alright my
position's worse he sat and thought
found that queen d3 move and if not for
that move he was gonna lose that game
before we move on for this i want to say
that because robert just said it is kind
of his tournament to lose right now he
gets four whites on the back half so
does he come into tomorrow's game with
duda as aggressive as he did against ali
rosa farouja elmira or maybe something a
little more solid
well i'm not sure i think he's going to
be aggressive tomorrow because look at
the last round bearings he's playing
against richard reports and what strikes
me he never won against richard you know
so this can be dangerous waters were
expecting so for him so i really think
he has to capitalize on his advantage
he's on plus two now
uh
because the last round is not going to
be like a picnic french would say
nothing's a picnic for anybody in this
event um and another player who uh
didn't have a picnic in this round in
the end he played well but fabio carwana
came up with a draw against rapport when
at one point we thought maybe he was
going to convert a big attack so
uh what do you think he's thinking about
now that he gets the black pieces
against someone hungry for a win and
only runs in perugia
yeah i'd argue that that was the best
kind of picnic where everyone's having a
good time
someone brings great dessert other
people bring the uh
surprise ditch bishop c6 oh this tastes
so good
but going forward against farrugia
that's a tricky pairing i would say for
fabiano i think that he's very pragmatic
so he's not going to look at his head to
head and say i've beaten him twice he's
never beaten me let's try to beat him
from the black side of this game i think
he's more looking at the tournament as a
whole because in round seven he gets the
white piecing of timor hijab up
timor has not been overly impressive
thus far so why should i take some
tremendous risk against maybe the most
dangerous player in the field and the
teenager alabasa frugia when i can just
work my first move advantage in game
seven so you pick your moments in these
tournaments and fabiano being so
experienced he's won this event before i
don't think he's gonna go out of his way
to do anything risky i think he's gonna
try to be solid tomorrow hold if the
opportunity presents itself he will play
for a win but first and foremost is
neutralizing whatever opening prep
alireza has and then he looks at game
seven and if i'm looking at the
tournament overall you have to pick
somebody to try and beat and so far the
job of is probably the opponent that
caron would be looking at you mentioned
the prep though for rouge and it makes
me wonder amira fabi fabi's the
storyline we were covering about his
approach to ferruccia but there's
another person who takes two to tango
right
is he going to have a choice do you
think ferocious is going to really look
to be aggressive tomorrow his last white
in the first half of the event against
fabiano as much as i loved robert's
analysis i was looking at this game from
ferocious perspective there is also
something dangerous about this situation
because he if he loses this game this is
where he crashes so that's
how do you approach this game yeah yeah
okay
so maybe prep hard but don't get too
crazy right that's what you're saying
all right and you're looking at the you
know the head as they're right 500 loss
to either of those two players frugia
good it's a good ending for his first
half but you could also get put in this
comfort zone which is weird like oh
those are my customers those are the
people that i like to ring up the wins
against and so you have to like you know
kind of tame your emotions in this
moment
bobby tame's emotions may be better than
anybody dingley wren trying to tame tame
over jabba in this game it is the only
game still going in round five if you're
just tuning in
three draws uh none of them really
disappointing necessarily the ferruccia
duda game was was not as spicy as the
other two but
we've had exciting chess despite the
peaceful results so don't just look at
the scoreboard back up check out our
highlight videos continue to look at the
analysis because they were interesting
but there's only one interesting battle
that we need to jump into and that is
this game
between where job off and dingley wren i
want to do a big reset in this game i
think we're going to be here for a while
because i think dingley wren is going to
try to push his advantage he can maybe
smell blood and he may not get another
opportunity
because of that i think we can take our
time and go back quite a ways to the
last time we looked at this position it
might shock
the the the people in chat
whoa okay yeah the last time we looked
at this position
was
on move
15 after knight to e5 was played from
dingley rent
that's uh it's been a while and at the
time elmira we were thinking
kind of equal right i mean you know
nothing's super spicy yet and uh the
pawn structure completely symmetrical
maybe even a bit better for white
because i wanted to point out that uh
usually this
positions are played around one square
and this square is c6
you know
might be considered as a weak square
here so that's why uh taymor tried to
he pushed f4 in order you know to
prepare this uh
well we know what happened in the game
and and because we're doing a reset
everyone you'll have to
provide the provide the analysis we're
about to give you with the live position
and contrast because we see that rajab
was aggressive right he advanced looking
at the position he advanced both the e
and the f pawns and he started with the
e pawn
after brook fd8 traded rooks and then
immediately advanced the f pawn so this
this looks
you know
aggressive here comes roger right with
the pawn structure on the king's side so
the question is where did where did he
maybe let it slip a little bit we'll
find out after knight to g6
knight to c4 bishop c5 oh no it was
queen to b7 first that's a nice move
i wonder if already knight to c4
although it looked good might not have
actually been the best move robert
because within a couple moves a3 bishop
c5
that knight was headed right back to d2
and uh we see that dingley wren's pieces
appear a little more coordinated than
whites especially when sometimes you
wish you could move upon back with an
exposed king yeah no black's king is
just safer and that's what's telling the
story because in order to kick black's
pieces away because you're nervous about
all of them you're creating other holes
uh for instance and just a few moves
from now as this game develops here like
white is just thinking like how do i do
something can i play e5 and kick your
knight from f6 and that way i protect my
e4 pawn putting it on a square protected
by pawn but as you're showing it hands
black d5 and f5 and that bishop on b2
will never be a good piece because it
stares into its own pawn right at the
end of the road so yeah these kind of
decisions are not ones you make lightly
and as the game continued here like
white is maneuvering around but doesn't
actually have a plan and what ding is
doing is he's trying to
optimize the placement of his pieces now
he's got a pin on the d-file he has
pressure on the e4 pawn how do you get
out of this pin you have to move your
queen once again and so ding you know he
just continued his shuffling he didn't
have a clear path through just yet but
then he started just uh strike forward
on the king side
yeah it's interesting because
again it's
a position where the computer lights
black and i i guess it's just because of
what you're pointing out that white
seems to have more targets but
the more we look at it the more we look
at the live position i mean
there's nothing concrete for either
player just yet this move is fantastic
h5 because look at the knight on d4 the
it requires the defense of both the
bishop on b2 and the knight on f3 so now
the threat from ding's point of view is
by h4
giving up that pawn in two different
ways you can't take with a knight
because you lose your d4 knight and if
you take with your makes a move to show
it yeah and if you take with the pawn on
f4 instead so you don't drop a piece
then your pawn f4 is a target in
addition to the double isolated h-pawn
so this is just not a situation you want
you can already see the evaluation going
sky high for black because knight h5
will take care of the f4 pawn
h5 just continues to be the move we see
people play on mira when they're playing
for a win the alpha zero influence
continues it's like you could say i'm
gonna sit on the position but if you
think you're better
advance the h pawn and again it's it's
it's kind of funny but it's just an idea
that not to say that chess players
weren't aware of before you know alpha
zero bursts on the scene but really
appreciating the depth of of how there's
always some way to pry open a seemingly
looking solid position forces for java
to play h4 and then
now we have a new weakness so yeah h5
what a what a fantastic way to pry
things open
a little bit of tickle
rook ca queen d3 now back to g4 there's
no longer the idea of creating a threat
on g7 that was the purpose of rook c8
and after b4 queen d7
rook d2 and rook c4
the position as it stands a little
better for black but what
is the plan for dingley ren to make
progress here elmira
well somehow they transport to sort of
the queen's gambit accepted structure
you know with those bishops being on b2
and b6 so
first of all white is to move i think he
needs to um
we'll exchange a few pieces
if if it is possible
is there a way
you can see knight b3 doesn't work here
because queen g3
yes it will simply lose
is there something we can make with a
temple
well the pressure's coming to the night
so you got to do something with it
oh you said knight to b3 no knight b3 i
think i feel it loses immediately after
queen d3 so
yeah
rookie four no rookie four yes you take
the pound yes so no knight b3 no that's
not possible then okay knight knight f5
is possible made it
oh
yes that's a spicy move but i i think
it's just super direct you take on d3
because the queen you know has hang take
any time with check the king goes that
f8 and
in this position you can even throw in
the move rook c2 check you probably
which forces rook to d2
and the problem for white there are
long-term issues look at the pawn a3 and
b4 look at the pawn on g3 f4 h4 all on
dark squares and in this position the
knight is going to come to e3 with check
to protect the rook then you're going to
or maybe even after you yeah
take and then do it some order over here
and the problem for white is that all of
these pawns are going to become
potential targets so even though the
evaluation says white's only slightly
worse from a practical point of view it
feels like all your pawns are about to
be potentially picked off and it's
deeply uncomfortable
yeah it's definitely a position that
speaks to a theme that almir and i have
talked about a few times which is the
principle of two weaknesses right
white literally has weaknesses on both
sides of the board that are on the color
of black's now demon bishop right
because if that bishop gets going you
can poke and prod so i really like that
knight f5 is
it's a very direct solution it's
interesting but what i don't like about
knight f5 uh although if you exchange a
pair of knights then
your pawn on e4 is you know is hanging
all the time so you don't want to push
it t5 yes yeah
i mean g7 at some point you know you
should probably consider capturing that
but e4 seems more important in in this
position yeah
you you could even go for checkmate
ideas right g2 isn't that safe
no the only thing that's saving it is
rook d2 if it not if if not for this
move rook d2 the rook flips over to this
side of the board and with the knight
and bishop working together there's a
lot of danger okay but this is beautiful
rook c2 check okay rook d2 you just take
and play f6 you don't even go for pawns
that bishop oh wow he's about to be
trapped so how do you save your bishop
you play e5 or this yeah well my king
will just hunt you down king of seven
king jason now i play f5 and your bishop
is shut out and importantly this pawn on
g3 is an extra pawn but it can't go
anywhere because black has his claws f5
and h5 there saying your pawn can't move
it's stuck in place and you know that a3
pawn we were talking about you're not
going to see it on the board for much
longer because black can bring the
knight in or the bishop in as you're
pointing out and this is actually just
looking winning for black pawns locked
on one color have a natural predator
and it's that color's bishop right that
bishop is always hunting always looking
and uh that's a that's a so that was a
fantastic line robert welcome to madrid
that was that was a fantastic idea
seriously this
that sort of theme
could be game changing because while
it's unlikely to be missed
it's possible even even the best players
in the world could underestimate an idea
like f6 where suddenly the bishop
is completely shut out so
man
oh
man and java he spent a lot of time on
this move okay they're moved 35 they're
nearing the time control but you can
sense that java understands this is the
moment because either he's just going to
be
worse and groveling for a draw
you know or his positions collapses he
makes a bad move or if he finds knight
of five there's some way to liquidate
trades and pieces and then he can save
his king and his pawns in the process
then it's worth it but you can see like
even after knight f5 black has just
moved knight d5 and it's just chaos
that would be that would be quite the
mess
nice g5 yeah oh my god i haven't seen
this one
all the black's pieces are aiming at the
white king so maybe you want the queens
on the board i got a feeling i got a
feeling about dingley ren's uh dingly
ren's chances here in madrid maybe
turning around but
while we wait for roger to figure out
what his feelings are in the position we
know he works hard
he works super hard what are the staples
of of the waiver job of plays chess and
he works super hard to get to the
candidates we're going to take a second
to remind everybody in chess.com's
latest
player highlight how the oldest player
in the field got to madrid
the oldest player in madrid at age 35
timur rajab is competing for the third
time at the candidates and for the first
time in nine years
once ranked in the top five in the world
raja qualified for the candidates two
years ago but was unable to compete due
to covet concerns
for this year's tournament fide offered
raja a wild card which raja accepted
born in the same azerbaijani city as
former world champion gary kasparov raja
beat gary kasparov at age 15.
in fact he has never lost to the former
world champion
one of the peak achievements of
rajabov's career was his victory at the
fide world cup
in that tournament he defeated the top
seed ding lyren in the final to qualify
for the 2020 candidates tournament
in madrid raja hopes that he can lean on
his experience at the candidates to post
some impressive performances even though
expectations for him here are not as
high as they once were
[Music]
you know it's interesting because
the way the way that rajab got into the
candidates by the way
was beating the person who he might lose
to
in this game you think dingley wren
remembers that robert a little revenge
yes and no because the top two people
from that world cup qualified so once
you make it to the final you kind of
don't care anymore ding wanted to beat
him and he probably is like i'm gonna
get you next time but when two places
are for grabs and you're one of the two
i don't think you necessarily care which
uh
part of the pecking order you finish
with it's it's actually a very
interesting comment because uh he didn't
feel that way when i interviewed him in
um saint louis after beating magnus
carlsen you know he won just one single
cup that was such impressive performance
and i asked him like if there was a lot
of media coverage in china and he
explained to me that since this is a
private tournament it doesn't mean
anything so the only thing that means
something
is the world cup
uh the candidates the olympiad and the
world championship match that's
fascinating actually
well
expectations obviously not super high on
rajab and i say obviously with all due
respect he's had an incredible career
unfortunately right now he's in the
bottom of the standings so
what does he what do you do with a
mindset where you know expectations
aren't high but you don't want to become
a punching bag either right how do you
keep yourself motivated
throughout the event especially should
he lose this game to dingley wren
yes another
white pieces against rapport and that's
a stylistic clash
rapport is a highly energetic exciting
player who you know you won't even know
what he's going to plan move one rajabov
is a seasoned veteran he also has this
style where if he gets a slight
advantage he often will press it now in
game one against farouja he did actually
have an advantage but he sort of
liquidated too quickly and then he was a
material up but there were not really
winning chances so i do think that that
round six match-up against report is one
where vajava will have a very
interesting
chance because rapport is somebody who
is like so different stylistically than
the current hijab off but the earlier
job of like when he was younger he was
playing the king's indian and all sorts
of
crazy openings
okay wow queenie two
played by rajabov
i'm i'm even more impressed that queen
b7 immediately responded to by dingley
wren because look he puts the pressure
right back on her job off who has four
moves to make with only six minutes to
do so
he does not go for the forcing knight f5
decides that uh this was not
not correct and
given the brilliant idea you saw robert
with this bishop e7 being trapped i kind
of agree that that might have not been
not have been
the right way to defend this position
but
this is about to be really tough again
no increment
so
so no increment
i'm gonna keep saying it it's just
deeply uncomfortable for a white right
now you can't move your pieces you're
not a d4 can't move because your pawn e4
is loose so he goes queen d3 back look
at this he's decided he can just shuffle
puck until reaching time control he's
repeating but he can't very easily
because now
um ding can make the move knight to g6
and we remind everybody that they get an
additional hour after move 40 is made
we'll move 37 but the move knight to g6
also threatens e6 to e5 in many
positions because white's king it seems
safe enough for the moment but if i can
get more pieces into the attack i mean
that king is losing its shelter very
quickly
i love that idea in fact almost makes me
want to play e5 right away i don't think
you can or should but even right away
you're already thinking about ways to
just
pry open and break open white's king in
a position where your opponent's under
time pressure like for example if i took
with the pawn i guess maybe e6 and it's
it's not a good idea
but i was just thinking about some crazy
variations where the position opens up
you can see the evil bar even this yeah
that's my so it wasn't maybe as good but
i really like your idea of e5 and knight
g6 preparing it probably even more solid
yeah the computer likes that better but
from a practical perspective rajavo's
position might be hanging by a thread
here
this right here might be the move that
either wins the game or not because if
you play a not just a strong move here
almira but a move that makes her job off
think
right
that could be it well i was fascinated
by robert's comments you know that and i
tend to forget that i
i'm thinking about the position and we
are still on air you know i have to say
something
it's it's how difficult white's position
is like you i was looking for bishop a1
bishop b2 or queen e2 queen d3 just to
be able to hold
well that's what that's what rajab is
doing he's looking at queen e2 queen d3
bishop a1 bishop b2 what's funny if not
for the threat of e5 robert then
rejava's idea has merit right he's like
he's like hey i can't do anything better
with my pieces than i've already done
they're on the best squares so it's up
for dingley wren to show a way to mix it
i really like the e5 sack that i came up
with even though it's bad i just want to
do it i want to do it to spite chat well
i mean a way to to get e5 in with the
full force is if your pawn let's say the
pawn was already on f6
playing e5 would kick that knight out of
there and that gives black the e3 square
the diagonal for the bishop over there
on b6 that king on g2 is really not safe
so
there actually
is serious consideration for the move f6
here even right away it gives up the e6
bond it does but if you take that pawn
here's where the problem is rook takes
e4
and
do you look at that diagonal now yeah
right and the rookie three is a thread
knight e3 is going to be three the
knight on e7 is about to jump in to f or
d5 in all sorts of places for that piece
so the problem for black is you just
don't have that last piece in the game
the knight on e7 is controlled by the
pawn three squares away the e4 pawn so
you're happy to make that trade because
then your knight jumps in the game and
white's position falls apart and can you
exchange a few pieces like rook c2 is it
possible
yeah ah no now i thought 93 and then
rook c2 yes that's not roxy to knight c2
but 93 first yeah okay so which line is
rook c2 t2
let's say like yeah yeah well if it
takes don't take with the queen right
yes
but maybe 93 first and then take the
rook exactly so 93 check and you'd have
to take it and now you can't take back
because the night's pinned
wow
in fact
that's actually really huge so that
prevents white from simplifying the
pressure here makes me like f6 more and
more because it's like a slow that's
that is a time pressure move that
crushes your opponent right you play a
move like f6 with subtle improvement now
a very clear threat is on the board that
you only have five minutes to solve and
there's all kinds of ways it could go
wrong rook c2 being one of them yeah
though there is the downside that you've
given white like a potential point of
entry the e6 pawn and there could be a
situation where you you know you wish
you were a little more deliberate and
set it up better so knight g6 doesn't
change anything where you could play f6
next anyway so it's one of these
situations where i'm actually not sure
um both look appealing and the only
thing that i can see that black needs to
look out for is some kind of background
checkmate like it's not completely out
of the question with this knight g5 id
yeah there's some game saving tactic for
your java because the black king also
has its own problems one argument in
favor of six yeah that's true actually
another yeah exactly another point in
favor of f6 but
but i think that was ling's idea when he
played queen b7 instantly yeah he's
preparing f6 and e5
i like that i like that preparing to
prove ben feingold wrong there's almost
nothing i like
more yeah it's uh that definitely
is an exception to that quote-unquote
rule that best never move your f1 yeah
it looks really strong f6 will prepare
e5 again as we pointed out hard to make
moves for white that aren't blunders
when all
your pieces are dynamically poised for
tactics right that's uh that's tension
yeah and this would be
you can't even state how big a result
this would be for dingley wren yeah
because he you know he he heard his
interview after his first loss and he
started talking to dina and he was
saying how i played terribly and then
he's in a minus score so beating players
in this field is not very easy but if
dingley rent can win this game with the
black pieces we know he can beat anybody
in this competition and then he
has that belief in himself that he
didn't have in the previous candidates
where he lost the first two games so he
just played he plays f6 here we go
f6 elmira pumps her fists over here in
studio
f6 i
i feel like everybody wants to see
dingley ren find their his i even take
over java wants to see dean
can we just all agree that we want the
dingley rent of 2019 back can we all can
i just show of hands please i guess i
guess into this is
i'm raising my hand and screaming inside
you is dingly wren maybe like the most
liked player seriously he might be the
most beloved player who i i mean people
just love dingley
total sweetheart yeah
and again the 2019 thing we ran i was
saying in day one you and i commented on
the you know the epic tiebreak where he
beat magnus carlson in 2019 and i
remember
you and i talking
is this a preview of the world chess
championship match but even more
importantly a challenger that magnus
might have trouble with should dingley
run get through the candidates um
kobe had happened
dinglingrt has not been the same player
since well he he lost the first two
games yep in the previous candidates he
beat fabiano in game three but he just
was sluggish out of the gates yeah with
the pandemic you know with the lockdown
all those things associated with it was
clearly very difficult for him but then
the second half of the candidates he
scored the most points yeah no that's
true in fact we should remember that we
see you chat keep bringing it ding is
going to make a run if you're right
i think we have even more energy hasn't
been entertaining here in madrid but i
would love to see dingley wren get on a
roll come on ding
people are rooting for you and uh like i
said maybe even tame over jabba inside
is rooting for dingley wren to find his
form the mojo that has been escaping him
but that's a good point robert i guess i
forget because it was so out of reach i
really haven't remembered well but the
second half of the candidates last it
did go pretty good for dingley ren yeah
so and you know he beat janna pumps in
the final game where yon had nothing to
play for it john doesn't like losing
chess games but at that point the term
result was in the bag but ding was a
completely different player and i think
somehow despite his 2 800 plus rating
number two in the world people aren't
that familiar with dingley wren's chess
yeah and what i like most about his
chess is he has an extremely universal
style he often goes boa constrictor like
the game we're seeing here whereas
his opponent even making a single move
is difficult but then there are times
where he just stacks his queen and wins
the tiebreaker brilliancy against
crosstalk
people in like 25 moves and he beat
fabiano caruana in the 2019 sinkhole cup
actually in a really nice game where it
looked very level and every move was
difficult for fabiano to play so i have
tremendous amount we all have a
tremendous amount of respect for dingley
reign but i think somehow
he goes under the radar despite being
the only other player besides magnus
carlsen who's 2800 plus at the moment
well
uh at the moment
came over java only has two and a half
minutes and what did we say about f6
elmira we said that's a strong time
pressure move if you want to learn how
to beat your opponents when you have an
edge
and they're low on the clock it takes
poise right it takes moves like that
that give them
multiple problems to solve and ways to
go wrong well i also hope that once uh
we'll have time we can find zing's game
i think it's one what was one of the
most beautiful games that i've ever seen
played i think in uh in the chinese team
champs championship when he sacrificed
the queen his queen
and
it was
pure marvel you know i was remembering
the queen sacrifice against matt
although that was really just the
finishing touches on
on a brilliant a brilliant game from
dingley wren but um
and again and that's another reason why
people would be excited not just to see
him make a run but even play a match
against magnus because as carlson
himself has said
dingley wren
may be the toughest challenger he has
left in his generation and uh i know
he's kind of said both that both on and
off the record right i mean
besides the ferruga comments we know
that magnus has a ton of respect for
dingley ren's game look at rejava right
now yeah i mean he is desperately trying
to find a move here it's f6 was black's
37th move there are three moves to make
and only a minute and 35 seconds of
counting down for java this is a moment
where he's like i don't see a single
idea we said yes c2 fails to 93 check
that would be a pretty logical move to
play i can't move my knight from d4 open
bishop did you just go king h3
king h oh my gosh
tucks the king
by the way gets the king off the
diagonal so
it makes sense tactically
wow
what a move this works
king h3
like my first temptation to bring my
queen to the c8 h3 diagonal and just
sort of chase you down but i know that
if i do that then you'll bring your king
back to g2 because you're not
looking at my queen there and happy to
see it you're running
right away why go away from the plan you
had i mean of knight g6 and e5 right can
we continue to go for this probably if
you play e5 right away it's not as cute
as having a discovered check but you
still open that diagonal for the queen
to come there with tempe at some point
i just get the feeling that if it like
this could be a zook song if it were
white to move i feel like white might
just be lost
i'm serious right so one of those
positions where
what is white's move if you if you said
you have to move again what does white
play why can't you play e5 you probably
can it just you just want to i i want to
find out like knight of two you know
is forward or there is something where
you may check at the end like you always
to be careful we're you know we're oh
okay yes okay that's that's the point
but maybe we can show it because okay
let's see it's not that obvious yes so
e5 the points have removed the knight
away from d4 so you knight f2 check with
a fork but after you take on e5 and f
takes back now the problem for black is
this back ranks does knight even go to
e6 and you can't play knight f2 check
because i'll take it and then queen d8
is gonna lead to a big queen
lethal
yeah white's winning
okay probably check mating black
actually uh
okay so e5 is possible but on 96 you
just can't play knight f2 check although
if you're not going to play knight f2
check then
then why go for it right why okay so
exactly yes
so maybe that's not what dingley wren
has planned he has 10 minutes for two
moves so
plenty of time as compared to his
opponent but he wants to use it well you
know this is really instructive for
people at home because oftentimes people
ask
wait a second my opponent has a minute
and 20 seconds yeah shouldn't i blitz
them and flag them but no they're
right now we just saw white's 38th move
so two moves left for java to make time
patrol and as we just saw the evaluation
after e5 was
white was very happy about that sequence
so what ding is doing is he knows he's
better so if he can
you know keep his advantage he doesn't
really care that much let's move forward
because he's still much better yeah but
if he slips right now the game could
immediately turn from uh pressing for
his first win of the event to
every job of saying i've wiped my hands
of this
position i'm doing okay nichola we don't
want that we want blood um
so like i said even even table or java
is like he's like i'm not going to give
it to you but if you want to come and
take it we'd all be happy to see you on
a roll dingly brent um
all right well what other moves then you
established that the most forcing threat
behind f6 is probably not the follow-up
a more subtle move and dingley wren
plays a subtle move on that note you're
originally asked for queen to c8
is now on the board
so i expect king g2
and then he might just be like queen d7
and say what move are you going to make
right
yeah so it's a game of tickle right king
g2 put the queen here
but then then does the king sit on h5
the diagonal game okay wait wait wait we
have a very
aggressive move from rajabov
with only a minute to play
he makes a move that the computer does
not like wow this
this is this is why time pressure hurts
right very rarely does
does time pressure actually end in you
losing on time most of the time it leads
to mistakes and that's why we try to
avoid such situations
hikaru made comments almira that he
thought with increment rajab holds the
draw against him in round two
with increment here where job off maybe
doesn't play that blunder
what do you think
well that's we are having this time
control that's why because the people
want drama i guess yeah
well i mean if you just like extend
games right and you give all these top
players 24 hours per move magnus carlsen
isn't beating players very often maybe
he'll win a game here and there but
there'll be many draws because they have
all the time in the world so we already
don't give the max amount of time so
it's not to me that big of a deal that
we change the time so i think there
should be some uniformity especially in
a cycle
but this move e5 i mean i think it is
both the duress of the clock but also
he's been under pressure forever and the
response here from dingley wren that is
so strong i believe he plays with f5
himself
that is kind of a scary move to make
because you hand g5 to white but you
also get d5 you get this diagonal from
a8 all the way to h1 and this king on h3
is and clearly
some crazy diagonal
game uh so how important is the human
factor i think in chess you know we
tend to forget you know that's a random
thing to say but okay i really now that
you say a5 i really like it just the
grip
the that white
uh that black has and
although
you have to calculate so let's look at
it is that f5 gonna be met with knight
to g5
i think you just allowed me to bring my
so i take on d4 first i guess get rid of
one of the knights yeah and then put my
knight on d5 and i have a field day here
yeah this is
this is just torture yeah we're playing
checkers on different boards yeah so f5
we'll see what
is there anything else besides f5 we
could see i mean what if i just take it
honestly i didn't even think about it
but it looks pretty good
takes takes
but now knight g5 is a pretty serious
threat yeah and that also comes with
queen h7 so the computer still likes
black but i agree with robert that
feels like f5 is the is the grindingly
accurate move to play no but can you
somehow threaten mate on h1 i was
thinking about your line uh you take on
e5 take on e5 take on d4 first because
no no take on d4 okay take on d4 first
yes bishop d4 and now bring your queen
to the big deck queen c6 is a nice
square
yeah because you can't go knight g5 as
queen h1 leads to mate
and you know what else that means that
rook takes d4
because i'm just trying to remove the
defenders there if you take the knight
there you'll get mated take with the
queen you lose your knight enough three
and then get made to next so that looks
pretty miserable i like that a lot
that that feels like the
super you know that's the i'm trying to
win right now if you feel like you see a
concrete line because there's no way
dingley wren doesn't know that he's just
much better if he plays f5 right the
position is super concrete did you see
him look at rajabov oh you see something
he gave him that look he gave that look
like i might see the wind
i might i may have uh
lost against the black pieces in round
one but if i win with the black pieces
the ship has been righted that's that's
what you're saying if your daily rent
it's a big big moment for his chances
okay will it be f5 and grinding or f
takes e5 with a concrete line calculated
look at that right there five minutes
and 40 seconds to 59 seconds
on the clock
and this is one of these positions where
like f takes e5 white's 40th move may
just be like f65 so you get some time
control but f5 is one of those moves
like you're frazzled i don't even know
what to play in response and he does
take it so he's gonna go for that bishop
takes d4 line yeah elmira pointed out
so so ding
takes the very concrete approach of
capturing the e5 pawn as robert said the
the con of that move is rajopa doesn't
have to think on his 40th movie just
responds okay so but the problem is
you're still losing
that's a bit of an issue yes yeah it's
like uh out of the frying pan into the
fire sort of thing here for team over
jabba
and bishop takes d4 is just such an
excellent move and without it
black doesn't even have an advantage but
the point is that the bishop on the dark
square something we actually kind of
foreshadowed that it's staring into
pawns it doesn't have territory to work
with where the knights and the light
squares and it all started with that
move h5 by dingley wren that was
such a great move by him just inducing
h4 by rejavo and that's the problem that
has persisted is the light squares yep
there's no light square bishops give me
those light squares and the domination
remains all the way up to move 40 as
ding is still yet to make his final move
in the time control yeah love replaying
that h5 what a strong move
all right almira he better find the
follow up to your idea otherwise fdx e5
was no good and we should actually show
that because if you make some other move
in the position like just
i don't know
but you can't move the queen here
because v6 i think but just like queen
d7
white has knight g5 coming this is why
we initially
were liking f5 one of the reasons was we
don't have to deal with this threat so
the key is you have to take d4
or f takes e5 was not the best choice
from dingley run he he also only has
four minutes by the way yeah and he's
spending his time here i mean bishop
takes d4 is logical
eight different ways it just allows you
to plan on an f5 and then d5 and as
amira point out just the queen getting
to the diagonal is so essential
with all these checkmate threats down
the line over in h1 that it does seem
like dingley run
should be finding this move but we
haven't uh evaluated bishop d4 and
knight d4 we are still bringing our
queen to
the big diagonal maybe queen b7 and
queen a8 i think we
also have to consider
this move so
knight f3 back you know that's the only
way i can see
for white to hold at the moment so how
do we continue here in knight g5 by the
way
so that might be why dingley runs a
little nervous here yeah so maybe the
queen on the eighth rank is somehow
important like queen a8 instead of queen
b7
just to avoid that those kind of queen
d8 scary scenarios uh because a queen
trade will still be good for black in
many of these positions yeah
could he knight f3 and then just play
knight f5 or something like queen gate's
not scary as a queen trade
okay
queen d8 takes takes
yeah and i just bring my king out to f7
and you're still in the dominant spot
look at the knights of the episode i
look at the bishop right it's just a bad
piece a big pawn as we like to say but
yeah but it has to be bishop takes d4 so
it's either bishop takes d4
or you got nothing
yeah a bit curious as to why he put f
takes e5 and started down for three
minutes that's what makes me worried is
that he he forgot about knight d4 you
know like you're looking at bishop d4
automatically and sometimes before right
yeah he just did you see that he grabbed
his head like what am i doing
but he
he's clearly underestimating his own
advantage right we have the luxury of
the eval bar
and if we want it the engine lines but
dingley wren is feeling like his
advantage is not as big here as he
wanted it to be maybe regretting that he
didn't play a 5.
still lucky for him as long as he plays
bishop takes d4 and gets to move 40 and
doesn't lose on time in the next minute
and 45
he's still in a great spot to be honest
i've been in these situations so many
times because i'm like obsessed with one
idea because i was looking
yeah a little bit like dino you know i
want to mate but then when it doesn't
work and i'm surprised by my opponent's
reply so now like i i found a hole in my
variation so bishop d4 knight d4
and i start to like to panic because
you're faced with uncertainty and you
with very long time like very little
time he's panicking he's like he's
shuffling around and keeps looking at
the clock the good news of bishop takes
d4 is a very safe move like you know
that even if you don't see a win after
that you know that you're not getting
yourself into trouble in fact that helps
you in many regards that knight is
what's stopping him from playing queen
b7 because the e6 pawn drops and if e6
drops there's all sorts of checkmate
patterns that the black king needs to
worry about so dingley red is i'm under
a minute that's that's the thing though
is elmira said that like it's it may be
obvious but he clearly doesn't like
something he's now under a minute
is he going to panic and not play bishop
takes d4 i mean this is the problem
because now he's in his own head
i mean he has to play bishop takes d4
there's no situation where you want to
lead these knights just prancing around
you're not coming to g5 so 30 seconds 30
seconds okay wow this is he's isn't
making it seems that way for us but it's
like
now he's here yeah elmira is freaking
out over here like he got himself in
this spot and he's overwhelming the
situation all he has to do is capture
the knight
and he maintains the winning advantage
and he definitely knows that he hasn't
made his 40 oh no
that's the movement
we were worried that he overthought the
advantage oh my goodness
yeah and you can just tell by his face
he just
he went f takes e5 and then went deep in
the think tank normally you follow up
f65 with your next move and dingly wren
i mean this is not the first time this
tournament and you could just tell on
his face yeah the wheels and it's it's
what elmira said though she it was like
you've been in those situations where
you played a movie you thought was
winning you then realize it's not
and the emotions get the best of you you
just you can't see the bigger picture of
the forest through the trees like hey
all you have to do is like keep playing
the same idea even though it's not as
concretely winning as you thought right
yeah and that's what i was talking
about like
your emotions the human factors so
we were trying to explain some of the
decisions that de moore took before us
but that's the same is true for ding he
was under enormous pressure and he had
to make his last move with a few seconds
left
it's funny because it's it's hard
because it's from our perspective it
feels obvious right and it's not fair at
all it doesn't it doesn't pay tribute or
do you know do justice to one the the
pressure
right the dingly rim was under right
there and two how difficult that
situation is from a practical
perspective he has no information in
front of him telling him to take to take
the knight he has no complete
information at all and
when you calculate a line you think is
winning
and then you realize it's not sometimes
you can become your own worst enemy and
that's what we saw right there i'll give
you that but at the same time this is
the candidates tournament
everybody in this field is crazy strong
and if you don't capitalize
on the positions that give you
near-winning advantages and it wasn't
that straightforward there's plenty of
life left of course we have the benefit
of the engine but i i feel like he knows
it was winning just look at him he knows
he had something there yeah and he just
didn't find it and against rapport
earlier in the event he had a winning
position he allowed report to escape and
now look at rajava yeah he just looked
at dingley wren raised his eyebrows of
course we saw you chad
going nuts we know how sad you are we're
all sad for him go ahead robert if
dingley wren
doesn't compose himself he could lose
this game yeah
no that's how
crazy that moment was and again
so
so hard to like judge and i understand
what you're saying like you have to
judge right but also like just his
emotions got the best of me we have
compassion anymore right we understand
like we have an eval bar off the side
screen but the thing about it is that
dingley red knew that he had a great
position right he was shuffling finding
the perfect moments to strike and then
just something went wrong someone
haywire and unfortunately for him it's
likely gonna cost him a point here that
he very much needs so while we can be
you know empathetic and we do you know
understand this is the number two chess
player in the world right there's one
person on this planet high rate in him
that is magnus carlsen if he is really
trying to become the world champion and
fight magnus carlsen in a match
he needs to win games like this and it's
not to be overly critical and i know
maybe sometimes it comes off that way
and it's easy to be in a chair and have
the e-belt off to the side and all that
arm chair grandmaster
you're an actual professor i'm an
armchair
yeah i just it just
you know you when you get that feeling
it's not someone's event yeah once again
it's feeling that way for dingley and
somebody else was suffering this was the
monoronian how many times did he enter
the
candace tournament as the highest rate
of player or one of the top view and
even get off to a good start and then
the second half of the tournament he
just kind of collapsed so you feel for
that player we know how strong levon is
we know how strong dingley ren is but
something about this feels like i don't
know the pressure might have been too
big for him
go ahead elmira and what i wanted to say
is that we should also like calm down
and
have a look at this position objectively
let's say maybe it was difficult to find
this win after bishop d4 but
if he plays bishop d4 now bishop d4 and
let's dive into that we need to get to a
break so let's we have time control so
let's dive in
save your thought let's go let's look at
it objectively i totally agree with you
so we're going to throw to a break right
now but before we do remind you
everybody blitz champs is coming it's
the first celebrity chess event we've
done in quite a while really since last
year's pog champs so make sure you tune
in for your favorite nfl stars as they
throw down for a hundred thousand
dollars in charity uh we've got the
legends you see larry fitzgerald hall of
fame wide receiver amari cooper
cleveland browns wide receiver micah
parsons kayvon thibodeaux it's stacked
there are several others and it's going
to be awesome john erschel my good
friend joining me for commentary for
july 9th and 10th we're going to have
all kinds of action make sure you tune
in every day
at 1pm pacific
all right
dingley wren going to be feeling it what
a tough spot he has now put himself in
but just how tough is it like elmira
said we're gonna dive in see the chess
moves and find out does he still have a
chance to pull himself together a
beautiful afternoon here in madrid don't
go anywhere round five of the feed
candidates continues when we return
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
no stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
uh
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played played very well
soon to be 30 caruana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 2844 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vichy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
[Music]
me
ah
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less actor than them in every stage
yeah and that that stings a little bit
okay do the more game review okay yeah
thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks i
gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
probably need to work on these ones yeah
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taking
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pass
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
you're
inside the palacio de santonia
what a beautiful setting
for an event like this to take place
seriously i have not given it a proper
tour myself i'm going to
spend to spend some more time but
almira you're you are you are a uh a
connoisseur
of
of all kinds of artistic things your
thoughts on what it would be like to
play in an event like this
well i actually wanted to drive a
parallel between art and the way
computers see
well changed us the way we see chess you
know it's very strange parallel but the
same thing happened i think at the
beginning of the 20th century when
especially one artist stands out as
marcel duchamp you know he changed the
way uh we see art changed the way
the classical canons of the art he was
also a very good chess player
and i think that one of the way
as people were seeing modernism is that
you have to be innovative but subversive
at the same time so this is the way
we're playing chess now h4h5 has been
very subversive you know it's and we are
challenging everything we knew about
chess before every like
classical way of thinking is being
challenged by modern chess so well said
can't go here in studio i hope it made
sense along with grand master robert has
no i think it's true we have you know
you
we have to
i can't say it as eloquently as you just
did but i would make a comparison
complete information but also
taking the practical opportunities with
the aggressiveness with h5 the things
that should have gotten dingley run into
the spot to maybe win this game but or
you could just staple a receipt on the
wall and call it art sometimes that
works too that's true depending on which
modern museum you're in
well depending on which modern museum
you're in that's uh not this one but
where are we at in the in the
round five
show
today
we have three games so far in the books
as you can see the draws uh before your
eyes there's one game still in progress
but as we see nakamura finished his game
with nippon mishi and it was hikaru
who actually caught up with our own dina
bell and kaya
after the game
we'll uh we'll check in now to see what
did hikaru have to say about his draw
with yonda pombashi what were his
immediate post-game thoughts let's let
the interview with dina take it away
let's just say i lost a game in the
rapid chess championship i mean i think
already it's many weeks ago now probably
like
two months three months um but i lost
the game in this bishop g5 line to
fabiano um and then i i looked at this
thing that i came up with in the game
this whole hxg5 bishop e6 thought it was
interesting um
yeah i mean i was all prep up until
about move 20 wasn't very difficult to
find moves but then inevitably like
every other game so far there was a
moment where i got a little bit careless
for two to three moves and maybe richard
had some chance when i i played this
very strange uh
king king king e5 and this whole rook a1
thing but
anyway so
let's do it let's do a little bit of
preview as we try to get that interview
queued up he has white against dingley
red he might be facing a much more
dejected dingley red than he was about
to uh now almirah
well i'm still uh having my hopes uh hi
if i may say you think he's going to win
this game yes this is still not over so
but okay either way hikaru plays ding
with the white pieces so
well either way you know he he's
actually in the lead you know he won at
least on plus one
they made six draws so um
hikari is going to push once again
real quick interesting is
do you think it changes hikaru's
approach depending on whether or not
ding loses or wins this game robert i
think about that often do you try to
strike while somebody is down or do you
just treat them as if they're zero for
zero and i think the players hope to be
in the mindset where they just go in as
if it's you know any other day and
they're starting the tournament fresh
but i think that
no player really does that right they're
like this person has shown
that they're not
in their best shape so why don't we go
for
a potential line that could catch them
off guard and dingley ren is the type of
player who you know he has a universal
style but he definitely has his
preferences and his tactics have not
been his
uh call yeah well not on point
necessarily against rapport in this game
against uh nepo just everything was
going
wrong so
yeah maybe it's a time it's weird saying
with dingley wren but it's a time for
hikar say
that might be a person i'm gonna try to
pick on
hikaru did catch up with dina as we said
and we have we have that interview for
you right now so let's get his post-game
thoughts after his draw with yonder pot
yonder palmisia earlier today
no i mean obviously i suspected john
would play something
in this petrov
i mean i think i got everything i wanted
i i don't know what the objective
evaluation is but i think if i i mean i
don't have the sudden like brain slip
and play play knight d2 if i go knight
d4 i mean i think it's it's much better
if not winning so
uh once i played 92 and i allowed this
queen a1 a1q6 i mean probably it's still
a little bit better somehow but i mean i
was already very upset at myself and uh
and yeah i just kind of uh petered out
into this repetition so i mean quite
disappointing
you removed
your rook from e2 to b2 and then
repeated the position was it just the
principal soviet rule to repeat two
times and then uh think i mean you could
say that but also with no increment in
this tournament um trying to get closer
to move 40 is is always preferable so
that was the reason i did it um i mean
basically came down to this one moment
when i was going to play knight d4 and
then i thought 92 was simpler i just
overlooked this queen at one queen f6 um
if i played id4 i think i would have won
the game so
yeah it's
not good
wow that's pretty direct answer right
there in terms of how we felt about it
right not not playing knight d4 was the
difference in the game from mccarran's
view
he seemed pretty upset yeah and so we're
gonna have two players tomorrow when he
plays dingley red he's also upset
players who missed opportunities yeah
despite al miller's feelings that
dingley run might win uh i'm gonna go
with you that i think dingley wren is
going to be upset draw or loss even this
is crazy but almira
real quick so he said he got everything
he wanted in that petrov so that was
interesting to note as well because part
of our wondering was was hikaru where he
wanted to be turns out he got a position
he was okay with against yon
yes and i think he he liked his position
so
one more like argument or a point like
to add so he's he's feeling quite
confident so yeah he's looking for
tomorrow's game yeah
whatever the result might be today and
he
he'll certainly push well there's one
game that doesn't have a result in from
today yet and that is where we sit
between rajabov and dingley wren we see
them sitting in the far corner there and
dingley wren
just
man your heart goes out to him now the
more we look at him we had drama at the
end of the time control you you heard it
if you were watching live we screamed i
was i that was not faked i couldn't hold
back when g6 was on the board although
robert with every second that went by we
knew he was he was overthinking it you
could just feel it and
now you left us at the break robert
thinking that
he could lose this game potentially tell
me what i'm not saying it'll happen but
paint the picture for everybody what
goes wrong here for black to such a
degree that dingley ring could even lose
well it's you know white has to capture
the bishop back on d4 so let's start
there yep so the question becomes what
is white's plan what are white's threats
move like bishop c5 can already question
that knight and also the open d file
could be good for white to attack the
black king so there are very direct
threats here that ding needs to deal
with and he will do so by putting his
queen on the long diagonal most likely
and just threatening queen to h1 which
will lead to a checkmate so the
difference and the reason why rajabov
gets to hold this position is he can
bring his queen to f3 so instead of
having a pinned knight on
f3 he can bring his queen over and with
the queens getting swapped there is
still some initiative that black has but
there's not going to be a checkmate and
it seems like
the java suddenly is everything under
control yeah almerit now your turn i
know you want to turn but to say that
you still think dingley rank can win
this game so now you paint the picture
of
what could go right for black if he was
to still hold on and get the victory
well it's not an easy task of course so
i wanted to play knight f5 but you need
to prepare this move first yeah well you
can maybe do it
well i
robert rightfully said that after bishop
c5 he will threaten queen g8 and then
rook d7 you know and
well
okay it's not an easy position to defend
so maybe first exchange to queens and
then play knight to five so okay six
quincy six queen of three yes queen of
three
shake and bake and knight five here yeah
maybe you get still to play bishop c5
what do you think about this position
i think that it looks like black is like
a move away from winning after rook c3
but this is rook d8 check and i think
that white is very fortunate but
it doesn't matter how fortunate you are
as long as you can hold the balance and
yeah
yeah we'll show it knight g5
and then you have bishop f8 exactly king
has to go the last rank and that is
check and mate
check and mate okay so really important
you don't walk into mate pro tip for dan
um came to g7 bishop f8 check
now you can go
back to jada you have to what's funny
look at there's no discovered checks
that matter because every piece for
white is on a light square it's funny
yeah you know only the rook is on c3 but
bishop takes b4 is not a legal move
unfortunately so
you can just move your bishop back and
forth and the king will go up to g7 and
that's how you get to hold on to this
game because if you move your king
elsewhere you're getting checkmated
and the problem is that that might be
the most likely variation so as much as
i'm with you elmira that we would love
to see this not end heartbreakingly for
ding the truth is that type of line
does black have any better than rook c3
here that's the problem is actually no
actually do you have anything besides
rook c3 because you might lose yeah you
get and it's funny because you're
threading checkmate and rook takes g3 so
if the knight moves there's no time for
knight g5 so this is a very forcing
sequence that is very likely to happen
yeah can i try my d5 then you know i
will try everything really
okay
absolutely now knight g5 so i get to go
you don't have to play bishop c5 here
because then i have rook c3 so
it has been set rook c6 and two but down
but now this okay maybe you can't play
it right away because of 95 but
if we get bishop c5 now white is white
is pressing keeping your pieces
off of the open lines the knight can go
from e4 to c5 and things like that this
is just a position where
um the worst is far behind white so
um i do think we have to be careful
though so at queen c6 like just a couple
moves back here like instead of queen to
f3 we can also like queen f1 so we
shouldn't leave out the possibility that
suddenly we want to keep the queens on
the board because i want to move my
bishop away from d4 and backrank
checkmate u so
black still needs to be careful and
that's why i think keeping the queen on
maybe a8 is more precise and keeping the
queen on c6 just to cover the back rank
and avoid any sort of checkmates
this is
fascinating if you're just tuning in you
missed
high
stress
real drama when right at time control
this position was on the board
mu 40 faced dingley wren
and bishop takes d4
was a winning advantage for black again
i'll show you the basic ideas if the
bishop took black can bring the queen up
and you see the difference between this
position and the live game the knight
can never move to g5 without there being
checkmate and in fact you might not have
any move anyway because black is
threatening things like brook takes d4
where the knight is pinned to the
checkmate threat on h1 and if rook takes
d4 queen takes
then queen takes f3 is in is an easily
winning position for black so
for some reason what happened was
despite the huge advantage here
you could have done it a number of ways
f5 is perhaps perhaps the safest move
he goes for the forcing line but then
overthinks it
almira said that perhaps he saw knight
takes d4
and uh
this kind of panicked him perhaps
because now on queen a8 maybe he
you know maybe he mis-evaluated this
type of position here um
didn't realize that he still has a very
big advantage
yeah i mean it's not so simple there's
not a knockout here so i mean clearly
this is better for him than what he did
in the game this is the line so knight
d5 is a great move because the knight
takes e6 it looks like white's just
winning a pawn and black's position's
collapsing there's knight f4 check which
is i mean that is just beautiful and
you know if that's the line that you're
being missed and okay we can easily
understand that we'll just show it again
everyone it's checkmate here queen takes
h2 next and if you take with the knight
you lose the lady on f3 exactly
so 95 do you think that's the move that
he may be missed it's a pretty difficult
move to see from a distance because um
after queen f3 you don't want to trade
queens as we're talking about like in
the game yeah um you can move your queen
elsewhere uh potentially instead of
playing knight to d5 but it already
starts to feel like white
is gaining some activity so uh knight d5
here that might be from the distance
what
was overlooked
it's likely true and again that's it's
always useful to unpack and
develop some hypothesis because these
guys don't just make one move blunders
right there's something not in the
current position that they mis-evaluated
or missed and that's what's going to
influence a wrong decision in the
current position
oh man what
that was intense
that was intense and i'm i'm heartbroken
for dingley ren the story line it felt
so real
felt like dingley ren was ready to
pounce
felt like he was uh
he was he was gonna give us what we all
what we all wanted chat was going nuts
um you see your job of kind of staring
at him by the way i'm very curious what
that means like is roger gonna play
queen f3 and force the queens off or
maybe he thinks he can play on somehow i
feel like the white king is in more
danger with the queens on the board um
but if he's really feeling like
he has a an opportunity to strike but
dingley red missed his chance and is not
playing his best chess and make him like
rook d1 and keep pieces on the board and
hopefully more it's funny because you
know maybe he's
maybe what he was doing was literally
measuring ding up like looking at him
like is this guy not have it together
right now because he is obviously the
top player from china but he uh
he's rattled he misplayed the position
at time pressure
all right as tame over java considers
whether he wants to let this one peter
out or maybe push for a little more
against china's number one we're going
to remind you of all the great things
about dingley wren in our nextjust.com
player profile
it took some good fortune but dingley
wren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the very first time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify but when
a spot opened ding was next man up based
upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field the chat
went nuts they love their man dingley
run we said this is an engine move
humans don't find it and he found king
of one i'm absolutely stunned once again
this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top five for the
past five years
once out of the tournament completely
deng now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native lands history
well i know we're not looking at the
happiest of dingley wren
in this last game against him or java
but let's look at the happy career he's
had a three-time chinese champion
two-time olympic gold winner
uh we don't have pro chess league stats
on there but uh played for the shangdu
pandas okay that's another story uh pro
chesley coming back next year he won the
grand chester in 2019 that was the event
we were talking a ton about where he
beat carlson in a playoff uh what an
amazing performance that was the
two-time runner-up at the feeding world
cup that's a big deal by the way it's so
hard to make it through the gauntlet of
that that tells you how how much of a
monster this guy is when he's playing
well um and has one of the longest
unbeaten streaks in the history of our
game with a hundred games from august
2017 to november 2018. i remember the
thrill ride that was just every day
wondering will this guy ever lose a
chess game so
unfortunately he's gonna have to
probably take take his opportunity to
simplify this one or he could lose this
game against tame over javoff so i'm
anticipating as robert said that line of
queen of three knight f5 i'm sorry al
miller i know you don't want it but here
it comes queen of three
what i find also very interesting is
zing's personality you know we live in a
modern world where
well he with his results you know like
everyone would be claiming it everywhere
you know and he's such a modest humble
person you know so i don't have social
media so i haven't been following all
the debates but i think he only
concentrates like on the moves he's
making on the board you know so yeah
so old school
old-fashioned his old school and he's an
amazing player unfortunately
nerf's got the best from there
robert before this one does ultimately
go a direction we think it's going to
who knows we maybe can see more blunders
i want to go back to something you said
when we were off air and put you on the
spot a little bit because we were
talking about your comments about
that no matter how much compassion we
have and empathy we feel for that moment
where he just lost himself a little bit
but
if you want to beat the world champion
be the world champion you got to play
like the world champion magnus probably
finds bishop takes d4 or what you said
talk about the the different approach of
maybe playing f5 and why that might have
been the psychologically right thing to
do yeah it kept the position a little
more locked and yeah i think the most
surprising thing to me of all of that
was that he went pawn takes e5 and then
thought for all of his remaining time
right and then made the mistake like
mistakes happen obviously right and
these players they are exceptional he's
number two in the world for a reason
right he has earned his spot here based
on a long history of great chess playing
but it just didn't feel like his
response
they didn't work together right and i
want to show it on the board we're going
to back up because
we've got some time here it was right
here where e5 was played because again
yes objectively he was still winning to
take and the move that had us go oh no
was that he didn't play bishop takes e4
right but your point that roberts told
me off camera he's like magnus
if he goes for this maybe magnus finds
bishop before but he's like magnus
probably plays f5 in the position
and it's just because of what you said
it keeps the opportunities for raj to go
wrong it's the easier move to play
psychologically a little bit more
difficult for your opponent to face this
response i think it just doesn't give
white any semblance of an out yeah there
are no trades being offered the position
is closed and in closed positions
knights are better than bishop so you're
gonna take on d4 at some point very
likely your knight's coming into d5 your
queen is taking over all of these light
squares your work on c4 can't be touched
and isn't a great
both rank and file so everything is
going for well for black in this
position so it's
it's both f5 just kept it easy for him
and maybe it's not winning necessarily
because there could be some kind of
fortress that is impenetrable but the
fact that he went f65 and sat and
thought and like scratched his head and
just looked super uncomfortable there's
just something that he clearly
overlooked and it's uncharacteristic and
something about the candidates right he
struggled in the first half last time
even in his first go at the candidates
he never quite was vying for first place
like i think he ended up finishing plus
one so seven out of 14 but he wasn't
ever in the driver's seat trying to take
down the event so
i don't know what it is and we have
tremendous respect for dingley renton is
a long time top you know three player in
the world he is
had a hundred game unbeaten streak he
took down the 2019
grand chess tour including the singapore
cup against magnus carlson so his
accolades speak for themselves but it
just is a moment where if you are going
to become the challenger for the world
championship
you can't keep letting these moments
slip because against rapport and now in
this game against for java it's not
always even about the results of the
game it's about sort of
how the move was missed and in this case
it was just he froze yeah and it's very
sad like you know i've
i'm a huge fan of all the players in
this field and dingley ren in particular
in this case and it just felt like
something happened where instead of
proceeding with bishop takes d4 which he
made the next one because he had to
um he just
like got stuck in his tracks well
speaking of proceeding elmira you get
your wish
the game is proceeding and it's really
playing
so he didn't go for knight f5 in the
draw we were maybe predicting
i know you've been over there
calculating it so what's
immediately one of the key ideas is this
guards d8 so
we're not getting checkmated i guess in
some of these lines anymore but what
else do you think kingly run has up his
sleeve well we want this c3 square you
know so
when well he's forcing the bishop either
to move
either he will trade it you know on d4
so let's see if
white continue with bishop c5 i think uh
jing's intention here is to play rook c3
and
what to do here
are you king ji2
i think you i think you're going for
this oh i was looking for king okay
same draw because the king can't escape
no but rook f3 you have a vertical three
c6 you don't have rook f2 which would
end the game on the spot
and you don't have 95 either because
after rook c8
oh wait i'll just take e6
and then a6 and g6 are hanging and
that's not good white is
white is cleaning up so this is
unfortunately
okay and again not the dinghy runs gonna
completely tilt here but that would be
the recipe
of how you you just don't swallow
that the position is uh
it's no longer something you can play
for a win and you get yourself in
trouble
yeah it feels like we're just gonna get
a simplification right because you could
take this pawn on e5 and start trading
stuff white goes rookie two at the end
just win the e6 pawn like this
it feels like
it's very difficult at this point for
regela to go particularly wrong here
yeah and again why is this isn't this
isn't just good for white oh there's a
mating threat okay so you have to be
very careful there's bishop g1 as a
response king of seven if you take we go
in bishop g1
probably a number of things now then i
can get to f3 then then you win the game
oh let's try it
but i guess you can just move your
bishop away and that's well yeah i just
want to show it
that's the problem that's the problem
you move the bishop
you get mated
exactly fun little mating net to see
the problem is though the knight can't
control g4 and be on f3 at the same time
so in these sequences where you try to
reroute your knight over here
the bishop moves away and then after
knight f3 now white can play the move g4
exactly and now you made space for if
you go back
i go back which is probably why the
computer
says it's a draw yeah that looks like a
very forcing sequence
i've been staring at this position and i
had the crazy thought that
in case you would play bishop c5 rook c3
and then rook d6 or f3 x6 is there any
way that i could sacrifice the g pawn
and then play g5 and then play king f7
where this doesn't work it's way too
much
all in on the checkmate
no g5
first i don't know some but you can
simply take on this six no no this is uh
yes well let's show the checkmate though
because it's fun if you take here
you're going to go the other way still
not made but we want to get we want to
get in here something yes
yeah like rook i don't know b3 or
something
and if again you you know you take i
would probably even do it but
no but they can play king of what's the
idea you're threatening me
and even there there's bishop g1
yeah
oops sorry
wrong square
now white might win this game
no my idea was to play king f7 king g6
to avoid uh perpetual but this is way
too much you know so that's uh
yeah it just rotates
takes a success
yeah there's no way for ding to play and
i think bishop c5 was just played
there's no way for ding to play for a
win without just
maybe losing all his pawns so
yeah you can see on his face he he knows
the game is
going to be a split point and
well we kind of
for a moment there were ruling raj above
out we thought he was going to lose this
game go to the bottom of the standings
now
if he holds this game he goes a two out
of five that's
no he's reasonable he's still in
striking distance yeah
he's an experienced player obviously we
know that he'll uh he's he's never
raja is going to be the kind of player
i'll say that even if he's in the bottom
of the standings he's never going to be
a tough
sorry he's never going to be an easy
point he's going to he's going to play
super tough and we saw here today that
despite being
in a spot with his back against the wall
he's probably going to come out with a
half a point well i think in the first
round farouja kind of
penciled him as maybe a point that he
could go after yeah and he sacrificed
that exchange it was a really exciting
game
and
for jean was lost like he was in big
trouble at some point so it's clear that
you can't pick on anybody in this field
no matter what kind of form coming into
the event no matter what kind of form
during the event
nobody is a free point and you know
rajab has so much experience and he you
know at his core is a fighter in recent
years he hasn't been playing very much
and he hasn't won a game in classical
class in three years so
um it's not likely that he can pull off
a string of victories and win this
tournament but he definitely can beat
any single opponent in this tournament i
have a question for robert like did you
play against any of the candidates on
the field
have i played against yes i played
against a car i played against fabiano
and that is it
so like how how does it feel you know
going
while playing a game against such strong
players
what kind of games speeches no no no
classical classical is
especially when you're in class i only
played class school against chicago so
fabian and i haven't played we were kids
we're the same coach we you know kind of
grew up together uh oh this i didn't
know yeah
so um
with hikaru because he's a few years
older and he was like always one of the
strongest players it's fun i mean you
know he's the favorite and anytime
you're playing him you're probably doing
pretty well in the tournament
so
it was you know didn't go my way most of
the time
but when you're a 16 year old kid
playing in the us championship
yeah so you know
he of course has a
big score against me and i haven't
played very much over the last decade
but um yeah it's always fun i mean this
is these are like the hardest workers
and the best players in the
professionals the exact type of people
you want to play against
my story of playing hikaru i played him
many times in blitz
but
edward levy memorial
denver
2000 and
before you were born
before you were born young man no it was
uh
some some random year where i got
crushed by nakamura and boy cavish
um
in uh in a tournament in denver i
remember losing dewey kavitch fondly
because he was
yucking it up in the bar while beating
me in this meroxybene grind out game and
when i resigned elmira voykevich
literally said it took you long enough
so that welcome to the chess world as a
young american boy
i
[Laughter]
experience on more than one level for
all growing chess players
you know we have our own mojo stories
and may he rest in peace a fantastic
player obviously i went through a lot in
his life but yeah to answer your
question you know anytime you get a play
against players in this field it's just
such a great experience and
events these days like the grand swiss
and before that just the isle of man
tournament those give you an opportunity
to play against these people whereas for
the most part the round robin format
it's not it's an invitational for the
top ten and that's it and so you don't
get access and chess is very difficult
to like have any sort of motivation
because
um you know you want to play the best
people but you don't even have the
option like you do in tennis for example
if you stream together a few victories
and tennis then you get a play against
nadal or djokovic or federer or serena
williams or whomever wherein chess is
like you don't even get a ticket into
the to the arena now why ask this
question because well i had well really
a chance to play one of the best players
in the world and personally i always had
to overcome this fear you know so that's
uh you know it's i was not raised like
dude you know who said that from
starting from seven or eight you know i
always believe that i will be a world
champion and that clearly shows when
well that when he's playing against
magnus carlsen he has absolutely no fear
yeah well he does have a good record
against magnus girl not being young
chris of judah by the way ding has taken
on e5 which i think is the simplest
approach right the uh the least
dangerous approach as we were showing in
the variations that were occurring if
you didn't take on e5 and rook c3 there
were chances to lose so i think dingley
wren
understands uh
understands that this one has gotten
away from him here sorry elmira i know
it's okay
yes this was the variation that we
analyzed and knight g5 where how did it
go i think it was just a little knight
65 rookie 2 and oh yeah like i think
there are numerous ways to maintain the
balance and well speaking of this
fearlessness you know with duda i
actually think that serves fabiano
particularly well against magnus and
um you know he's beaten magnus i think
it's five times in classical chess and
they drew all their games in the world
championship so i think that some people
you know are just fearless in general
and they may lose sometimes but
they just go for it whereas other people
they have like
there's just this magnetism this almost
fear when you there's the magnus effect
i mean it's it's i think a very real
thing that you get in this position
where if you played somebody else you'd
feel okay but you're playing magnus so
you're like scanning the board to wonder
where you're gonna be uh
exploited like which part of the board
so i think judas fearlessness is great i
think that other players have that as
well and there's a reason why you know
these eight players have made their way
here to madrid yeah
well said
is raja
considering whether he should play for a
win or not we'll uh we'll find out i
think we're more than likely with these
two gentlemen focused behind us
likely going to see the most forcing
line so while we wait for that we might
as well
let the fans see some fun that we've
been having around the city of course
this game not as fun as maybe it once
was right at the time control turning
point for dingley wren but we've had a
lot of fun in madrid and uh well here's
another example of uh of such such fun
that we got up to
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah yeah
you know
you don't know what it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you've watched the
queen's gambit me too okay you guys
actually play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 unleashes yeah so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership
not kidding he's going to be a contender
in like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use that
i'll go back to it yeah all right man oh
you're an am that's me man
he's like number one oh yeah the guy
that like beats yeah so this tournament
decides who plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much have fun so much see a great
trip guys there you go no drinking no
drinking i'm sure
still no drinking that's true you guys
are connected now yeah no we're buddies
on we're going to send each other some
ticks do you think they already talked
and then we'll we'll we'll talk about it
is that your phone blessing because they
are there they already yeah they're
already hitting me up for my digits okay
yep maybe wearing a pager wasn't the
smartest idea to fit in with them
[Music]
it's fun i'm nothing if i'm not a man of
the people
and the man of the pigeons man of the
pigeons that's right that was a lot of
fun i had some good conversations with
those pigeons
it's fun to have fun but you need to
know how another great quote from dr
seuss yeah you got to learn how to have
fun right i'm here what do you think
about that you want to join me in my
next journey through the city well i
definitely will you know i always
considered myself to be like mildly
insane but you know that now i
understand why you're keeping me in the
studio you know
so i just make it all legitimate you
know
robert what about you you want to what
do you want to do with the free days you
got we got many left i know you got here
late but we got a long way to go so what
are we going to do on our free days
first of all there's no we in this
equation
we're going to spend a lot but also can
we talk about what i want to talk about
you know what i want to talk about talk
about whatever you want i mean you see
in this video right these you're saying
the candidates like what's that
candid sounds like a tv show for like
job applications like each episode is a
new person interviewing for a job
so can we change the name that would be
funny can we get like a name you could
talk to after this world championship
qualifier something that would you she's
like oh what are you here for like i'm
here for the world champion qualifier
like whoa that makes sense that's cool
not wrong at all and it showed in that
video they're like what in the world is
the candidates
all right well we've got a future chat
he walks around giving out diamond
memberships i love it what else i got
nothing else to give out and of course
i'm going to thank you pleasers and i i
give away diamond memberships from
photoshop too man of the pigeons hess
was quick with that one also our
producers were quick to get that yeah
they're all over it our team is crushing
it behind the scenes we love you guys by
the way hey hey
okay that's hilarious one of the people
maybe in the video if not maybe a future
cut shout out to the editing team by the
way because we filmed hours and hours
and somehow they'd make it come together
in the best way possible stop bringing
this up somehow that you're going to
sing you know and we are going to it'll
be an email soon go ahead sorry you're
going to be singing oh that's right
that's oh man i can't forget
okay that's something we're going to be
doing in a future uh
future of rest day
elmira wow all right well we're back to
the chats we've had a couple of trades
followed by rook to e2
and i think that robert also had a few
suggestions uh well
for your repertoire it's not only justin
bieber
oh oh yeah okay but danny is on top of
this yeah we're gonna talk about that
anyway off air and then we'll see where
we go with that robert knows all the
music i hate
and so he he would be a very dangerous
person to bring with me to a karaoke bar
um
rookie two's been played
we're
hey
i want to transition to karaoke players
as much as the rest
at this point there's not a lot to go
here but let's let's give a good
breakdown of of why this one is likely
to end in this perpetual
again the knight has to move so just
what knight you four right
taken in the obvious here the knight has
to move white's going to regain the pawn
because of the double attack
on g6 and a6
it would be wise for black to go for a
forcing threat to not lose a pawn
something like rook c2 comes to mind
because it threatens checkmate
right on that
might actually only has one move in the
position there's every other move loses
besides bishop g1
but after that's played
white is still going to win the pawn and
that but that's what got us to the
variation we did with 95. no but can we
continue like king of seven
i
once again i give a bit and then
robert's idea 95 knight f3 right that
that's what we looked at but the problem
is that as soon as the knight moves
roberto yeah so the bishop you know goes
away because the threads knight f3 which
hits the bishop and if the bishop moves
rook h2 would be checkmate so you'll
just lose a piece but if you move the
bishop away well not
yeah actually you can't go there because
there's actually a point to show another
um but
now you
land in a white wind but if you put the
bishop on c5 just away from this for a
second yeah the point is knight f3 it
looks like it's leading checkmate next
move with rook h2 mate but white can
push the pawn to g4 to give the g3
square to the king and this is how you
turn a position that should be an easy
draw into maybe a little bit of
difficulty well look at that
dingley wren
he's gonna take his bishop
he's
well no he's just going for a different
draw um i was like hold on
hold on
now he's starting to take the bishop and
we can get a very very forced line with
rook takes e6 knight takes c5
okay there's
actually i guess you just have to take
back it's actually funny you can't play
this this would be a recipe to lose and
then i can just move
for a second i thought the night was
pinned
but the rook is protected so
oops i just flipped the board
no never
that was a mouse like my apologies um
but
uh
after b takes c5
whatever happens here is just a draw
right yeah you you're gonna play king f7
so you take a6 you take c5 and now we
just have even material
the rook ending is ahead in fact dingley
rand immediately plays knight takes c5
which means we've
more than likely pretty much
agreed to the result on king f7
roger can play both rook c6 or brook
takes a6 but after he takes the pawn
well you know what's ahead chat
our fourth draw of the day unfortunately
not a not a day that didn't give us
fighting chess everyone so before
you hit the social media
talking to you levy rosman gotham chess
before you just keep complaining about
draws in top level chess levy why don't
you check yourself before you wrecked
yourself today was a good day elmira not
for dingley ren but not for dingley red
mill your thoughts i know you're
disappointed
dingley wren doesn't get the dub
and i think it's when you said that that
was the fourth draw of the day you know
i felt like what you know i felt like we
had so many you know decisive results i
was thinking about the game that fabiano
played against richard you know
oh no that was a draw
as well so yeah it's it's not the
feeling that i well that i get when i'm
thinking about today's games so
they were very hard fought
you know it's always interesting when
you see players leaving you know the
board and leaving the tournament hall
you would think that almost like
dingler played worse in this game based
on body language yeah he played the
better game between the two it just so
happened that in a critical moment he
let his advantage completely slip but
that's what happens in chess right
hikaru played
you know a better game than jana palmer
she did and jan was accurate when he
needed to be but jan's the one who's
very happy because he had a bad position
he ends with the half point that he
wanted so the players who actually had
the worst position today they can
breathe they can
go on tomorrow in the same exact
standing they entered today with
it is so weird the same result
for all eight players
yet some of them are feeling really good
about it and some of them are feeling
really bad about it and it's funny
because like hikaru i don't think i was
feeling really bad but he clearly was
dejected and knows that he spoiled an
advantage in the middle game dingley
runs body language said everything we
need to know about how he feels about
that game with her job off
uh
but
why don't we weigh in on the other two
that ended earlier um al mira will start
with your thoughts on ferocious draw
with judah again just didn't get enough
with the white pieces also time
management still an issue your thoughts
on what uh what went down between those
two
well
maybe he was not expecting such an um
short and easy draw today you know
but so more that i think about this game
i feel that's it's dawned on him how
difficult this tournament is you know
it's like especially you know when i
said that he was not smiling he left the
tournament hall immediately say
sort of realization you know this is not
going to be easy at all yeah
well i love what amir said about it's
dawning on farouja how difficult the
tournament is
let's expand on that point because you
said again
he got here by winning an open
tournament really borderline right and
he's never played this type of
competition in back to back-to-back
games and what does he need to do to
keep himself in the right mental state
yeah i think part of it's unfair to him
not from us but there's all of these
people out there who are putting the
weight of the world on his shoulders and
magnus did it himself magnus knows
exactly what he's doing when he's saying
this is my challenger and that's the
only person he's putting so much
pressure on ali ray's shoulders and it's
really difficult winning any game
against anybody in this tournament uh
doing it you know over the course of 14
rounds you said he the way he got here
in the
grand swiss he had a great performance
but he was often beating up on the 2670s
right if chess rating system not quite
the elite of the elite of chess great
players right but not the the dudas and
the carwanas in fact he lost to fabiano
in their head-to-head match so i think
that while alireza fuja is exceptional
he just can't possibly have the
experience because he's so young and it
doesn't mean he can't win this very
event he may go on to win it but i think
there's like these prognosticators who
just are like okay ali raza's gonna
continue beating everybody you heard
from the other top players they're like
um
but and not just from like a selfish
like no give me my chances but from like
a realistic perspective of what a lot of
these top players used to be that
prodigy and maybe not quite as much of a
prodigy as farouja but it's just
asking for so much for someone their
first candidates to suddenly just be
beating everybody left and right and
he's a minus scorer after five rounds
he does have a minor score after five
rounds and
he caught up with our own dina bell and
kaya after the game so let's see what
went down in that interview and how
perusa is feeling after this game
alive it's great to have you here
finally thanks for coming
how do you feel about today's game
yes it was a very um
interesting game
my opponent played a very solid line and
the game was very
dressed
and i couldn't really impress him a lot
so
in general how do you like being here in
madrid so far
yes it's okay um
it's
it's a good city and
i'm happy to be here and play yes
you had your birthday recently uh how
did you celebrate
i didn't have much time to celebrate it
was a very tough game
against richard so
nothing just sleeping but wasn't that a
great birthday present to save that game
against richard
yes you can put it that way i don't know
[Laughter]
there was a little bit of smiles there
from here but i'm here at the start of
you for sure kind of was right on point
to what you were saying about it just
doesn't seem like he's having very much
fun does he you know everything about
his body language as robert said that
shows that well it's not a bad
body language of a conqueror you know
it's like he's still struggling in this
tournament and i also feel that uh ali
rezain needs to win
in order you know to win again you know
he's fueling on his wins you know his
victory so he's he's really waiting for
this to happen yeah it's a good like you
said you have to win in order to win
again like you have to win to get back
on track right so
all right well uh that was good to catch
up glad dina caught up with him let's uh
catch up on where we stand after five
rounds everybody uh yonder pom nasheen
still the man to beat uh in fact
everything about the standings as far as
people's position pretty much remains
where it was as we headed into this
round robert yeah there are i'd say two
winners besides john deposit everyone
drew their games yeah but people who can
be very happy are rapport who drew five
out of the black pieces in a really
sharp game it was short but the length
of the game kind of belies how difficult
it was along the way and then young
chest of dude we just heard from alireza
who was saying i got nothing and you
know the point i was making earlier i
think can be summarized
to some extent otherwise is used to
overpowering people a la shaquille
o'neal style but now he's facing all the
other you know big boys where you can't
just like overpower them the same way
and
you know he's disappointed but on the
flip side of that game is yanchustav
duda who drew with the black pieces
without major difficulties and he
continues to be right there
behind the leader so you know
i mean you said it so a cat out of the
bag because we have conversations with
fabi
in our own way but bobby's been
impressed probably even said like young
chris of duda like seems to be informed
and he's preparing well choosing
openings well so i mean i will see if
that continues to be the case for him um
all right
we uh
need to turn to tomorrow
set the tone for what's
in store in round six
for java report right at the top
right that's uh one where you have
someone at the struggling right now at
the bottom but uh with the white pieces
against report for ruja caruana i think
is the matchup that we're all we're all
excited about uh
the youngster gets the white pieces but
against someone who he's lost two games
against
and then the nakamura ding game i mean i
but all of them actually napalm mashida
welcome to the candidates
i guess every game is interesting
right uh almira circle your favorite
matchup for tomorrow
well as much as i want uh
uh larissa ferguson to bounce back so
he's one of the red lanterns you know
this tournament it was very surprising
to me to to see that he's at the bottom
of the standings
but i think that uh we should
watch very closely nakamura ding and nip
will yan be able to increase his
or his advantage over the field
and
how aggressive is hikaru going to be
tomorrow
robert give me one game your favorite
game i'm gonna surprise you okay and i
was gonna pick this before you start
talking the game between the job of and
report okay because what reports showed
us today
was just stellar over-the-board
brilliance like the guy just came up
with his bishop c6 idea pushed his apon
made a complicated mess at a position
that looked like it was going downhill
for him quite quickly and he gets the
black pieces again and he's playing
somebody who clashes with him
stylistically jabba as we've seen here
today was not a particularly good effort
after the opening stage but he does have
this style that i think is particularly
annoying to deal with because he wants a
slight edge and he's willing to press
that advan advantage for like 70 moves
and for somebody like rapport i mean
that's not particularly fun so these two
you know they're not kind of the names
that everyone's looking at to win this
event but i'm curious to see if rapport
is here to stay and from rajabov's point
of view i'm wondering if he's ready to
finally get that first victory in a
classical game in three years okay
first victory in classical chess in
three years what a day that would be for
us tomorrow but all right
we've got another day tomorrow and after
that we have a rest day but not for our
chess fans around the world friday
brings us
a double header of action that starts
with the women's speed chess
championship
the quarterfinalists from last year
katarina lagno takes on the qualifier
from this year women's grand master
vantikra agrawal in a first round clash
it's the two seed versus the 15 seed and
it starts friday at 5 a.m pacific time
right after that we have the i'm not a
gm speed chess championship canty got by
shubalova then i ran into trent actually
outside the hotel here in madrid and he
was pumped for his match-up whoever wins
this of course will throw down against
eric rosen i hate that guy
in the final of the i'm not a gm scc um
it's like oh no where's my queen it's
like ugh
whatever eric
thanks for beating me
um
anyway
this this has been awesome
i know i acted like a child there yeah i
was happy to be back until that moment
so i'm so glad to have you back almira
it's it's uh we we've got a partner here
right we're not doing this thing solo
right it's good we got more help here
it's going to be great these long days
so thank you both again for a great day
the pressure is on robert now pressure's
on robert
thanks to the whole team here we're
going to call it a night here from
madrid that's the palacio de centonia we
see an interview going down right now as
we speak between dina and taymor we'll
have that one on there of course
tomorrow
it's round six from madrid as the
evening falls on round five it's been a
great day
from the 2022 feed a candidates
chess.com coverage continues tomorrow
like it always does and we will see you
then
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
you